et après cavalier A5
fou2 pour pouvoir venir en C4 ou en
B5 voilà donc juste j'ai vu que
peut-être eu un petit problème de son
donc je vous souhaite la bienvenue et et
aujourd'hui donc c'est la deuxème
journée des des
demi-finales demi-finale donc qui oppose
West à Nobe hier Nobe a gagné la
première manche et euh et donc so dans
l'obligation de gagner son match
aujourd'hui pourevenir à un partout et
s'offrir une troisième manche décisive
peut-être un petit peu plus tard dans la
soirée euh dans l'autre demi-finale on
ira voir un petit peu ce qui se passe
aussi si vous voulez à certain moment
euh c'est Magnus Carlsen qui affronte
euh Fabiano carwana mais Magnus l'a
emporté hier un petit peu contre le
courour du jeu même un petit peu
beaucoup mais
euh mais il mène au score et il est bien
parti donc pour se qualifier en en
finale donc euh voilà je vous disais
donc cette ouverture un petit peu
étrange choisie par So mais je pense
qu'il était pas particulièrement ravi de
euh de des positions qu'il obtenait
après E4 E5 dans les bah dans les parti
dière et donc là il a changé un petit
peu son son fusil d'épaule donc tout ça
c'est assez théorique encore même si
c'est bien sûr plus rare que que les
grandes variantes jouai après E4 ou D4
euh les blancs donc essayie de faire
pression sur sur ce centre noir ils ont
fait C4 bah l'idée c'est peut-être de
pouvoir ramener le cavalier en C2 et
puis de bah quand même mettre une
pression au centre le cavali C2 pourra
ensuite aider par
D4 éventuellement l'expansion et le
cavalier peut aussi venir en F3 par par
la suite donc nordbe qui
OK et a West jouer donc peut-être un
coup c C2 semblerait logique pour
ramener ce cavalier au bar le ramener
is donc ce cavalier mal placé mais le
cavalier A5 n'est pas génial non plus
hein il est venu en A5 justement pour
stopper l'arrivée du C C4 donc et l'un
et l'autre se marque un petit peu à la
culotte qui a essayé de été jouer et je
m'attends un coup peut-être comme comme
tour 8 ici qui qui a l'air pas bête ça
met une tour en jeu et aussi ça va
permettre au f D6 mal placé de
potentiellement aller en F8 pour pouvoir
ensuite jouer avec D5 et libérer
finalement tout le tout le jeu noir
alors après ça va ressembler à une
position peut-être de de 6 si inversé
euh si inversé
ouais parce que c'est comme s'il y avait
eu E4 au premier coup et C5 une c un
petit peu bizarre si vous voulez mais
mais ça pourrait ressembler à ça en tout
cas quiess de jouer et un nordibbe de
réfléchir mais ch intéressant un on de
la part de sa qui comme je vous le dis a
besoin de s'imposer pour revenir dans ce
match donc il suit pas les les sentiers
battus et il tente quelque chose dès la
première partie il attend pas d'être
complètement dos au mur pour pour réagir
euh alors je vais aller voir un petit
peu ce que vous dites dans le chat
j'allume tout ça keV me rejoindra un
petit peu plus
tard hop voilà j'ai coupé le
son donc K6 jouer par paratf donc oui
bon ben lui aussi he il trouvait que son
cavalier là-bas était plutôt hors jeu et
il il le ramène en qu' avait pas là il
est là il est là mais il arrivera
euh il va pas tarder ne vous inquiétez
pas et j'essaie de gérer au mieux
pendant ce temps-là donc D4 jouer parce
qui met ce pion au centre alors
maintenant unb de voir sil prend ou s
défend son son centre avec un coup comme
tour 8 en cas de prise j'imagine que
Wesley aura le choix reprendre du pion
il se fait un centre pas trop mal et il
voudra suivre après F3 et petitck soit
peut-être même en qure prises il
pourrait prendre du cavalier pourer la
diagonale ouverte alors le seul truc un
petit peu désagréable si on joue comme
ça c'est qu'on toère fou B4
échec fou B4 échec on a rien à opposer
et le roi devrait bouger donc je suis
d'avis qu'après eu prend des4 il
reprennent du pion e qui crée un joli
centre qui fasse vite F3 vite petit rock
et après il verra s'il joue une
expansion avec des 5 pour prendre de
l'espace chasser ce cavalier ouvrir la
diagonale pour son fou et cetera et puis
à noter queun fois qu'on a pris de la
case de 3 du coup deviendrait vacante et
le cavalier pourrait bondir dessus puis
peut-être vers D5 vers F5 et et suivre
suivre son chemin
euh donc en fait je suis pas convaincu
hein que quebe doivent prendre bon il a
pris et comme je disis je meends prend
ça a été fait instantanément par Wesley
euh donc à mon avis les blancs leur plan
ça de vite continuer le développement
vite C F3 petit rock et après voir s'ils
font cavalier3 dans un deuxième temps ou
D5 selon ce que font les Noirs mais je
pense Wesley peut être plutôt plutôt
content de de ce qu'il a fait dans
l'ouverture euh voilà c'est pas il a pas
un gros avantage mais il une position où
il s'est pas fait sécher tout de suite
son adversaire doit réfléchir d'ailleurs
regardez il y a 4 minutes d'avance à la
pendule donc il peut aussi mettre une
petite pression au temp donc choix choix
intéressant d'avoir joué ce ce B3 au
premier coup l'verture nimzoarsen allez
je vous remonte le début pour ceux qui
étaient pas là donc il a joué avec B3 au
premier coup E5 fou B2 attaque le pion
cavalier C6 le défend E3 pour développer
ce fou et aller en B5 un peu comme les
Espagnols pour faire pression sur ce
cavalier attaquer le pion mais pendant
ce temps les Noirs ont quand même le
temps de se développer fou ici donc
voilà ça menace de prendre et de prendre
et donc pour défendre soit on fait des6
soit on fait fou des6 comme l'a fait
nierbeck qui est un peu étrange parce
que ça bloque ce pion pour développer le
fou mais l'idée des Noirs c'est de
roquer et de réenlever ce fou par la
suite alors soit avec tour E8 et fou E7
soit enlever ce cavalier faire C6 le fou
B5 devra rentrer chez lui faire fou C7
et D5 mais sa connaissait et a fait
cavalier A3 avec les venir ici profiter
de se fou mal placer cavalier a 5 jouer
donc pas mal de coups bizarres mais en
fait facilement comprensible une fois
qu'onon sait ce qui se passe hein et
donc on en est là il vient de jouer k B4
il aimait bien avoir un échange pour
faire foupran et faire échec et des
roqueteri mais à mon avis
Westley soit jouer F3 soit A3 comme ça
en cas de prise dame prend euh il y aura
un pion A3 qui contrôlera la ce B4 soit
même peut-être encore mieux j'ai envie
dire peut-être cavalier
E3 cavalier E3 qui euh refuse l'échange
replace le cavalier au centre ce
cavalier E3 capable peut-être de bondir
vers F5 par la suite de la partie et on
laisse ce cal en B4 un peu tout seul et
on sera prêt à le chasser par A3 un peu
quand on veut d'ailleurs voilà c'est ce
que Westley choisit de faire ce coup
cavalier 3 donc cavalier 3
et Abdou de de réfléchir à ce qu'il
compte jouer mais je trouve qu'il est un
peu englué avec ses pièces hein ce
cavalier pour l'instant il a pas été
très heureux dans ses dans ses choix et
je rappelle son trajet k C6 k A5 k C6
retour k B4 il risque de se faire
chasser de retourner en C6 pour la 3è
fois de la partie en moins de 15 coups
euh et du coup s D6 bon ça est il faut
le bouger c'est bien il l'a fait bah il
gêne ce pond donc de partir c'est bien
ça va peut-être l'aider à faire D6 ou D5
à mon avis il aimerait faire des5 il
aimerait faire des5 pour bah mettre un
pion au centre et permettre de terminer
le développement avec ce fou C8 qui
pourra s'ouvrir le long de la diagonale
ici A3 jouer donc pour chasser ce
cavalier qui repart et peut-être il va
encore gagner un tempo avec des 5 voilà
c'est fait de la part de Westley qui
joue donc pour un avantage d'espace et
qui euh qui active son fou alors dessus
maintenant choix pour les Noirs soit
cavalier E5 à priori soit fou E5 fou E5
on qui part pas la menace mais qui fait
une contremenace sur le fou B2 donc si
on prenait ce cavalier le fou E5
pourrait prendre le notre en B2 et donc
sur fou E5 il faudrait peut-être les
changer euh après à voir ce qui se passe
mais je serai plutôt partisan d'un coup
comme F 5 à première vue pour échanger
et museler ce ce fou B2
euh fou B2 qui est
euh ah qui qui qui est potentiellement
dangereux quoi j'ai envie de
dire
vous l'attendez tous l'arrivée de
kèeve je pas mattend fa là je pense
qu'ils attendent surtout la compétition
mon Fab là c'est c'est tellement
intéressant tu as plus besoin du
streamer tu pourrais quasiment partir et
moi aussi que ouais on laissera les Ch
l'intérêt serait quasiment le même voire
même peut-être encore supérieur les
échecs parlent de même ouais ouais
clairement il se passe quoi alors FA bah
il a joué B3 premier coup pour je pense
qu'il était mécontent un peu de ce qu'il
obtenir avec E4 cétait rien il a même
souffert avec les Blancs et ben écoute
petite position sympa il est pas mal il
a fou de Kayon donc ouis il a pris des
cours avec sardoch quoi pendant la nuit
il a regardé les Liv vill de la SMR
rosal il a vu les pompes et tout il
s'est dit très bien et ouais là je me
disais peut-être fou E5 pour pour pas
tolérer ce fou B2 qui peut faire très
mal par la suite il ser pas juste mal
avec les Noirs là ouais c'est pas pas
ouf ouf ce qu'il a fait mais bon il a
pas vu la vidéo de matthie cornet
peut-être entre les parties Matth cornet
against be non il a joué la vieille
ligne principale
euh et issu alors qu'il fallait faire
les nouvelles lignes principales tuas
dit quoi dans le chat le chat pas
grandchose le chat ne dit pas
grand-chose ah il dis quand même oh le
caot yo le
B tu as mis le
kimono CHC ils ont fait un petit un
petit short alors j'ai pas regardé j'ai
juste vu le titre tellement de trucs
mais firouj qui a mieux kimono ah ils
ont fait ça
ouais mais qui fait yuken je sais pas il
faut qu'on regarde la vidéo mais ils ont
fait un
short comm français hein oui ben je
comprends bien de base je pensais que
c'est les autres mais bon une fois que
j'ai entendu bon je B non ça peut pas
être les
serait tellement beau qu' joue et
tuarrête
mieux bon benelle parti en tout cas pour
le Fab ouais ouais intéressant
intéressant mais ouais comme je dis
ouais il a joué la vieille manière de
jouer avec ce fou des 6 là qui bloque
tout mais moi j'avais déjà joué comme ça
en 2003 donc c'était genre moderne à
l'époque mais ils ont trouvé mieux
maintenant c'est terrible on est tous
les deux à plus rien voir je suis obligé
de de m'approcher de ah ouais voir mais
toi aussi là je je suis sur mon bon il
ouais je suis très bien
[Musique]
là B si on peut mettre là et puis non
non mais on est trait bien aussi
enfin les gre c'estant parce
que avant c'est moi je voyais bien Mo je
vois plus toi tu étais avec tes lunettes
tu étais bien mais tu vois plus vraiment
non plus ouais on voit de moins en moins
quoi bientôt live les lunettes comme ça
et la loupe quoi des de
glace regard les positions oui bon
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué je pas vraim vu
bouger quoi à B3 comme dans tournée
ménage
[Rires]
quoi j'entends le bruit de la mousse ah
tu vois plus mais tu entends
toujours encore j'entends
encore
profitesen la de F c'est du veu lourd tu
vois pour le moment on peut encore
parler mais tu sais j'ai remarqué c'est
terrible les cheveux h moi ça fait
longtemps que j'en ai plus mais non mais
oui to tu l'expérience mais tu sais j'ai
j'ai remarqué que en parlant de de
vieillesse désolé he de pour les plus
jeunes mais on parle un peu de de nos
problèmes
mais mais tu sais j' reg pour la BUP
genre quand il y avait j'avait l'eau tu
sais qui m'était tombé dessus quand je
suis Allis prendre la photo ouais bah en
fait du coup tu vois j'ai les cheveux
comme ça ça là ça mais mais regarde là
il y en a plus du tout
mais genre vraiment loin en fait et là
non plus ouais moi je suis né comme ça
en fait donc ça m'impressionne pas trop
mais ouais mais ça genre petit à petit
je commence à enfin bientôt on est pas
enfin tu vois il me quitte quoi mais tu
compte me rattraper quoi tu as du boulot
mais ouais mais ça avance ouais mais
c'est
bien donc Dame des 4 on parle nos
problèmes de vieux les amis jeis me
faire couper les cheveux tout à l'heure
un
peu je crois que
jeis un endroit que où tu
allais par hasard endroit vert je sais
pas comment ça s'appelle ni rien on
demande qu'est-ce que tu fais ou quoi je
dis des échecs machin ah ouais mais puis
bon il pensa que tu appelis Julien
c'est mon
cousin bon je sais pas trop puis après
il cons me dire ouais il est grand il
est brun il est maigre machin enfin j'ai
compris ça parlait de toi quoi ENF un
moment on me suis bon bah oui c'est
Kevin en fait alors et euh c'est un
endroit je vais aller avant ouais a
priori donc tu as le bonjour mais il y a
longtemps ou enfin ça sentait qu' me
vivait pas longtemps ou pas moi au moins
un an quoi ouais c'est un j'avais
avant donc voilà
ah je sais où c'est mais ils sont pas
mal de toute façon j'ai pas demandé un
truc
de
blunderer qui pensait qu'on pouvait
assister au match mais en fait les seuls
tickets qu'il vendait céit pour cet
événement c'était pour la Fan Zone avec
les bras est- normal alors je sa pas si
c'est normal mais c'est ce qu'ils ont
prévu en tout cas oui je peux pas avoir
accès à la salle de jeu tu as le
seum B dir rien je pense qu'il aurait
bien aimé être voir un peu les joueurs
en action et en fait bah juste ouais tu
es dans une sorte de barre et
euh tu as les bras qui qui doivent
danser sur de la techno en même temps
que ça joue je pense après ils sont
sympas les bras non je sais je rigole je
c pourquoi il fait pas c G6 en fait euh
ben il a pas trop le choix mais ouais
mais il doit faire c'est pour ça je Veen
pr réfléch aussi longtemps parce qu'en
fait quand il a fait dame D4 on a rien
dit parce enfin dans ma tête c'était qu'
enfin bah peut-être qu' F prend 3 je
sais pas en sinon c'est le seul de coup
euh il va se faire défoncer là pourrait
envisager mais
bon
G4 tu vas te faire mat ser peut-être la
partie qu'on fera demain ah très bien
très belle partie
ça ça t sa
position il il a pris de la dame pas du
F
bizarre pas repris de non je sais pas
c'est moi qui dit ça peutêtre que c'est
très bien de la
dame j'aisardé ma petite batterie non
maisens je pousse tout mais là c'est pas
malard4 pour dégager 5 si
j pris il est
G6
H4 gagant a
blan
je pense qu'il va le défoncer non bah ça
serait mérité au vu de de l'entame de
match mais c'est VO je peux revoir le
début tu peux je suis curieux
ok ah il a joué ce truc là ouais mais
encore qu' à 5 ça va mais je sais pas où
il s'est trompé exactement en fait à si
peut-être déjà c'est bizarre je sais pas
euh mais là peut-être tour 8 ou enfin il
y a des coups en fait mais là ce qu'il a
fait c'est juste ça c'est échanger
d'ailleurs il a aidé les blancs si tu F
la case 3 c'est nul en fait ce qu'il a
fait là il là il est déjà pas trop bien
ok ouais mais en plus c'est hyper
bizarre parce que tu as fait 1 2 3 4
c'est ex le dessin que j'ai fait et pour
retourner
ouis mais c'est ridicule ce qu'il a fait
ben oui oui non ça se voit visuellement
que c'est pas bien après il bah comme
d'hab on le connait il va se battre il
va mettre des Barbel tant qu'il peut
mais il a raté son son entam de partie
surpris par ce B3 et et forcément les
joueurs quand ils sont moins à l'aise
avec les ouvertures ils peuvent aussi
partir à la faute comme monsieur et
madame tout le
monde puis il a plus de temps il va il
va justeer en plus à CH il va devoir
refaire cavalier au 5 mais attends ce
cavalier c'est qu'il a fait quoi il a
fait ça 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8/ 17 un coup sur
deux c'est un coup de C il va il va se
prendre ça enfin ouais
ça va continuer bon peut-être H6 pour
bien empouer cas noir avant que les
Noirs puissent peut-être le faire
eux-même et bon il serait toujours pas
trop bien mais euh non mais H6 c'est sûr
ouais tu gagnes les cases noires vu
qu'il a pas de fou et puis
tu jeande si je fais pas H6 je voulais
faire H6 G6 dame D4 je déjà F4 cavalier
G4 F prend G4 et une pièce et si tu fais
F4 qui D7 je fait G4 g G5 et ça clou
tout j'aurais bien garder juste mon
cavalier en G protéger le fou et juste
gagner avec sur la diagonale mais
d'ailleurs moi ce que j'aurais vraiment
fait sur le D5 au 13e coup c'est fou 5 5
ah oui mais tu as raison je pense tu es
sûrement peut-être moins bien mais après
ça ça a dû le saouler hein ok mais je je
préfère ça
oui non mais j'aurais fait ça aussi mais
g non mais il a raté il a raté mais un
moment une fois que tu es comme ça tu
ouais tu tentes ça et tu dis tuasens de
faire F enfin ouais tuuras ton P d'
isolé tu es moins bien et puis puis tu
es moins bien mais ouais B bref euh H5
tout ça k 5 touours westler on s'attend
à h6 de sa part pour aller vraiment
affaiblir les cases noires c'est une
jolie partie en tout casin ouis c'est
vraiment un modèle de ce qu'il faut pas
faire avec les Noirs mais c'est pour ça
que Vlad il m'a toujours dit tu fais ça
ça ça ça euh oui il est le plus simple
c'est G6 fou G7 il t'oppose l'autre il
t'oppose
l'autre après je sais que D5 ça va au
non non je sais mais il m'a toujours dit
ça enfin tu fais ça ça il t'attaque tu
fais ça il fait ça j avec des6 ou tu
échanges ou tu peu importe tu fais ça
enfin ce que j'ai retenu je sais plus
comment il joue avec les blancs mais en
gros quand il fais ça tu fais ça
HM même si là va te bouffer le pion
ouais c'est ça enfin c'est j'ai jamais
rien appris hein mais il m'a dit oui et
important enfin tu connais Vlad tu n'as
rien à savoir juste que tu dois savoir
c'est que quand
il 5 fait des 6 et il est là il est
cloué et il se marre en plus quand il
dit ça et là tu es cloué mais alors
parce qu'il y a une théorie de Vlad
alors c'est hyper important comme
théorie bon là il fait il fait ce qu'on
dire mais j'en profite hein et je la
redis à Fab c'est théorie de Vlad et
c'est un grand joueur de fianqueto c'est
quand il y a deux fianqueto qui se font
face le fianqueto devant le rock est
supérieur parce que le roi protège le
fou et donc que tu as des tactiques à
base de E4 h et c'est pour ça que quand
tu fais cavalier F3 bah du coup B6 G3
fou B7 fou G2 c'est très grave pour les
Noirs donc parce que ton foup parce que
ton fou2 est supérieur parce que tu vas
faire petit rock et tu auras la priorité
sur toutes les
tactiques donc ça peut aller mais tu
dans l'autre cas de figure que si jamais
tu mets ton cavalier devant que lui peut
bouger son cavalier et te clouer en bon
voilà c'est ce que m'a pris Vlad et donc
il te dit que B3 E5 très bien pour faire
G6 fou G7 et du coup tu as le tu as la
priorité bon ça vaut ce que ça vaut ENF
c'est Vlad c'est bon là c'est la partie
exactement ce qu'on vous disait Dame des
grand D7 il va uneèceà ouais c'est
abandon en
fait théorie de Vlad he non très
intéressant je sais pas ce que ça
vaut mais F4 en fait c'est juste abandon
non ah il veut qu' C5 ouais mais bon
est-ce qu'on a pas même dame C3 je sais
pas je fa ouais ce que j'avais dire
enfin c'est ah il qu'
qure et je pas tour pas
prend non mais bien bien ouais comme ça
il prend son B3 Bou la dame dégage pu en
plus tu lui réappuies sur5 derrière bon
il va essayer hein mais après ça se trou
tu vux me faire B4 comme ça il VI pas te
faire chi F6 ou mais bon tu vas tu vas
faire F4 fais Caval F7 oui bon j'ai 4 g
ouais c'est écrasant mais bon je pense
j'is prendre le matériel perso mais ça
ça l'
intéressant j'aié non mais belle partie
pour le coup dire se fait un peu grand
maître contre amateur quoi
ouais je me souviens on avait fait une
vidéo il y a longtemps déjà maintenant
sur ça sur exactement c'est devant k 3
Christian Boer premier rond des
Olympiades ou quoi contre un péruvien
paragu mais bon le mec était 2002 ou
2003 c'est pas
ou je crois que cette ancienne variante
c'est vraiment pas le meilleur moyen non
mais comme je dis moi je jouais ça je
sais que je l'ai joué en 2003 côté
noir un mec qui joue que B3 mais
maintenant encore quoi c'est un vieux hi
colombien maintenant à l'époque il était
pas si vieux mais peut-être qu'il avait
mon âge de maintenant quoi et pour te
dire à quel point il était vieux et et
et déjà il faisait que B3
quoi c un temps à fermer que je faisais
un Salou en Espagne jolie ville Salou
sympa ville touristique ville de fête
ville de fête de
samba belle boîte de nuit à Salou Fab il
y a toujours il ex toujours ce
tournocheèque à Salou bah là en fait
quand j'avis fait c un tour fermé mais
sinon euh
bah il a trouvé hein bravo Wesley euh
j'avis fait l'Open quelque fois
et je pense je l'ai pas fait peut-être
de depuis so 2008 2009 2010 par là quoi
il y a un petit moment je le vois pas
pas forcément annoncé encore maintenant
mais mais il y a tellement de tournoir
en
Catalogne ça serait pas étonant qu'il a
quand même quelque chose mais bon
peut-être
que j' jou l' Open de taragona qui pas
pas loin ouis ville voisine c'est qui
qui jouait dans un dans le port là ils
avaient un
grand le port de taragon dans le port de
taragon ils ont un grand g entre
guillemets mais qui éta un peu tu vois
réutilisé en en salle qui a qui qui est
assez assez agréable aussi j'aime bien
les les tour en Espagne sonv bien
organisé oui en ce moment il y a l'Open
important d'ailleurs pour la course au
candidat à l'Open de cess et et tu as vu
Dominguez qui jouait contre un gars à
1900 ho ah mais pere ça va rien lui
rapporter ça oui en plus il a le se
parce que le mec a gagné à 2003 et
2450 mais ça il a 12 ans ou il oui sur
de 12 ans ouais donc il dois jouer à 25
déjà enfin 184
8 va faire la course au candidats tiens
vas-y va t'amuser
à non dominas pas de chance non mais
c'est dur les open l je connais oui mais
bienvenue dans la réalité quoi c'est pas
juste de jouer tes petits potes à 2007
contre qui tu peux faire des nuls en
répétant tes variantes c'est tu joues tu
joues chaque jour contre des gens sous
classés et tu tu tu comm faire
connaissance avec les Indiens quoi après
aurait peut-être du commencer avec zé
sur 3 et après remonter aussi bien joué
au début du coup
ouais il sera arrivé non mais il aura
quand même perdu des points ouais
malheureusement donc lui Ctait pas trop
son objectif ouais c'est une bonne
technique parce que générement quand tu
perds les premières parties après tu
compre des mecs g moins fort ouais vu
qu'ils ont fait Z0 sur 3 normalement
c'est pas des gées bah tu Vaas pas avoir
l'Indien à 2 sur de a 1800 non ça c'est
sûr quand tu as zéro sur zéro là tu peux
te prendre la balle perdue ah merde mais
là hier je sais pas ce que valit
l'Américain qui l' j mais je vais
regarder tiens par curiosité sa position
à Dominguez c'est quand même intéressant
ouais
euh on va aller sur ch
EV en tout cas Abdou qui essaye bon bien
sûr il a perdu une pièce donc il est pas
bien lae de chesscom elle est souvent
pas très gentil pour celui qui a
l'avantage fait si tu fais tour sur ton
ordi va déjà te mettre plus su ou un
truc comme ça mais bon là il tente tu
vois ENF il vise le roi adverse il
essaie d'ouvrir B5 il veut faire tour B8
fa F5 il envoie ses ses petites pièces
bah écoute il est il joue à 1800 et il
su il su il est un peu mieux à la sortie
de l'ouverture dire c'est pas c'est loin
d'être fait
mais il va ah mais c'est pas mal contre
un indien ça c'est stratégique tu as ta
cas tu as des trucs enfin c'est parfait
il va la gagner mais B tu le fais pas
calculer à te prendre des trucs c'est
hyper bien de jouer des des positions
comme ça techniques jeux montrer la
position il a les blancs C D5 tout ça
oui mais genre c'est ah oui mais c'est
pas un 1800 que tu balayes enre tu es
obligé de faire ça pour gagner à 1800
c'est ben non mais c'est que le mec est
pas vraiment 1800
mais mais il gagne quoi il gagne 02
probablement non mais là je crois qu'il
gag peut-être même zé enfin c'est le
nvelle manière de compter les points ho
tu te fais complètement baiser
maintenant en plus il est au blanc
ouais noir à la prochaine non mais c'est
absolument honteux qui est pas 0,8 à
chaque fois comme c'était le cas avant
et c'est tout autant honteux qu'ils
essaient de rattraper le coup en faant
plus 400 point en fait c'est le truc
anglais to wrong doesn't make one right
en fait tu as fait une connerie tu es
pas de refaire une deuxième truc une
deème connerie ou truc injuste pour
essayer de rattraper enfin c'est souvent
j'entendais ça au foot c'est quand tu
siffles un penalty qui a pas c'est pas
de donner un autre penalty qui a pas à
l'adversaire tu après quand Mme parf
tuas des équipes qui ont des penalties
dans certains matchs à 94e minute qui ne
devrait pas avoir tu pourrais dire tien
après ils sont à
l'extérieur une autre équipe au hasard
allemande on sait pas bon avec un
maillot jaune maot jaune pourussi avoir
un P 94 quiupère 21 là çaura fait oneou
c'est ça tu repèes le point que tu
aurais pas dû avoir et bon ben il se
trouve qu' une équipe
italienne rouge et noir complètement
hasard là qui du coup serait qualifié
alors bon on sait pas pourquoi voilà bon
tout ça
reste ouais
et on me demande si je faire l'OP non je
vais pas jouer je prévois plus de jouer
en fait
j'aurais pas de à Montpellier j'aurais
pas d' open plus ou moins nulle part en
fait Tura fallu 40 ans pour le
comprendre mais ça y est quoi tuas assez
évolué pour comprendre c'était
complètement de la
merde al double attaque on va faire dame
3 j'imagine pour faire double défense
là il y a quand même un piège quoi dame
D4 ah oui faire attention et encore tu
peut-être x 2 et puis ça se trouve ça va
quoi c'est mérité TB de qui
te c'est beau quoi même le pire
coupame 3 il défend tout en tout cas il
défend son C 5 son pion à
3 mais Abdou vraiment il serait capable
d'arnaquer beaucoup de joueurs même dans
des positions comme ça ça se sent qu'il
est hyper mais il est il est fin s mis
sur ses appuis il pr à bondir propose
TB3 le côté c'est le côté
Puma c'est c'est un genre de Puma de
toute
façon son équipementtier il fait fou
f5er ce cavalier de E5 à un moment comme
ça on aa des dames 8 il menace là il
menace en fait tour B3 ouais il tour B3
F prend B3 d dame prend à 3 et dame
prend d Pr 5 tu es obligé de faire roi
B2 k C3 tu l'as donné ta dame mais bon
là il peut faire k C6 et du coup tour B3
dame8 ou tour c'est bien aussi par que
ça défend le cavalier sur d' pr
b3eoui juste mais ah oui parce que l' tu
aurais tourb de mat
encore donc bien joué C chin de westel
qui menace peut-être aussi juste de
bouger le cavalier un peu partout pour
avir du dame
8 mais tu vois je sais pas il a des
coups
tu
il veut t'embrouiller mais il embrouille
réellement alors que peuttre ils ont
fini dans l'autre match son de se mettre
devant la camé de partout
okour s la fin ce sera la partie de
demain fa magnifique c'est un modèle
stratégique il va falloir lâcher ça côté
Abdou
peut-être fait F6
échec bon t D4
moi j'aurais fait dame5 dame D4 ouais en
fait j'avais oublié quand j'ai proposé
mon coup qu'on attaqu la T
B8 moi je voulais même faire juste
cavalier prend enfin moi je juste ça
quoi prends la
gardeendour fais-moi encore des AR si tu
veux
tiens3
encore en victoire et dans l'autre
partie dans l'autre partie ok qui avait
les blancs Carlson avait les blancs ok
bon carwana qui va tenter son son vatou
avec les blancs dans les prochaines
rondes alors j'ai une très bonne
nouvelle à t'annoncer dis-moi tout comme
Wesley avait perdu le premier set et que
là il gagne ouais on a vu sa victoire là
dans la première partie ça augmente les
chances qu'il gagne le deuxième set bien
évidemment ou donc un 3è set donc ça
augment les chances de 3è set tout à
fait ah mais ça je m'y attends enfin oui
mais j'espère j' que tu te délectes je
me délecte et puis peut-être 3è sera
tellement serré qu'on aura un arm
àagedon ça ce serait génial là au moins
bon on est là jusqu pas trop rêver je
veux pas trop rêver bon les amis attends
je vais ouvrir un chat ici quand même
oui comme ça on peut voir ce que vous
nous
dites j'ai pas envie de rêver trop fort
Fab mais là c'est vrai qu'on est bien
parti pour avoir TR set et puis qui sait
si fait 2 de avec 4 nuls un Armagedon
là-bas oui et c'est pas grave parce
Queen fait même si on a un deuxè un
trème set de l'autre côté même si
finissait avec un score genre 2 21 bon
score vraiment
enfin terrible ou on aurait l'ARM Magon
de l'autre côté voilà voilà c'est ça
c'est quand même donc on peut peut-être
peut-être si on rêve voir 5 et h parties
aujourd'hui ouais c'est vrai en plus
c'est pas
mal va se délecter non mais là pour nous
franchement c'est le f ça commence très
bien bravo très bon choix et on ver peut
réagir ou
pas petite n dans la prochaine ça serait
pas mal pour nous reste à la des nul de
partout la proch ser bien ou peut-être
victoire de Carana
pour allez à tout de suite les tout à
l'heure
sharpen your performance change the game
with air things a new opening for your
wall is here capture new major pieces on
unique metal posters from displate now
with the official collection from
Chess.com Mount them in seconds with a
toolf magnet kit and swap them whenever
you like make your move get an exclusive
discount on all metal postersop now with
the code
displate.com
[Musique]
ch
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça ça repart alors attends ça repart pas
des deux parties en même temps en fait
ouais ils ont ils ont changé le truc
j'ai l'impression que c'est l'autre qui
repart avant Fab ouis ouais d'habitude
cétait Carl qui en premier on s'est fait
dépasser par par la minute de délai mais
on a rien raté parce que je peux je peux
t'expliquer l'ouverture si tu veux Fab
ok vas-y je veux bien que tu m'expliques
par attend mettre du bon côté et oui
parce que sinon
tu tu sais pas ah bah des4 D5 déjà c'est
moi mon domaine
hein tu as jamais des4 D5 de ton côté
non ça m déjà arrivé mais alors D4 D5 il
veut prendre le cent tu prends le centre
aussi c'est facile non mais après C4 C6
donc la SA k S3 cavalier F6 cavalier F3
euh dernièrement il y a un peu de E3 qui
est populaire mais bon il font cavalier
F3 ou en fait ce font E3 ils veulent pas
avir dépanés quoi ouais donc cavalier F3
ils veulent pas avoir dépensé mais il
joue E6 grande variante de la semilave
sur quoi il a jouer E3 fou G5 c'est
peut-être le coup le principal mais E3
c'est très fort aussi cavalier BD7 et
fou D3 donc c'est vraiment la grande
variante man de chez Méran à l'ancienne
d prend C4 tu prends il prends euh
B53 et là maintenant il font un nouveau
coup alors j'avais déjà vu c'est fou D6
c'est ça on faisait soit a pour faire C5
soit fou B7 pour faire B4 et C5 et
plutôt a 6 d'ailleurs qui était mie Plô
a 6 puis après c'était un peu fou B7
c'était un petit peu les deux mais en
gros avec vraiment dans les deux cas
jouer C5 pour a donc c'est de faire C5
B7 c'est B4 C5 et de reprendre en d'un
seul coup avec le fou mais ils se sont
mis un peu à faire du fou des6 je l'ai
vu dans la base il y a pas longtemps
regardant et c'est un coup qui m'a
plutôt surpris parce qu'avant c'est un
coup qu'on considérait même pas en fait
bah normalement c'était moins l'idée
mais j'imagine que F des6 bah soit tu
peux quand même partir sur les plans don
tu parlais soit tu peux jouer pour E5 tu
tu es peut-être plus souple ou alors
qu'à l'époque on pensait que tu allais
faire fou B7 tour C8 et que tu allais tu
pouris tu aurais jamais le temps de
faire C5 en
fait en fait tu peux sement que les
nouveaux modules ont montré qu'en fait
ça tient parce que ça tient et que c'est
comme ça mais tout ça pour te dire
qu'historiquement c'est pas censé être
bien mais que finalement c'est bien non
mais je sais moi quand j' regardé ça
allez cétait pareil il y a 20 ans euh
j'avais regardé à 6
ouais c'était à 6 avant le coup après
fou B7 c'est un peu venu quand même
ouais ben je sais que c'est un coup que
toi tu tu aimais bien fou B7 d'ailleurs
quand on a fait nos stages t'en parlais
c'était un peu plutôt fou B7 le truc que
tu qu'on avait montré a c'est bien en
fait c'est bien en fait fou B7 mais du
coup tu vois moi comme je joue pas de
toute façon j'ai pas regarder plus que
ça et et aussi à un moment moi quand je
jouais un peu le Méran j'avais joué
aussi les Méran avec
A6 ouais c'est autre chose alors c'est
autre chose non mais je celui-là j'avais
regardé j'avais joué un peu mais le
meant avec ass6 après dans un deuxème
temps j' joué mais c'est le A6 bien plus
tôt hein avec le F F8 alors maintenant
de toute façon la plupart ils te font ça
ça et 3
ça tu fais ça ils font ça et tu il ils
on bouffer le fou ouais il faut bien
connaître avec les Noirs sinon tu es
très mal
moi j'ai jamais été fan de ça mais
problème c'est que moi j'étais jamais un
vrai joueur de slave je pense jouer à 6
moi et leur idée si tu fais aussi c'est
de mettre le calier en D2 ouais et comme
ça après il faut
pr C4 ils vont fout des TR 4ou alors tu
peux sûrment jouer des trucs avec C5
avec les noirs ou je ne sais quoi mais
ouais
chose juste bon par les vent sch avec G6
j'en ai vu il y a pas longtemps mais moi
j'ai jamais aimé mais je suppose qu'en
fait sur ça ça et ça tu peux
complètement jouer G6 si tu veux F G7 F
G4 tu donnes ton fou tu feras6 après et
tu non mais tu peux c'est pas trop mon
goût mais tu
peux
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ça joué
de trois coups dame C2 fou B7 G5 H6
caval4 F7 ouis mais tu vois avant on
avait je sais plus c'était exactement ça
laante mais tu sens bien que le F en D6
avant à l'époque quand s les ordis on
Taurait dit très graveah ça paraî qu' en
D6 pour te
retrouver tu vas te faire V en C5 ton
fou sera mauvais mais juste en fait si
tu peux pas viser C5 blan ont pas le
temps de faire B2 B4 bon ils ont pas le
temps fait F mais ils a bien faire à B4
et sur a 5 ver tour B1 et tout ça et là
les blanc seraient beaucoup mieux bah
voilà il essaye on on va avoir notre
réponse je c'est à 5 ou je sais pas
enfin il doit savoir sa de toute façon
apparemment d'après l'ordi c'est 5
direct quand même
ok qui B
5 on va voir la partie mais ouais
c'est très concret tout ça parce que moi
je vois ça je vois juste j'ai un pion de
Mo mais il a fait à 5 bon c'est le coup
que j'aurais jouer moi en fait et là ok
bon peu importe C8 pour préparer B4 C5
à voir façon si tu as le temps tu as le
temps
ouis non mais les Noirs c'est hyper
important qu'ils y arrivent s'ils y
arrivent il y aura normalement pas trop
de problème enfin au moins le position
ira ça veut pas dire qu'ils peuvent pas
quand même perdre d'une manire d'unutre
plus tard mais mais le problème
d'ouverture est résolu moi j'ai tours
pensé quand je jouis que quand je fais
c5fin c'est égal d'après la position
mais j'ai toujours pensé que c'est les
blancs qui risqu après ENF de mon
expérience c'est toujours les blancs qui
jouent pour nul après bah le truc c'est
que tu es content tu as déjà solutionné
ton premier problème et en fait d vir
d'un truc où tu es peut-être un peu
moins bien égal tu es sur le courant
ascendant donc tu as aussi un côté ouais
mais tu as l'impression de tuas un côté
je sais pas comment dire tu as la
confiance quoi c'est un peu comme dans
la calage quand tu fais des 5 en fait ça
se trouve il peut tout échanger ou quoi
mais je suis tellement content
que je me sens mieux en fait Mo j'étais
en partie j'éis toujours là après hyper
bien assis hyper concentré h tiens
regarde j'ai moin 01 maintenant tu vas
vraiment devoir défendre pendant
longtemps non mais tu tu as une euphorie
ouais c'est ça ou regarde mon fou en B7
il attaque
maintenant fou des deux il bouge pas non
en gros c'est égal
ouais fout des de en tout cas jouer par
donc il développe sa dernière pièce qui
se donne la caisse C1 pour mettre une
tour je assez logique je me suis fait
défoncer par un certain Lévon à rogant
il y a pas si longtemps là il y a 10
jours c pas une slaveoué ouais en title
on s retrouvé avec cette structure il
m'a foutu un C en C5 rev il est Fortan
oua il m'a mis 26
coups il m'a défoncé mais cétait quoi
l'ouverture alors F3 C4 machin de la
merde cétait une scandinave D3 mais jou
une que que moi joue j'ai un pe analysé
sauf que lui il a en fait j'ai raté un
moment pour égaliser mais bon il fait
hyper bien
joué il m'a
défoncé mais déboité mais comment il a
ramené un pion à
eux il y a pas de P 3 c'est un truc qui
ressemble à ça non mais je sais non mais
c'est pas la même structure enfin genre
la structure c pas tout à fait ça mais
genre l'important c'est qu'il y avait un
fou en B7 qui
[Musique]
fallait ou mais bon ça change rien en
fait qu'il a pas de pion ah non non mais
c'est même mieux pour les blancs
mais non mais c'était la même idée de
truc en bon ça aucun
rapport il m'a laminé je sais pas ce qu'
devient ce Lévon je sais pas ce qu'il
fait je pense qu'il être comme ça quoi
ah non pendant la partie ouais il doit
être très heureux mais mais je dire
globalement écoute mais il a joué il a
joué quand les bon mais il a joué il a
battu à Rea ah oui
c'est partie con complètement
pourri ah mais et c'est la fameuse
finale où ala il a fait le truc enlevé
sa tour de à 4 la fameuse finale
Fab le coup est très moche je sais pas
comment tu peux le jouer en
fait comm dir VL quoi j'ai l'impression
que bourr mort avec 10 secondes tu tu
fais ro F7 quoi tomber sur les
Ch
là il a fait tour C8 oui bon plutôt
logique il met la tour en vis-àvis avec
la dame et comme on vous a dit le plan
c'est de faire C5 la tour va appuyer ce
C5 et c'est une colonne qui est promise
à s'ouvrir donc la tour qui a trou une
activité ici qu'elle naurait pas eu en
la
8 si j'avais les blancs par contre je
serais déjà en panique en fait en
panique ça me saoulerait
quoi
non mais c'est bien en fait c'est si
simple que ça ça don envie de de jouer
la mer mais personne joue ça avec les
Blancs comment ça ah il font plus alors
normalement F TR il te font jamais en
fait là maintenant soit ils te font dam
C2 non s font ça ils te font tous dam C2
en fait ok il te font plus de fou TR je
vois plus je suis dégoûté parce que c ma
rond préférée avec les Noirs mais plus
personne te le
fait et de toute façon ils te font là
ils te font FG5 en fait en fait ça tu
vas jamais le voir et fou 5 là c'est
pénible oui oui
ben pour moi c'est plus fort que le TR
même visuellement tu t'enfermes pas un
fou tu cloues tu te
développes c'est pas du goût de tout le
monde à cause de H6 oui ou DESC B et
tout mais mais c'est plutôt ça mais au
pire si tu es pas très content tu fais
ça et avec les Blancs c'est quand même
intéressant sais qu' y a un mec qui m'a
fait un truc mauvais mais que troué
intéressant je connaissais pas
E4 ouais je sais il font C2 ou mais tois
j'étais là bon j'avais gagné la partie
quoi je me disok est con mais quand même
pas tant que ça quoi enfin c'est pas
complètement abruti quoi mais je l'avais
pas vuir quoi
enfin je fais
quoi donc oui j'en ai joué quelquesunes
mais tout ça c'est c'est il y a
quasiment 20 ans toutes ces parties dont
je parle mais du coup ça en fait tu vas
jamais enfin oui si tu es très heureux
de la position avec les malheureusement
tu l'auras jamais quoi et là il doit
avoir C 5
à la fin c'est ça
ouais sur qu' prend
F6 tu peux bou bou dame D5 au pire
c'est5 il va déjà falloir sécher la
partie
C5 doit faireali
Pr
tu dois déjà en fait après c 5 c'est les
blancs qui doivent comme dirait effacer
la
partie par
plus tu dois l'effacer en fait mais
c'est 5 c'est
visible façon tu regardes depuis ça fait
5 coups qu'on regarde que
ça ok alors tu dois faire raelle moi
j'avais c'étaitif qui m'avait montré ça
quand il travaill à CAN et il m'avait
dit bon je vais pas faire une imitation
du YF parce que je la raterai mais il
m'avait dit dans cette position tu dois
à chaque coup avec les Noirs calculés si
C5 marche à chaque coup avec les Blancs
calculés mais il raison il dit si les
Blancs jouent cavalier C5 c'est déjà
terminé mais il a raison oui mais je
sais donc en fait dire que le coup est
hyper facile dans le sens où de toute
façon tuas pas le choix si tu de toute
façon tu as perdu si marche pas
stratégiquement mais ou mais tu dois
être prêt avant que ça ça arrive le fait
accompl donc oui le problème pour les
blancs c'est que s'ils prennent du pion
ils perdent une pièce on prendra deux
fois E4 et on va bouffer le fou des
deux donc voilà et si s'ils prennent du
cavalier bon c'est ce qui va se passer a
priori c'est fou prend pu on prend dame
D5 menace matant G2 menace tour D8 aussi
enfilade le CL de la colonne D attention
c'est trouvé dans le calcul non mais le
4 faire qu' pr 4 ah oui
pardon à moins que ça marche pas la dame
prend ah il ah faut prend 5 fa B4 oua
bon mais attends de toute façon c'est
sûr que ça marche alors k prend
C5 dame D5 d'abord
parce que vu que c'était E4 on prend
des4 et on on le terrasse
ou Wesley désolé hein comme on joue pas
la partie c'est un peu plus dur d'être
précis dans ces trucs là mais c'est
visuel de toute façon que ça marche
ok bon du coup tu peux ni prendre du C
ni du pion
oui donc tu dois prendre F6 moi c'est la
que quand on parla celle de4 moi j'avais
celleel en
tête j'ai j'étais à côté en
fait là 5 PR2 tuas pas le temps de
faire4 attaquer là tu prends à 3
3 oui tu prendras 3 un jour quo Bou
bouff j' pris à 3 je pas ten un P
pass Bou je je tiens ma petite
nul bon après tu peux aussi jouer je me
questionnais si Jef était possible pour
jouer le gars
mais là il se questionne
pas mais gen mais tu sais tu pourrais
battre un tel que Ding avec coup non
mais je pens exactement à ça en fait il
te fait pion prend regarde tu fais tour
prend tout un coup tu fais ro H8 t
G5 ça
Chi
donc oui ça va faire nul dans une très
belle partie encore entre guillemets
pour le moment deux parties très
instructives Fab
ouais il ait F prend b2ussi
oui pas mal il va voir moi je m'attends
pas à ce que Wesley perde donc pour
l'instant il tient
son il tient son
avantage son demi-point son enfin son
son point d'avance quoi demi en fait
c'est point d'avance mais il tient son
demi-point dans cette
partie donc évidemment là on est plutôt
supporter de Wesley si si vous nous
voyez parce qu'on espère avoir un 3è
set c'est pas qu'on aime pas Abd satorov
non non pas du tout après que le
meilleur gagne hein mais bien sûr on
serait serait un peu tristoun s' y avait
pas de 3è set ni dans ce match ni dans
l'autre quand même tout est mis en place
pour qu'on ait des matchs qui durent
avec du suspense et cetera et euh et
voilà on espère que qu'on va vivre ça
quoi tout a été fait pour en tout cas
Fab les règlements tout tout été mis en
place ça dure le plus longtemps
possible et ce serait un sacré coup du
destin Fab si c'était pas le cas imagine
ni aujourd'hui ni pour la finale
ais bon
ok alors ça a quand même très bien
marché cette stratégie pour tout ce qui
était phase de
Calif quasiment quasiment que ça je
pense 90% des matchs au moins sont
terminon pour moi pas dans C match il
man quelque
chose trop de
par mie j en de parties faire plus de 7
AA êre 3 gagnant de deux
parties mais là ouais non là bravo là
finement
pensé ser bien une fois qu'on fasse
notre nos règles de tournoi vraiment
optimum quoi finement pensa
aussi pourit te faire un tel format de
génie une BUP 4 a que des arm mais par
contre on pourra pas la faire sur une
journée non non ça sera sur au moins de
enfin non de jours je pense 3 mois tour
alors là c'est une gaffe apparemment
mais c'est ce que je te disais ah juste
3 ça per un pion
voit mais mais en fait tu vasf oui il
reste le pion il est bienou tu perds
juste un pion mais tu vois ce que je te
disais c'est que c position quand
égalise avec les blanc faut vraiment
effacer la partie mais AB peutêre qu'il
son obligé de tenter
mais en fait je vois pas ce qu' tente
c'est ça que je comprend mais alors là
juste pour expliquer à quel point c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour pour tout le
monde c'est c'est que ce match peut se
terminé donc après seulement trois
parties avec une victoire de sauce qui
nous assure un 3è set mais le 3è set ne
sera pas joué en
parallèle ah B non on va attendre bien
comme il faut que match oui ah bien sûr
et au pire du pire ce match finira
d'magedon
oui c'est qu'on aura au pire au pire c
part voilà cinq
parties mais en fait c'est pas grave s
en a que trois c'est que si SAU fait nul
la 3è on a'ura pas la déception non
ouais dans cette cour mais je crois que
il comprend
pas bah personne comprend là enfin nous
on apprendre à la turbine mais c'est
vrai fa prend à 3 fa prend
C5 alors j'ai
compris il veut peut-être fou
C3
H7 ça bon il va le voir quand même ah
mais là il y a dame G5
c'est pire sonire B4 on sera quand
même non je sais pas ce qu'il veut en
fait Mo il a pris la
mais comme quoi je raconte pas n'importe
quoi dans ces Slav tu vois
l'expérience d'en avoir joué beaucoup tu
sais que les Blancs enfin c'est ce que
je disais évidemment là lui avit pas
voulu faire nul tout de suite il a voulu
continuer à jouer mais je t'ai dis si tu
veux continuer à jouer c'est hyper
dangereux très attention ouais c'est
hyper dangereux j'en ai gagné plein
comme ça je v pas dire le nom mais il y
avait un quand je JIS en jeune il y
avait un gamin mais qui arrêté les
échecs d'ailleurs mais je sais pas moi
je sur 2150 tuis
quelque chose comme ça moi j'étais pas
mal sousclassé comme je jouis pas
beaucoup et puis Paris un peu surclassé
en fait mais chaque fois qu'il avait les
blanc jou des Slaves vou toujours gagner
quoi moi je Russ toujours à faire mon C5
y chaque fois je batis avec les noir
mais
vraiment
par dire on a joué que deux fois c Slav
mais je mis
20 15
fois gag arrête quoi juste c'est nul
c'est nul quo fait nul enfin tu me
connaisi j'ai toujours été d'accord pour
les petits nuls aussi quoi moi je te
propose nul il veut gagner quoi non mais
c'est pourquoi on fait pas des tournois
avec que des armageddons bah c'est une
question qu'on s'est posé hier avec Fab
et on s'est peut-être dit qu' faudrait
qu'on lance un tournoi qu'on appellerait
aussi Armagedon ce
serait Armon parti ouais alors ils font
un truc ils étaient en Allemagne tout ça
mais là c'est V des armons très rapid
mais ça s'appelle Armagedon mais c'est
pas des Armagedon en fait ouis ah bon
non ah je jamais regardé en fait c'est
bon
ça alors moi dis-toi que j'en ai
commenté un sais où ils é habillé avec
des sortes d'uniformes rouge et noir moi
j'en ai commenté un c'était vachement
bien payé donc je sais très heureux le
commentaire ouais bon j'imagine que
jouer c'était bien pé aussi mais ouais
ah mais c'était bien en fait comme
tournoi c'était hyper c'est très
dynamique en vrai c'est en fait c'est
que des Blitz et à la fin en fait c'est
comme c'est une série de quatre Blitz et
s' y a de deux il y a un armagadon ah
mais c'est normal enfin OK non c'est un
truc complètement normal en fait je
pensais que tout le temps non non mais
moi aussi au début j'étais très heureux
évidemment mais mais non en fait c'est
un truc normal et c'est les premiers qui
ont fait les doubles éliminations ah ok
l'idée a été reprise évidemment mais
autant si c'est oui c'est un tournoi où
tu fais que des match je peux entendre
parce que non mais ça assez sympa parce
que les matchs sont rapides en fa bit
dég tu dégages ouais et tu as deux vies
du coup dans le TR ce qui est assez
logique si les matchs sont en 4 blit
ENIT en fait leur truc est hyper logique
he mais ça a pas eu un grand succès
enfin ça existe encore ils le font
qu'une fois par an ou finalement ça a
disparu non mais je sais pas ils le font
je crois que c'est un milliardaire alors
est-ce que c'est allemand ou est-ce que
c'est un Russe qui vit en Allemagne qui
finance enfin c'est de nouveau un truc
un peu zarbi mais le truc est assez
sympa ouais non pour le coup c'est sympa
il tente des trucs de design bon ça
marche pas du tout he mais il tente un
truc quoi il tente un truc tu vois il
serait un peu dans l'esprit de la BUP en
quelque sorte B4 ah bah tu vois c'était
l'idée qu'on a raté
mais déjà rien F Pr
je pense c'est ou c'est la ligne parce
que tu avir une pièce une tour trois
pions ou TR de ouais mais mais pas
n'importe lesquel enfin c'est très fort
pour les n ça se voit que tu es gagnant
là c'est pour ça qu'on a même pas pensé
au coup en fait que c'est évident que
bah vu qu'on peut penser à rien il a
raison d'au moins bouffer une dame
[Musique]
mais
l'armagedon à bas niveau je sais pas ce
que ça pourrait donnerit perso je prends
les Noirs tous les jours moi je donne
moi s'il y a une sub battle d'armagedon
je donnerai à mes mecs les blancs tout
le temps
quoiah ça dépend la cadence de votre
Armagedon le vrai Armagedon traditionnel
moi j'aimais bien les
blancs moi je les blanc less mais là
avec 15 minutes ou quoi je sais pas trop
bon déjà j'ai jamais joué
mais c'est différent puis en plus avec
la plus une seconde 60e machin enfin ça
devient un autre jeu
quoi ah les commentaires sur Youtube ça
me fume il y a un gars qui écrit je cite
faudra dire à la blondass donc Annna
d'arrêter de surjouer de surjouer quoi
je sais pas mais les cour YouTube en
fait c'est le monde des aigris quoi
ouais ils sont tellement égris sur
Youtube mais ça dépend ça dépend si tu
fais de la merde peut-être que il te ils
sont
là fantastique bravo tu fais un truc et
on t'insulte quoi je sais pas elle a
rien demandé à quoi
enfin si tu te c'est le mec qui est
misogène quoi d'ù la blondasse enfin
qu'est-ce que tu racontes moi je
écrire je réponds
vas-y défonce-le
quoi il y en a un qui a écrit un
commentaire de génie alors attends je
vais te le lire parce qu'il est
fantastique non mais moi je peux
m'énerver en fait c'est dangereux non
mais le commentaire est vraiment drôle
non mais si CIT comme l'ARE quand il
disait c'était la foire au truc ça
j'aime bien qu'est-ce qu' nous a dit le
mec c une époque il y a longtemps a la
kmess tipi avec un type ouais alors que
c al attends attends attends mais j'ai
j'ai envie de quasiment le publier sur
Youtube tellement son commentaire est
génial donc pris en B4 prend obligé F
prend
faut 4 ben écoute je peux vous dire on
échange on prend C 5 ah non désolé mais
Anna m'inupporte tu prends C 5 peut-être
ouais ouais donc je lis hein je cite je
cite désolé mais Anna m' supporte c'est
vraiment la fille Barbie à papa maman
gâté qui a eu la vie facile et qui
sourit naïvement pour rien comme une
débile une telle naïveté je peux pas
mais enfin elle est gentille app porte
de la visibilité au
moins j'aime bien quand tu fais ta
petite voix comme ça de ag un confi qui
écrit son comaire j'adore non mais j'ai
bien aimé c'est vraiment la fille Barbie
à papa maman gâté qui a eu la vie
facile rien j'en sais rien en fait en et
puis tant mie enfin quand même tant
mieux pour elle enfin pourquoi ça serait
mal d'avoir une belle vie
ouais bien sûr mais
[Musique]
ouais je sais pas faut pas s'en prendre
au gens quand tu connais pas leur vie
quoi enfin mais là j'aime bien avec ça
apporte pas grand chose en plus de
raconter tout ça quoi mais je trouve
qu'avec cette voix le commentaire est
magnifique oui B ouioui
mais bon un petit roi G8 probablement je
vois bien faire à 4 à3 quandême SF7 tu
t'en fous toutçon tu as le fou qui tient
les
cases et puis on 3 l'autre en B4 tu
seras deux casses de dame ça avance bien
un effort
collectif
mais tout gagne en fait non mais c'est
sûr gens qui AR commentaire le niveau
degritude du mec être j'ai fa le
partager surit comme toi sur
Twitter j'ai envie de partager quandme
que je trouve que c'est le se ultime
quoi
ouais il a le ça mais il se retient
quand même il fait pas
d'insulte mais tu sens son niveau de se
est quand même ouais il y a de la sueur
du sel de
partout Go qui la voix est parfaite est
magnifique c'est la voix du livre de
Maxime là ça V que j'ai trouvé event au
début de quand tu disais
le ybl je début plutôt deux fous de
caves ou un fou un cave ah bah plutôt de
fous hein de fous c'est fort c'est mieux
parce que tu contrôles toutes les
couleurs ils sont très bien il on
appelle ça la paire de fou et en c'est
c'est plus puissant que juste deux
piècesoi ah attends n donne une bonne
attends est-ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle Carana ser en train de gagner
contre Carlsen c'est une très bonne
nouvelle alors oui et non parce que ça
nous éloigne peut-être d'un armagéon
dans ses premiers ah oui mais bon Magnus
peut revenir ouais c'est mieux quand
même comme ça que parce que là on est
déjà quasiment assuré d'avoir au moins
ouais c'est
vrai en fait on voudrait une Fabi en
Armagedon et du 3è set à
fond
du 3 avec armadon si possible possible
en plus avec deux matchs du coup on a
d'autant plus de Chan que ça puisse
arriver
et bah là en tout cas on est quasiment
assuré un des de set parce que je vois
en plus il fait dame 7 d ça VO que ça
passait
pas c'est tour C8 fou B2 A3 déjà et
pu t
B8
à un moment je me souviens j'étais
vraiment pas bien personnellement
effectivement les gens à Lain avent le
don de m'inupporter après de là à faire
des commentaires de ce genre quand même
pas
ouais mais du coup c'est que c'est toi
qui va pas bien en fait donc
oui en plus tu sais pas c'est pas parce
que les gens sont ultra positifs qui
sont vraiment heureux en fait s rien
quoi non puis de toute façon en ça va
rien dire en fait en fait le truc
déjà bizarre ou pas bizarre c'est comme
ça mais en langue anglaise son que la
langue est plus
positive enfin la manière de parler que
ça va plus vite que
ça les expressions tout rien que de
bases
déjà MC ce soir aussi ouais du
Do bah tu as bien vu après dans la
soirée quand je parlais russe on parlait
plus fort et on rigolait beaucoup plus
que quand on parlait en français
h parce qu'on a gris en fait mais c'est
vrai que tu rigoles plus quand tu parles
russe plus drôle en fait non mais il y a
un truc qui fait que c'est drôle mais
mais je souviens enfin juste même quand
je faisais les résumés Eurosport et que
j'avais le gars à côté qui parlait en
anglais ça ça glissait plus welcome to
londonens et moi je suis là bah
bienvenue à Londres mais
mais ça sort pas quoi ben oui mais non
enfin et tu as l'impression que tu vis
un truc incroyable tu dis la même chose
mais juste dans une autre langue et
euh je sais pas c'est c'est mieux huilé
quoi
ça mais abandonne Abdou là c'est tour B2
à2 tu peux rien y faire là en fait
ou bon peut-être qu'il oui il va
abandonner mais alors là c'est vraiment
le le scénario de rêve pour nous Fab
ouais on pouvait pas arriver mieux à la
fin des deux parties entre Fabiano qui
mène quand
même il tombe
Iland le pion était
inarrêtable déchaîné là ce match retour
on peut peut-être aller voir ce qui se
passe chez
Fabiano l'air très bien d'près la jauge
visuellement la position on voit qu'il a
du jeu mais encore falloir finir hier
des fois on sait qu'il a eu du mal
cavalier H5 F6
il vient F5 prend
H6 couvre un peu les cases
noires F4
peut-être sur pr
f43'est- que c'est je sais pas c'est il
veut F5 il ve F si
pr il aussi il veut bien sûr est-ce que
ce fou peut s'en aller ramènera
peut-être le cavalier en F3 dame 3 il
veut dame F5 t F8 il veut qu' F3 pour
blinder G1 et compagnie ok on comprend
le coup ça va ça va ça va du coup il va
faire un coup de fou quoi
ouais peut-être qu'il F3 du coup pour un
peu blinder parce que maintenant il est
en l'air en
H4 il m'a pas l'air d'être il est pas
clinique pour finir non il est pas
clinique manque de manque de vision
laser
deux deux retournements de 7 ça
serait extraordinaire mais j'aimerais
bien quand même que le retournement et
lion en
armagon attends imagine le scénario par
par exemple catastrophe là tu nul dans
la prochaine de saut contre Abdou et
ouais ouais là c'est vrai qu'on se prive
de de nombreuses
parties bah oui non mais c'est vrai que
on perd au moins de enfin au moins une
et deux parties
euh
S
bon allez faut prendre en G6 faire qu'
prend le 5
non mais il pourra pas gagner ce match
hein s'il fait
ça
F5 c'est mauvais ben ça a pas l'air très
bon parce que tu peux faire prise et
prendre sur échec tu vas plus vite
peut-être que c'est peut-être que c'est
jouable F5 mais je dire pourquoi
pourquoi per du temps quand tu parce que
tu vois les Noirs ils vont pas se
tourner les pous ils vont te faire tour
B1 ils vont prendre ton pion B2 ils vont
se pion passer
ouais tu fais ton truc quoi tu prends la
dame tu prends le 5 tu fais échec il est
obligé de cacher son roi là tuas le
temps d'aviser est-ce que tu ramèes la
tour en pour F2 est-ce que je sais pas
après faut voir
euh mais en tout cas bon clairement Fabi
a pas joué de manière optimale
avant et il comm à en dessous d'une
minute on n'est pas sûr qu'il va la
gagner celle-là mais comment on disait
c'est pas forcément une mauvaise
nouvelle une nul s'il est nul
s'enchaîne on avance doucement mais
sûrement jusqu'à
ragadon mais oui c'est bizarre ce qu'il
a fait de
pas il a pas pris son temps au bon
moment au moment de mettre le mais c'est
bizarre parce que normalement justement
les joueurs de top niveau ils sont forts
pour mettre le punch final là il a joué
des coups pour
ouais il descend à 25 secondes
ok il fait mais va on prend prend 5 H7
il a fou des6 qui peut menacer quand
même soit il fait tour D7 soevent F3 moi
j'aurais fait cavalier F3
pour tour des7 c'est c'est pas mal aussi
hein sûrement qu' va faire tour B1 ou je
ne sais quoi pour aller prendre B2 et se
donner un petit contrejeu voilà bon t de
C du même
Akabi mais ok avec 7 secondes tu peux te
faire arnaquer
hein 3 G3 quand
même ce fou F4 alord donne plus gagnant
mais tu reprends B4 en fait il aim pas
à cause de tour B2 direct genre ça c'est
plus gagnant quoi ouais enfin je sais
pas trop mais bon on va voir l'ORD aucun
des coup mais ils sont tous plus ou
moins logiques franchement il peut
passer plein de choses c'estd que bien
sûr il a de P pass centraux mais il y
aite il a T
fou il y a qu'on a même pas un pion
d'avance Fab a vraiment complètement
troll raté mais bon on va voir peê
encore mieux mais
ou mais il peut même finir par perdre si
ça Toure mal je veux dire un petit F
prre des C des familles ici ou là mais
là il avance mais il va peut-être se
prendre un fou en E5 non ah mais il veut
ro
F2 allez
pousse pousse c'est pas mal il de P
passé qui avancecent ensemble
pousse
pousse je sais pas si doit pousser mais
je pousseon ça te fait plaisir de dire
pousse quoi pe faire qu' F5 qui pousse
après quoi alors l'autre va pousser
aussi
pousse il pousse hein roi mais mais
regarde la jauge il a poussé oua ouais
mais il a pas assez poussé avec les
Blancs
bah fallait
pousser
imbécile bah faut prendre 5 de merde pr
oh oh là là mais fallait pousser Fabi
fait D7 faut F6 B8 ou mais B2 quoi ça
pousse je veux dire bouffe pousse
pousse voil il a les principes
quoi P boui bouffi sa merde voilà
bravo vas-y pousse
quoi c'est bien jou que
j'ai
bien joué H4
d'abord5 pr maintenant mais il moins
bien mis la tour le RO c'est
éloigné c'est
nul3 Magnus qui tente de
gagner bah il pousse quoi
ou
pousse tu
pousses
mais bon tu peux pas gagner
ouais en fait il va te faire H3 il va se
avec la tour tu vas faire ro H1 il va
faire échec j'ai un
dame mais bien fait pour Fabiano quand
même qui a pas mis le final quand il
fallait qui a pas poussé quand on lui
criait de le
faire crier assez fort bon du coup
westle qui a quasiment mange gagné qui
mène 2-0 et Fabiano Magnus un partout
Fabiano qui manque de réalisme dans ce
match et ça risque de lui coûter cher on
se retrouve après la petite pause à tout
à
l'heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les amis on s'est délecté d'une superbe
interview de de
Wesley intéressant marrant Wesley
agréable ouais franchement il l'air
tellement
heureux donc là il mène il mène 2-0 en
fait westle oui il très bien qui va nous
rejoind le petit B3 au premier coup donc
ça veut dire que une nuul lui suffit
ouais ouis je le vois plus jouer E4 en
deux
parties en tout cas bravo he bravo
Wesley il fait très plaisir
Wesley qui espère que le match va
continuer sur ce sur cette lancée la
chance les Italiens il avaient la pub
avec le tessarama qui faisait du foot ah
et nous on l'a pas non mais on l' aussi
mais juste me on aurait pu faire un
match quoi faudrait qu'on essaie un
match de foot échec là ça a l'air
exceptionnel il joue le
4 fait nous un beau qure cavalier des4
quoi
ah une petite écossaise je vais te dire
ce qui se passe du côté de Dominguez bah
c'est toujours pas gagné hein quoi que
non si si c'est l'ordi
qui une pièce de plus bon ça va est
vraiment à côté quoi comment s'est
passéi une partie
important il va gagner à
1800 ge ses chances de se battre pourand
je pense sera très dur il a pas choisi
le bon
tournoi
il a choisi unour le plus dur il aurait
pu aller jouer un petit open débile moi
j'aurais
ça créer un truc et là c'est vraiment
dur pour lui au Mexique aussi
hein parce qu'on rappelle il pas le
droit de jouer aux États-Unis enfin il a
le droit il fait ce qu'il veut mais ça
Nura pas été comptabilisé ça aurait été
comptabilisé mais juste ça aurait pas
rendu éligible
ouais mais bon maintenant qu'il a joué
là-bas il peut rentrer aux États-Unis et
jouer à fond jusquà la fin de l'année
peut-être il
peut qui a joué la avec fou B4
échec comme moi tu fais
ouais sur F 3 c'est quoi au lieu de C
F5 F B6 F5 à ce
momentl c'est
possible
en fait sur6 tu vas faire F 3 tu vas
l'attaquer et tu es content si t'échange
oui en tout cas est je sais pas j'aime
bien dans les interview crois not
préféré du tournoi lui Abdou non les
deux marrant aussi moins que quand Mme
mais je
tellement il a l'air
heureux D6 éé joué Pardou il laisse le
pion G7
il va prendre va faire ro F V du damage
4 vite V l'activité de partout comme il
aime bien
C peut-être mauvais en fait moi je sais
que je joue ça mais c'est c'est
peut-être nul en fait parce que D6 F3 il
F5 intermédiaire ouais peut-être qu'il
s'est trompéut je me trompe aussi tout
le temps et
s'est trompé aussi peutêtre qu'il a T
parti depuis que tu l' fa scandy ouais
interesting blit stream creative
Player sur le truc normal c'est pas fou3
fou B6 c'est4
d'ailleurs je me rappelle plus en fait
Fab du truc normal je sais que je fais
ça mais je me rappelle plus du truc
normal non non mais je sais pas trop moi
j'aurais fait F 3 mais euh je peux pas
dire soit le coup hein moi je je joue
pas ça donc euh je ne suis pas
expert
fa que je vérifieès quand ça fait
longtemps que je joue plus moi j'oublie
vite
maintenant en ce moment je joue pas
beaucoup et quand je joue pas beaucoup
j'oublie viteoubl vraiment vite çaarrive
à tout le monde faut pratiquer bah non
c'est sûr que c'est pas ça je suis sûr
que j'ai déjà perdu comme ça en fait et
je suis sûr que j'ai déjà regardé après
en tout cas là qui bah je sais que c'est
pas ça non mais il a raison de faire je
dire mant qu'il eu des 6 il eu des 6
hein ouais do pro s'est fou 3 puis
cavalier F5 quo tu vois je me rappelais
plus bah c'est sûr que j'ai déjà perdu
comme ça alors ça j'en suis sûr à 100 %
parce que je sais que j'ai déjà regardé
après je sais que c'est pas bon al
tuabandonne pas mais euh mais je sais
que je suis déjà fait défoncer après la
partie je regardé oui ça va pas ça je
sais comme quoi il y a pas que moi qui
oublie la théorie
on pourit boire le CAL jusqu'à la
LI égalisation ENF
2 on perd on perd notre trè match
quoi le coup de
bambou dur pour le moral allez
saccrocher on espère
après c'est pas
perdu non mais bon il relance quand même
Abdou en le mettant dans son type de
position ressorti le
puma bolivien là Puma blanc avec les
petites couleurs
ouais
qui porortter chance
hier est-ce que tu penses qu'il y a une
toute petite chance que Carlsen aille
jouer les
candidats aussi inf film soit-elle bah
inf film alors oui après je crois pas
qu'il en a trop l'envie ou le ce soit
son délire mais
euh mais il peut toujours passer des
choses avec Carl
si que ça allez je vais jouer hop et ça
changerait la perception de l'événement
si
car bah concrètement il remplacerait
abasof oui en terme de niveau de jeu ce
serait oui même de plateau enfin abasof
n'a rien à faire là c'est pas
offense jamais vu un J aussi mauvais au
candidat quoi c'est simplement ça juste
tu passerais d'un truc avec un lineup
questionnable tout d'un coup un super
lineup quoi un joueur changerait
vraiment tout
là tu prends le pire et par le meilleur
possible ouais donc oui ça change pas
mal C 5 jouer il ramène des pièces pens
qu' a pu prendre mais ça peutre BL
simplifier échanger roquet ou G4 ou quoi
il ramène du matos à l'attaque le5 il
peut mettre la tour H8 en G8 l'utre F en
G4 et cet donc il s'apprête à ramener
ramener du beau monde pas facile pour
W dur à jouer pour les blancs je pense
ouis non c'est F3 cavalier F5 en fait tu
dois rentrer dans un truc tu contrôles
la case D5
ouais je oui ça para plus logique moi
mais bon je conteste rien
je regarder ce qui se dit sur sur les
raisons en même temps sur la la
compétition celle-ci
ouais alors pas grand chose c'est pas
bon signe
alors en fait le truc c'est que je crois
que les gens ils sont hype enfin les
gens quelques gars de la la
communautéche genre Guiry machin et tout
ils sont vraiment sur le site j domingaz
en fait ah
oui non mais en fait je normalement le
jouer pour le titre de champion du monde
ça passe devant tout enfin je sais pas
ils inventent des circuits parallèles
mais tuas un titre aux échecs et tout le
reste n'existe pas vraiment enfin c'est
non mais je vois que c'est un peu le le
truc marrant du jour quoi mais donc donc
c'est logique quelque part
quoi tu je vois en fait tous les gens en
faitas chestc et les comp qui tweet sur
la machin là sur champion Etas les
compesre Bard gu machin et tout qui qui
par que de qui parle que de
Dominguez donc
c'est c'est balancé tout ça
West spentol
Twitter
i était sur Twitter à
fondas des tweets marrants aujourd'hui
ah bon a
dit il a troll nan
ok en je sais pas ou il envoyé un tweet
genre le top niveau des échecs sera bien
différent dans 5 à 10
ans en disant que c'est lui qui sera top
quo dit j'aurais déjà arrêté ma carrière
c'est un peu long j'aurais déjà ma
carrière j'auris commencé le golf quoi
que ton foutu de sa gueule en fait
bravo après il a un peu troll avec anich
sur les candidats les machins de
Dominguez ouais donc il était
complètement il d'être en grande forme
en ce il d'être un peu plus troll
qu'avant je sais pas comment dire ouais
ouais il se débride
quoi il se lâche il lâche les chevaux il
lâche les chevaux
ouais
B nan qui fait tout le temps le malin ça
me dépasse un peu quand même je me
ferais bien petit à sa
place c'est quand même dommage ah oui
bon c'est sûr très marrant mais ah il
est très drôle tu dois être
aigri
après les échecs ça reste quand même un
milieu microscopique hein oui tout le
monde s'en fout mais gen ça toucherait
du vrai grand public ce serait pas comme
ça non ça pourrait pas genre Carlsen ce
sera un scandale qu'il ait pas pris de
plus enfin en fait tous ces trucs là ça
pourrait pas passer dans un plus grand
milieu je tour G8 c'est pas intéressant
est sur dame D2 tour prend
G3 cré une menace cal H5 he bien sûr
c'est aussi une possibilité pour jouer
sur JOUER dame D2
ouais VE
t G8 ouais du coup dame D2 tour G3 dame
H6 bou bou tour
g7on faut se barrer ro D2 ro C2 ta ta
quoi des de tu protèges ta tour en plus
ou c'est ouais que ou la T pr G3 c'est
clairement une menace le P H2 est
cloué
tu es pas perdant hein c'est juste c'est
dur à
jouer en fait pas du tout hein il on 64
skatein du où le meilleur joueur du
monde ne joue pas le Championnat du
Monde le tournoi perd toute sa
crédibilité euh je sais pas si Jok vient
pas jouer Roland Garos Roland Garos aura
lieu sera un très beau titre quand même
et et puis c'est tout en fait donc car
ça ne joue pas car ça ne joue pas ça
regarde que lui on préférerait qu'il
joue après il joue pas il joue pas ça
reste le titre à avoir en
fait par il le joue pas et c'est dommage
enfin je préféris qu'il joue mais c'est
pas pour autant que c'est plus important
quoi ils sont pr degré les groupis de
Nan sur Twitter je crois que oui hein
malheureusement oui si c'était que des
gens qui je trouve ça marrant en
comprenant
le marrant qui oui mais là non je crois
que c'est des écervelet en fait non mais
sérieus enfin je sais pas comment les
appeler enfin c'est pas possible de ça
but ça
but non mais je pense en plus bah oui
mais je pense aussi qu' sont premier
degé he c'est on atteint un
niveau donc ci des deux en tout cas il
tente de s'en
aller en fait Dominguez pour aller au
candidat ce qu' aurait dû faire h HM
arrive au tournoi se faire un certificat
de maladie pour les trois premières
rondes
ou donc il peut pas jouer comme ça
4 qui sont à 0 sur 3 il fait 5 sur 5
ouais c'est ça et tu penses ça suffit ou
quoi 6 sur 6 il aa pu me faire
[Musique]
h chercher un truc de génie du mal non
non mais c'était pas con enfin non il a
joué faire quoi en
fait et euh mais c'est dur d' d'aller
jouer un
open
c'est vraiment pas le meilleur moyen de
gagner des points h non faitre un peu
plus
marlou mais mais on va voir s'il
s'arrête là et qu'il avoue son échec ou
alors si te fait une remontada de fou et
que il enchaîne les points parce qu'il
pourrait peut-être genre je me
souviens il y a très
longtemps
97 il tourno à Bourbon lanc Vergon par
là-bas mais qui Fa un open assez fort en
fait qui a disparu depuis mais bon peu
importe euh j'avais battu Bologan ronde
2 donc bon bravo quoi enfin bon bah
après il a fait 7/ 7 quoi il a fait se
en tête avec 8/ 9 et alors que bon tu
vois un mec AC sur de et puis le tournoi
était pas mauvais il y avait pas mal de
grands maîtres ou quoi mais c'est plus
dur aujourd'hui un peu comme le disait
Naka d'ailleurs dans son interview enfin
dans sa réaction à l'interview à au
podcast de de carwana il avant les 25 25
50 au noir c'était tr très facile de
gagner ils sont hyper bien préparés et
oui c'est dur mais donc il était arrivé
à à faire cette remontée de fou
enchaîner les gars donc c'est ton Jama
pour domingaz évidemment je le mets pas
favori pour pour réaliser ça mais donc
c'est pas
fait on dit de la même manière qui dit
que le championat du monde et le truc à
faire tout ceci vient d'un ré humain bah
ça vient de comment le sport est
organisé mais par exemple si c'était
plus un système de grand schlem d'échec
machin et tout ce serait complètement
différent juste là aux échecs moi je
suis pas forcément pour ce truc de
mettre autant d'importance sur un seul
tournoi parce que du coup déjà que c'est
pas très intéressant tout le reste
devient complètement inintéressant je
pense qu'un système comme le tennis et
le GO d'ailleurs il a d'autres jeux qui
font comme ça qui font ça justement pour
que la saison soit pas genre là si
c'était je sais pas moi ça un
de de je sais pas quoi avec des points
en jeu qui jouent pour la première place
mondiale ce serait peut-être beaucoup
plus intéressant peu importe mais le
fait c'est que le sport actuellement est
construit comme ça donc on donne toute
l'importance au match Championnat du
Monde et et au circuit après que les
échecs soient extrêmement mal organisés
et qu'on puisse difficilement faire pire
ça je pense que c'est le cas mais il se
trouve qu'aujourd'hui c'est comme
ça
master de la BUP 3 bravo keV et à tous
ceux impliqués merci pour ce que vous
faites pour les échecs écoute merci à
toi let's go soutenir n'hésitez pas si
vous voulez soutenir à mettre des tweets
à écrire à continuer à utiliser le
hashtag BUP 3 en parue à retweet sur
Twitter à mettre des commentaires sur
les messages ça êre vraiment en fait
parce que j'avais déjà dit au début de
la BUP avec mon mégaphone mais vous
aidez enfin bravo à ceux qui aident
genre si tu compares le Banger qu'on a
fait avec ce qui ferait dans l'port
c'est ridicule en fait la commu échecort
ils sont toujours il sport le MO ouais
ils font toujours du bruit ouais ils
font le moindre émission à la con ils
sont en fait c'est que
je je moi je suis pas du tout en fait
mais j'en entends quand même parler
alors qu'il font des truc al je demande
pas à en entendre parler hein je je suis
aucun compte je mais ça me revient aux
oreilles quand parce qu'ils sont tous là
que c'est des gamins de 14 15 ans ils
sont là retweet absolu bon alors que tu
as vu le truc tu dis comment tument tu
peux regarder un truc aussi nul
mais mais mais nous dans les échecs en
fait même quand il y a des trucs bien
les
gens alors je comprends c'est parce
qu'on est plus âgé du coup on est plus
normaux donc enfin c'est une qualité
mais on peut des fois enfin on se lâche
quoi non mais c'est un peu ce dont
parlait à propos d'un autre sujet dont
on parlera pas aujourd'hui avec Fab mais
des fois faut se battre avec les armes
des autres enfin tant pis HM des fois tu
as pas le choix quoi bi j'imagine des5
là pour les Noirs c'est do ouvrir le jeu
ça doit faire mal c'est là qui passe à
côté de sa partie hein mais cette
position pour l'avoir joué avec les
Blancs enfin pour M déjà trompé c'est
ouais après il avait le niveau peut-être
pour la tenir mais genre c'est tu vois
l'ordi mais 00 mais pour
il va être dégoûté il va nous redire ça
y est il a rejoué comm une machine quoi
je pouvais vraiment rien
faire perso en tant que Demian d'échec
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a des tourir
random tout au long de l'année sans hype
et je comprends pas tellement à quoi il
ser bah écoute le truc perdu de
charrette c'est qu'en fait nous on est
fan d'échec on est dans la même
situation que toi même questionnement
que
toi il y a énormément de tournois sans
hype et euh on sait pas trop pourquoi
ils ont lieu on sait pas trop comment il
y a autant d'argent pour tous ces
tournois et on se pose aussi la question
et on n' pas la réponse mais ça fait
longtemps que ça dure c'est comme ça et
et moi je pense très sincèrement et
premier vraiment au premier degré que
c'est pire que rien c'està-dire que ça
nuit au sport en fait parce qu'il y en a
vraiment beaucoup et je pense que rien
serait mieux mais s'il y a des
milliardaires qui veulent mettre leur
argent on peut pas les interdire pour
une raison X ou Y oui après la question
c'est plutôt pourquoi mais c'est comme
quelqu'un qui prend de l'argent et qui
le brûle quoi tu demander pourquoi tu
fais ça mais il raison ça tu peux
l'interdire par contre l'argent mais bon
si voulait le bon fait le brule 12 il va
en mer et puis je sais pas il le jette
dans
la tu te demandes quoi mais
après après le problème c'est qu'on
dirait les top joueurs comme Naka plus
renire du champion du monde alors je
pense que Naka a vraiment envie de le
devenir firou il a dit qu'il voulait pas
le devenir qu' étaiit pas intéressés par
les candidats mais on verra si jint
vraiment ses actions c'est moi ces
actions oui parce après tu peux dire des
trucs pour t'enlever de la pression ou
de toute façon enfin tout ce qui est dit
en interview en conférence de presse
faut toujours le prendre avec des
pincettes hein c'est pas la première
fois vous allez voir des entraîneurs de
foot dire ah machin est blessé il sera
pas là puis tiens le jour du match il
joue bon ça arrive dans tous les tous
les sports tous les jeux ou quoi donc on
peut pas vraiment sair on n'est pas dans
sa tête hein on dit après l' sport
surtoutêt de la vraie compète au-delà de
la SP show la BUP c'est plutôt
l'équivalent d'un kcx petit éch alors
déjà oui je suis d'accord avec toi mais
la kcx ça fait masse de buzz et moi je
kiffe l'event donc plutôt merci parce
que je prends ça comm un compliment et
pour aller plus loin pour te répondre le
truc c'est que l'ORT a des compétitions
qui sont intéressantes à suivre ce qui
n'est pas le cas des échecs donc en
réalité un event comme la BUP ça plus
vocation à créer une nouvelle manière de
faire des compétitions d'échec qui
pourrait devenir sérieuse en réalité euh
alors que que la cacorp n'a pas besoin
de faire ça vu que l'port est déjà
nettement mieux organisé que les échecs
donc en gros c'est juste VO juste pour
ajouter ce petit truc mais sinon sur le
fond je suis d'accord avec toi je trouve
qu'il y a un peu cet élément
supplémentaire pourquoi ne pas faire
gagner d'argent aux participants alors
là il gagne beaucoup d'argent il y a
500000 dollars de prix pour 6 jours de
compétition
j' le stream de 3 pour j'ai l'impression
que chaque fois que j'arrive ça les
échecs bah pas bon moment juste là on
regarde la partie tranquillement quoi
enfin on discute quoi
voilà il va la perdre en fait simplement
mais tu aurais pu passer pour la partie
1 on est très heure de la partie 1 qu'on
va qu'on compte faire en
vidéo et là bon ouais on est un peu
moins content de de ce qu' a fait sa bah
il a fait c'est une pièce bah toute mal
placée il y a pas de coordination bon il
essaie de survivre comme il peut mais
c'est dur ouais ça c'est ouais c'est
c'est terminé en fait
allez donne la dame c'eston jamais
attends et pas ah puis on prend 7 tour
D8
finito il y a pas du tout ah parce
qu'ilion prend à 7 intermédiaire c'est
bizarre les mais il y a pas 4
tour des4 alors peut-être tour des 4 t
des 4 mais c'est en fait je sais pas
dans ma tête moi cétait pu on prend B6
on a pas les coups de l'ordi tu reprends
B6 parce que je me disais pu on prend4
prend peux l'avir
D4 si tu vois B Adam
4 normalement tu l'as mais bizarre
d'avoir laissé ça
trop confiant trop je fini trop facile
ouais
le fait que westlerléchisse maintenant
c'est normalement il doit avoiron tu
fais juste j'ai prend F désabusé et puis
[Musique]
bon perso j'ai invité une nouau échec à
la BUP elle arrivait pas du tout à
suivre les Games c'est pas adapté pour
un qui n'a pas un peu l'habitude des
stream échec bah ouais mais là
malheureusement il a tour des qu il a
trouvé c'est quand même pas facile de
d'expliquer des parties d'échec des gens
qui onont jamais jouer aux échecs là
c'est pas des trucs où c'est plus
possible
quoi
malheureusement tu es obligé de un tout
petit peu connaître les règles quoi
oui don tu peux pas
enfin mais je peux entendre le truc par
contre ah je comprends tout à fait ouais
mais quand même un problème disons tuir
99 % même plus des gens qui connaissent
très bien qui savent pourquoi ils sont
là et
cetera tu vas pas leur expliquer qu'on
se déplace un pion et un
je sais pas quoi et surtout en plus
c'est la 3è édition donc on peut penser
que la prière c'est un moment
donné non parce que là tu vois quand on
regarde le live de ce truc chaque jour
on explique que c'est l'armon un moment
ouis mais tu connais quand même les r
des échecs mais tour des 4 c'est fou
avoir
laissé pr B6 dans ma tête c'était
vraiment tellement
automatique
tu tu prends le dangereux criminel ce
pionb qui va être un P pass en 7 rangé
au prochain coup
et ça relance un peu les débats
peut-être Westley va
finalement ne pas perdre cette partie et
remporter la manche on va voir en tout
cas la dame H4 est attaquée le pion à 7
est
attaqué non dans les trucs qui pourrait
être sympa tu vois comme ajou parce que
là on peut pas le faire malheureusement
sur un stream on est comme quelqu'un
demandé d'enlever là est-ce qu'on peut
enlever la barre non on est obligé de la
mettre mais tant mieux au moins vous
avez vous PZ regarder la barre mais
c'est vrai que dans les événements IRL
si tu veux pas mettre bar des Val ça
pourrait être sympa que pas pour le
stream mais pour les gens IRL un endroit
où il a une barre en fait un écran juste
la
bar où tu puisses pour les gens qui sont
vraiment Noph qui puissent regarder la
barre pour pour avoir l'évaluation quoi
juste pour
revenirag final une précision il dit que
c'était pas juste les règles mais en
fait le ça va vite oui ça va vite ça va
vite oua mais bon je pense qu'elle
souffrirait plus sur des
parties encore plus longtemps
mais oui oui le Blitz ça va vite mais en
même temps
c'est c'est même form en 15 + 3 par
exemple au li que laale 2h de ça durit
8h
quoi je suis pas sûr qu'elle soit plus
heureuse de c'est pas plus facile à
suivre tu connais rien ouais mais lol en
fait il se passe plus de choses P la
partie même quand tu joues pas du tout
ouais mais du coup il est plus le P le P
à 7 il est hyper fort G7 tu V tu
reprends 7 mais est-ce que tu auras le
temps on y a un C B5 qui va arriver à le
défendre je prendrai les Noirs moi quand
même malgré7 faut faire je pense de
toute façon ouais r G7 tu dois faire et
juste puis on prend F3 du coup
matériellement ça ferait tour fou de
pions contre la dame c'est pas mal et
puis bah le roi G7 il va être dans la
diagonale du fou B2 peêtre un petit C4
qui va partir unant il fait d' G6 échec
ok euh
ouais B c'est un co intermédiaire he
l'ordi aime pas mais ou je demandis si
ouais tu V faire fou D3
ouis le cavalier prend je fais dame je
prends ta tour et je prends
D3 bon pere 31 c'est pas c'est un coup
aussi hein mais je ça me questionne F TR
j'auraai du mal à
dire R1 sinon ça m'tient un peu le
statut coup de ce qu'on voyait ro C1 a
priori faire ro G7 on fer g à ce
momentlà mais faut des TR c'est en temps
quand même je pourrais comprendre que W
joue il a fait F TR d'ailleurs
est pas A8 tours tu pourrais
ou caval8 en fait je demander est-ce que
tu es content
de bon je pense d prend
G8 je pense qu'il va la gagner en fait
Abd
Abd Abd garde sa dame ouais mais si
c'est pour faire ça j'aurais pas fait
fout des TR que là tu te reprends la
pression tu avais renversé le truc tu
allais prendre l'initiative et après
il défend bien ouis mais je comprends ce
qu'il veut en fait il se dit qu'il va
faire cavalier de roi 5 Caval à champion
prend et qu'après il va faire C4 et qu'
va attaquerou et qu'en fait c'est lui
qui met la pression avec tour F4 qui
arrive la partie est marrante elle est
mal globalement mal joué mais on
comprend ce qu'il fait et c'est pas
c'est pas absurde du tout bien
sûr j'adore Bir un truc marrant mais
j'ai lu un peu pareil mais dit le blit
si tu connais pas tu piges rien pendant
10 minutes en partie longue tu comprends
rien pendant 4
He non mais pour le coup chaque cadence
à son son intérêt hein c'est pas non non
bien sûr mais c'était par rapport au
gens si tu connais pas les échecs je
crois que oui oui non non bah oui c'est
juste ça va fait rire bon F2 jouer en
tout cas il va faire
roimose là je pas damage
ouais bien et là j'ai ouais je pense
prend ch il aura F pr G2 c'est chiant
mais j'ai prend
F3 ouais prise d'ame prend peut-être tu
vas faire
C4 problme c'est que not 3 est toujours
pas magnifique c'est le cavalier moi que
j'aime pas pas le roi si le c était
mieux
en fait tu as deux pièces cour porté qui
sont mal placées gre comme sais comme la
règle dans les final h c'est mené
2-0 parlant de mené 2-0 c'est dommage
que newassa est pas réussi à marquer ce
deuxème but hier
ou à tenir le
10 je pense qu'il va faire C4 ouais tu
vois on avait quand même la parti
globalement ouais mais il a rien de fait
c'est hyper chaud parce que le fou B2 du
coup est enfin ouvert et fait un clouage
à distance sur le Cali F6 un petit tour
G4 pourrait partir un
moment ça peut faire des choses mais bon
il y a quand mêmeme le pion h passé des
Noirs qui est vraiment bien est- pas G4
ah bah peut-être enfin pr dame G5 C F8
F6
tu
menassespr cavaler bien il se déclou bon
peut-être qu' C2 on ramène ou quoi t D1
j'aime bien ok ok il couvre sa première
rangée il a joue assez vite
je comprends parce que dame pr F3 c'est
fort l' dit vou les dame C3 d'abord pour
pour garder ton pion qui est quand même
une arme offensive en fait et et menacer
des trucs
ok je comprends que ce soit une gaffe
mais je comprends pourquoi il a fait
mais c'est pas fini pour
autant pas du
tout il fait le tour C8 alors est-ce
qu'il va faire roi bien pour se cacher
ou dame C3 ou C de tant pis tu c'est
cool mais ro bien
aussi je pense que et l'un et l'autre
considère pas trop le F3 bon ça ouais
mais tu vois c'est dommage pas
commmencer par tour
C3 cette dame D2 pour ramener un peu
cette dame par ici et puis revener
ensuite vers vers D4 fait il cache ENF
son roi qui a sué toute la partie il
enfin à
l'abri y a de nouveau problèm peut-être
ouais ouais mieux que dame D2 mten je
suis d'accord hop il se place il dame G7
c'est pas mat non mais bon tu
res
g 3 F5 c2ou ce cavalier qui
sû il évite la menace allez C2 peut-être
B5 est quelque part tu rebondis de
partout quoi tu
jaillis mais bon il a du dame F2 qui
rote quand
même
B52 tu dois faire tu dois tu fais
quoi de B je voulais fou D4 mais en fait
il y a dame G1 et k
E5 et si tu es obligé de faire dame D4
c'est pas beau
ouais c'est pas t dame
F2 alors dis que tuas dame 4 dame machin
encore ouais mais bon tu es passif enfin
tu étais mieux dans l'état tu dois faire
hein je suis d'accord que tu dois faire
tu veux pas échanger les dames avec les
pions passifs qui Tavance desessus alors
attention tu es peut-être pas si mal en
Hain bizarrement par que tu coup tout ta
première sur roi H6 tu es quand même en
face donc tu es heureux tu as B7 dans le
viseur si le roi se barre tu as du Tour
F1 dans le Range peut-être le cavalier
qui rebondit C qui rebondit de fou puis
peut-être H5 alors attention il ve tour
de quand
même 6 tour 2 cavalier F5 tour B2 tu
fais
quoi
un tour G4 dam H 6 dam h 7 et tu
récupères la tour mais bon il y aura le
pion qui par ouais je crois que tu es
dans la sauce en
fait faut CLI
W F5 t
B2 est-ce que cavalier
h jeis pas trop ce qu'on fait après ou
mais peut-être cavalier F5 retour il a
pas F5 tu prend
B2 il peut pas partir ailleurs qui H4 et
s va en G5 cavalier F3 roi F4 et tu as
pas tour F1 parce que tu le cloues
pas P Lord 10 c'est incroyable en fait
tu as cavalier H4 tour G2 et tu le
forces à perpè ok c'est juste ouf mais
peut-être il va faire Tourer de
direct quel
génie bon commencer par HK devait être
plus fort parce que plus forçant par que
tu la PR
F5 il va le faire de toute façon parceou
il est
obligé ah je crois pas je crois qu'il a
répité une fois trop non non non non
c'est bon pas encore faire d' pr
il a fait et du coup tu aurais commencé
par cavalier H4 tu forc la
nulle reste au mie au nord tout
ça il va gagner je pense avec les Noirs
dommage pour il avait la bonne
idée je pense d' m 3 c'est un bon coup
il fait Tourch ah t c'est malin
franchement il joue
bien
bahend cheval les dam prend H4 et elle
doit perdre ouais mais tant pis j'ai
tourb j'ai bien aussi allez monte monte
le roi ESS de choper B7 essaie de faire
des trucs quoi mais j'aime bien le fait
qu'il veille choper le truc avec le
roi va faire tour tour qui
monte tour bien manant
j'ai pas aimé le RO le
TB B5 il a C4 ah merde
dame à 6 peut-être par qu'il joue dame 4
tu peux pas Bou
B6 t sur la première
et c'est ce qui tente en tout casen fait
il lu faut5 ah il veut qu' D7 mais tu
peux bouffer roi C6 qui est D3 roi D5 tu
reviens
vite vient à
fond H2 tour H7 il va faire qu' échec
d'abord le problème c'est qu'
TR tu pe revenir sur la
première il va faire3 un moment c'est
peut-être pas grave il fait dame tu fais
dame
aussi ah mais tu vas où avec le roi faut
que tu aill en C3 peut-être là tu peux
faire C6 non il faut il bouffe C6 tu
reviens ah mais il fait
F3
C3 c'est bien
joué ah c'est pas mal qu il défend
quandme tente tout quoi ouais il est
hyper fort et B toi quoi
allez pour l'instant sur on te reprend
reprend l'autre ri C3 de
remonte c'est trois
fois allez pousse pousse cavalier il il
veut CEN il va il va il va il va faire
oh non
ah il fait dam sur
échec belle partie c'était marrant ou
c'était gros combat elle était drôle et
et Carlson
Carana non non attends c'est de ah bah
oui il y avait un partout donc Magnus
égalisé attends mais non il y avait 1
avait nul il nul mais oui il devant
carrément alors pant donc là Fabi va
être obligé de gagner pour aller
chercher l'ARM magedon je te rappelle
pas si sa position était corement
gagnant et fait
ou donc là Magnus a gagné celle-là
euh on commence à être en grand danger
là oui on peut vraiment avir une soirée
de merde si ça continue comme
ça mais la partie était marrante
celle-là
oui et ben écoutez on se retrouve dans
pas trop longtemps il y aura beaucoup je
dans la 4è ronde à tout de
[Musique]
suite m them in seconds with a magnet
and swap themever you like make your get
an exclusive discount on
Allal now with the code
[Musique]
displate.com
les amis ça
repart et qui joue une slave A6 cette
fois il a pas répété le MAN cétait
pourtant bien bien passé et Slav A6 C5
donc il ferme la structure mais parce
qu'il a eu à 6 jouer donc il a le TR B6
et il veut éventuellement en profiter
etle qui se développe avec son coup de
fou
F5 donc dessus les blancs peuvent
peut-être faire c H4 pour le chasser ou
fou F4 simplement pour se développer
quand même logique de se fout case noir
plutôt que de l'emurer derrière la
structure en en sc après un coup comme
E3 est-ce que tu as rappelé le l'enjeu à
l'enjeu euh oui alors l'enjeu est très
important euh il y a déjà eu une manche
hierorté par abdous satorov là c'est la
Manche numéro 2 c'est la 4è partie de la
manche 2 il y a 21 pour West leso donc
Abdou satarov doit gagner à la demande
pour égaliser et
euh et avoir la chance d' un armillénon
pour peut-être valider sa qualification
pour la finale alors que dans l'autre
demi-finale Magnus Carlsen a gagné
surdemande pour égaliser alors non ne
suivez pas le Twitter officiel qui ne
n'est plus au courant des scores et qui
pense que Carlsen a égalisé donc Carlsen
a pris l'avantage dans le set n plus
besoin que du nul simplement pour déjà
gagner un en terne en deux manches un
peu à sens unique d'ailleurs bon je suis
bien content qu'on ait plutôt suivi ce
match là qui nous tient vraiment en
aleine qui va peut-être nous amener
jusqu'à un Armageddon dans
ce peut-être gagné par Wesley ça serait
le scénario idéal idéal idéal
après bon si Wesley venait à ne pas
perdre cette partie bon on serait privé
d'un Armagedon alors à moins que Fabi
gagne avec les pièces noir contre Magnus
mais très peu de
chance mais on aurait quand même le
droit à un 3è set et c'est quand même
vraiment ce qu'on souhaite pour pour
bien se
délecter jusqu'au jusqu'au bout de la
nuit jusqu'au bout des doigts de manger
jusqu'au bout des doigts
ont tellement bon tu SAU avec les
doigs
alors ça pousse au centre pas qui prend5
qui prend G3 qui prend D7 qui prend H1
c'est ça
ok non ça succulent
quoi bon mais Wesley qui qui nous sort
toutes sortes de slave il a bien bien
travaillé
quoi a je crois que c'est un beau bossur
ouis
ouais de préférer bosser que de jouer en
fait qu' a une très bonne question de y
C qui demande à la demande de qui
euh bon c'est vrai qu'on sait pas trop à
la demande du joueur lui-même hein
c'estàd que quand il est en obligation
de gagner pour égaliser ou que sinon tu
éliminé c'est ça qu'ils appellent la
demande mais c'est leur expression à eux
qu'on a qu'on a repris qui nous amuse
parce qu'en fait c'est une expression
qu' utilisent en boucle en fait dès que
tu gagnes tu
gag une expressionutil 40 fois
par par
jour gag la dem ils sont très
heure donc voilà tennis B
[Musique]
de
temp à la demande la demande il y avait
un zéro quand même tu égalisé ouais à la
demande ouais tu
es donc c'est une expression qui nous
amuse avec Fab voilà ce qui nous amuse
c'est pas ça c'est qu'en fait quand on
regarde le live en anglais je CIS on se
dit à tous les deux ouis on de demande
il lui disent donc qu'on est très
heureux et du coup maintenant même quand
il y a plus
de était pas mené il a quand même gagné
la demande il tout le temps en fait je
CIS ils sont trop heureux de le dire
quoi donc
voilà je crois que c'est parti d'un
délire sur chess 24 à la base ils ont
commencé à dire ça tout le temps dans
toutes les langues et du coup chascom il
continuent la tradition ils ont repris
là qu'ils ont quand même recruté un peu
du staff he qui ont
repris il ont racheté donc peut-être le
même staff qui refait les même
chos comme ça marchait bien ça continueo
raison oui change pas une équipe qui
gagnef bien évidemment ils ont eu raison
de ils ont même repris un peu l'idée de
base des 7 à deux à la fin mais ils ont
rajouté l'armagedon donc évidemment
voilà c'est ils ont agrémenté tout
ça P nous commenter les coups bah là ça
c'est la théorie en fait hein pour mieux
comprendre en fait nous non plus on
comprend pas vraiment mais ça a l'air
d'être il joue tout tempo et ça a l'air
d'être les bons coups donc ça doit être
la théorie
hein assez logique ce qu'ils font après
bah les n on pris le centre en fait
c'est le la contrepartie de jouer le
coup C5 avec les blan c'est que tu perds
de la pression sur le centre sur la case
D5 et donc c'est d'autant plus simple
pour les noirs de pouvoir
jouer5 av un tigre en C4 qui
était coup de Griff un peu plus loin
mais il griffe le vide en fait il arrive
plus il a pas le Dr de faire des griffes
arrière ouais il fait que des griffes
comme ça quoi tu vois il alors peut-être
à un moment il va griffer quelque chose
en B6 ou en D6 mais euh mais bon pour
l'instant c'est des ces vides ce qui a
permis donc à Westley de de surgir en E5
avec ce pion de créer le tout pion
central dans le petit centre et euh et
de peut-être pouvoir un moment pousser
E4 s'il le souhaite ou pour l'instant de
maintenir la tension parce qu'on ne sait
pas s'il compte peut-être faire k G7
cavali F5 à un moment rejaillir faire
pression sur C sur le centre et aussi
sur le fou H4 plan très thématique hein
de cette
structure
on VO des systèmes de
[Musique]
Londres sur la chaîne du coup qu je un
peu connaître la
varianterê c'est juste pour faire
chier con
[Musique]
lui
amusez-vous probl orig
min de jou de faire une spons sur ma cha
pe comme l'ARE
je att que je sois là bien sû je vais me
connecter avec toi pour
faire
football g premium
account on leur dit
ou CR Football Club
Saint-Étienne de Green
pces question alors qui nous demande si
des pion fait pas trop de trou sur cas
no alors ça Vaas que le pion G qui
effectivementit un petit trou
mais mais bon V H4 tu c pas grandchose
pour l'instant après bon un jour
évidemment tu peux tu peux le regretter
mais actuellement tu as pas vraiment
enfin tu es compact quand même tu as les
pièces qui couvrent tout tout va bien
quoi demandé G5 ça me paraissait bien
parce qu'il y a plus l'échec là ouais G5
on prend F pr il y a pas Échec donc on a
le temps de prendre le
h4re tu fais G7 ici tu reviens en F5 tu
presses tout non c'est bien W qui nous
fait une bonne partie il a un peu raté
son ouverture tout à l'heure dans l'c
mais sinon il a l'air en forme
aujourd'hui il
affutter
fait très sympa les Vié d' Cana kramling
sympa de vous associer sur les événs de
ce genre bah ouais c'est la meilleure
streameuse hein pour moi
anglophone de très loin actuellement
dans les
échecs moi j'aimais bien Alexandra Botz
mais qui maintenant fait plutôt autre
chose ça c'est pour ça que j'ai
actuellement dans les échecs
qu'Alexandra bon elle est là une fois de
100 ans mais elle fait plus d' fait plus
de poker
oua bien je CIS poer enfin je sais pas
trop mais elle fait des gros tourno en
tout cas je sais pas trop ses places
mais Monaco ici ou là j'ai vu l'autre
jour à la table de nér à nous elle était
très heureuse
et qui demande ça serait quoi toi
l'enchère que tu mettrais la plus basse
pour si tu voulais les
Noirs 8
20 tu cliques quoi mais moi je voudrais
pas les Noirs en fait tu mettrais 18
19fett peuttre 10 9 par principe
mais4 sur H peutêtre une
option
sur conservate comme cou et
sur3 F5 du cavalierentuement coup
d'abruti comme cavalier F4 c'est
possible
h4re un coup d'abruti
mais je pas j'aime pas
trop g
naturellement là prob F5 donc pour
selacer il fa d'abord pourquoi pas il
veutre F5 F4 et rouler complètement sur
cette roi une position maintenant un peu
type système de
Londres Franco carocan
inversé
bon il va sûrement faire à4 t B1 le plan
des blancs et à l dame clairement le
plan des noirs et à
roi mais il faudra savoir comment réagir
contre un coup F5 qui devrait suivre je
pense qu'il compte faire F4 he pour pas
se laisser complètement foncer sur
F5 à mon
avis on pourra faire prise en passant en
F3 et essayer d'installer le C D7 en F6
puis en E4 sur une belle case
centrale
bon mais après je comprends qu'il fasse
ça Abdou il est en must win bah il joue
oui oui bien sûr mais je crois que juste
il s'est fait dépasser un peu par
l'ouverturef il l'a pas mal joué par
plaisir ou apprend pour rien c'est juste
que a mieux traité l'ouverture après
maintenant maintenant la position est
comme elle est et toute façon lui ce
qu'il veut c'est qu'il est pas de nul
trop simple au pire
voilà il sait qu'il a au moins un troème
set quoi qu'il arrive
il faut envoyer F5 là
c'est bon il a tout fait pour après
peut-être on peut attendre un petit peu
mais oui ça paraît hyper logique de
jouer F5 maintenant très clairement j'
un Bullet c'est le coup qui partira
instantanément il a tout fait
pour après tu peux hésiter avec cavalier
F5 cavalier H4 j' en de dire donc F5 F4
voilà le coup attendu il veut pas se
laisser enfoncer et je pens à la prise
en passant personnellement parce que on
a pas envie de prendre en F4 sinon il va
prendre du Fou et il s'installe sur une
jolie case alors on peut peut-être faire
H6 pour maintenir la pression mais du C
tuas plus la prise en passant c'est ça
c'est maintenant ou jamais et d'illeurs
il l'a fait et je pensais ensuite voilà
sur fou prend ou tour prend jouer avec C
F6 et venir vers la case4 jolie case en
cas d'échange on reprendra de F on
s'ouvrira le fou E6 vers l'roi et en
tendant la case F5 pour le C
G7 faire g pr F3 ça l'air dangereux il y
aura sûrement F4 donc il a pris du Fou
et donc c F6 semble peut-être logique
maintenant ou plus tard mais en tout cas
c'est le futur de ce C
D7 il y avait s pic elle a disparu sous
les radars bah sic elle a surtout eu
deux enfants
oui tu tu es marié avec Aniche avec le
double
I the double
eye mais ils ont eu un deuxième il est
né leur deuxième enfant ou pas je sais
pas est-ce qu'on a
l'info
est-ce que Dominguez a gagné alors bonne
question ça domingaz là est blanc
domingaz il est où jou à 1800 je le vois
pas il est là il a gagné ça y
est
bravo soosaki aussi qui l'
emporté est-ce qu'on sait s'il y a du
délai dans ce tournoi de
CJS aucune
idée quand même tu vois c'est un tournoi
important qu'il a des qualifications
candidats peut-être possible est-ce que
quand même il y a des mesures prises
pour qu'on soit bien sûr que tout se
passe du mieux
possible c'est quand même dommage qu'un
joueur àariller puisse venir si
et piquer les points gen comme
Dom donc il est né son deuxème le deuxè
enfant déjà un enfant tu as plus trop de
temps mais al de il est grand le petit
le premier à niche 4 5 ans je je sais
pas
trop en tout cas bravo à la maman et au
papa à la maman plus mon avis a fait
plus d'effort
que le papa pour le mettre au
monde et je ne pense pas que ce soit le
double I qui me
contredisent je sens plus troll sur
Twitter
que que faire une césarienne le wi quand
même non
pendant
quoi téléphone dans une main estce
qu'elle pelle de l'autre partout
quoi
il y a un délai nous
ditons très jolie ville que cette ville
de
C joli village de
pêcheur suis jamais allé très joli à
côté de Barcelone ouis je sais pas très
loin recommande d'aller le visiter si
vous êtes du côté de de Barcelone sud de
Barcelone non c c'est un petit peu au
sud mais c'est vraiment très joli c'est
un très joli village de pêcheur très
touristique quand même beaucoup de resto
c'est oui c'est vraiment ultra
touristique moi j'avais du mal à bien
manger ou quoi parce que c'est très joli
et très réputé
et le papa on est jamais bien sûr alors
moi je suis bien sûr
mais c'est grâce à l'aide
médical mais c'est vrai que
sinon le
[Musique]
papa jeelle plus le pourcentage dans les
mari le trème enfant qui n'est pas du
même père sans que personne le sache
enfin personne le 3è ou déjà le premier
non le
trè je crois qu'on c'est un truc comme
10 % ou un truc c'est c'est un chiffre
de malade en fait quand tu le sais h
ça je suis le deuxième
je pas 3è
ouis le 3è je crois que c'est
euh
c'est quoi le plus gros tour que vous
avez gagné al moi j'ai pas gagné
beaucoup de gros tour un trit de
débile ça de débile c'est le championnat
de Moscou des amateurs en gros c'est
championnat de Moscou moins de 2400
c'est pas si simple à gagner en vrai
c'est déjà pas mal ouais c'est un assez
beau tournoi en vrai mais c'est quand
même un peu de la
merde mais moi je sais
pas des beau trucs ouis mon cada c'était
pas mal c'est un tourno côté de
Barcelone mais dans le circuit catalan
je sais pas trop ce que j'ai cap d'AG
une
fois c'est beau tournois
is je sais pas tourno rapide des trucs
mais sûrement que ma meilleure
performance c'est pas quand j'ai gagné
c'était le le Ravi où j'ai fait sur le
podium où il y av ma medof qui jouait et
tout et je parte numéro et je crois que
é très surpris de ton résultat bah
sûrement oui moi le premier hein enfin
oui mais oui c'était surprenant oui je
sais pas quoi dire donc sûement cétait
ça mon meilleur résultat mais c'est pas
une victoire au final mais mais un
podium oui c'était c'était
bien c'est très beau résultat
ça tu avais fait quoi au dernière ronde
j'avais gagné contre GN Jones avec les
Noirs à la dernière et l'avnière j'ai
gagné avec cl blancs contre grand
pour te dire le niveau de
grand heureusement est é maintenant al
il une phraseis pour ça ça veut plus
dire sur granda que sur
toi ça ça plus dire
quoià wesle il est bien cavalier
cavalier4 ça arrive il se déplace il se
mou vers cette belle case
il va vers H5 alors ça j'aurais pas fait
mais il doit vouloir G4 mais oui G4 ou
F4 quand même et reprendre du
cheval plutôt G4 ouais mais c'est plus
offensif ce qui fait Wesley que ce que
moi j'aurais eu naïvement mais marrant
parce que quand il doit faire nul avec
les Blancs il su tous et quand faire nul
avec les Noirs il il joue pour les
défoncer il joue pour les défoncer c'est
marrant hein
ouais la psychologie c'est tellement
important aux échecs
ouis tiens demand si j'ais gagner un
champion de France jaune en fait jamais
non j'ai alors si enfin oui non enfin
non j'avais gagné un championnat de
France rapide en jeune mais c'est ça été
supprimé après mais voilà ou sinon j'ai
fait TR fois V
champion fait j'ai fait beaucoup de
place d'honneur donc champion plus
hifique possible mais tro fois mais non
jamais gagné mais le champion de France
rapide il était bien il sarê très jamais
jou
pas mais mais organisé sur un weekendi
je sou cétait la Tony Garnier à Lyon sur
de jours et donc bon oui et mais voilà
mais j'étais petit enfin
genre en moins de 10 ans
quoi c'est un bon endroit pour lutter
contre la triche ouais dans le chat WP
quoi ouais le tour du C malheureusement
non c'est en octobre et moi je serais
pas compte de jouer jouer nu s'il fait
pas froid ça n'arangera absolument pas
je me remettrai peut-être même au
parties long tiens pour le coup non je
me lveris souvent tu regardz je suis là
je serais très heureux
quoi ce serait beau
quoi B vas-y cap quoi le jour où il y a
le premier tournoi d'échec en partie
longue où on est obligé d'être nu je
jouerai quoi je reprends la compétition
pour ce
tournoi je serais très heureux quoi je
propose de filmer euh le
tournoi un cavalier
F6 ah c'est bonne partie de wesle pour
l'instant il déplace bien ses pièces
vers la il débarque
quoel qui m'a écrit a proposé une idée
contre la trich je sais plus exactement
quoi prop un truc de
génie
que dans des endroits comme budap dans
des bains
donc tu dois te mettre nu tu vas dans la
flotte nous on t'a préparer des
vêtements pour quand tu sors et une fois
que tu es sorti de l'eau et du machin là
tu peux aller jouer quoi
et pourquoi faut aller dans l'eau avant
pour détruire tes ah ouis c'est truc
pour que tu été nu qu' pourquoi on te
fait pas juste jouer dans l'eau tant
qu'on y est et puis oui on peut te faire
jouer dans l'eau ouais mais après
maintenant les iPhon et tout ça survit à
l'eau
malheureusement il est très très
mal ENF c'est visuel en fait son attaque
à l'AME elle a même pas commencé donc lu
joue de ce côté de les chiqu c'est ça
pas commencé pour les blancs et les noir
on voit qu' sont déjà sont là
coucou faudrail encore finir ou juste
finir par un PERP si jamais mais ça
prend forme G4 qui arrive qui vient
titiller ce pion
H3 prise prend du cavalier
sûrement donc il veut prendre H3 et sur
G pr le H5 pourrait bouger un moment
attaquer le pion faire F7 pour faire
tour G8 et ça arrive massivement on va
dire
ouais il tente de fermer là non juste
moi j'ai des7 en tête al attends est-ce
que c'est ça ouais des7 ligne
main le fou attaque H4 va jouer
instantanément par par Wesley tel que
lui avait imagine imagine
Wesley coup était vraiment pas difficile
Fabien
encore une mauvaise
partie la meilleure partie du match
viment c'était la première première mais
bon il une partie des noir quand même
mais au moins elle est intéressante là
cellel et bon pour l'instant il fait
trois bonnes parties sur
4 il s'est juste trompé dans
l'ouverture et le plug et je pense que
si tu es complètement nu on peut même
détecter on peut peut-être passer au
truc métallique
et vérifier moi j'ai peur des plus
souscutané encore plus que du plug anal
mais ça ça se trouve c'est déjà installé
ouais mais c'est facile à faire ouais
suraintenant il y a même pas de trac de
cicatrice ou non non mais s de Plug Mo
c'est un truc marrant
mais je sais pas trop si tu caches bien
ton jeu mais les
puces dès le fameux tournoi de
reavic avait déjà
fait
bien mais de plus H4
G3 les de tout
g h TU aussi les
F6 question de
goût
sur G3 il veut juste essayer de se
barrer avec le roi faire fou F3 et sur
damage 2 ro F1
dam2 il s'en
allit problme c'est qu'on est pas sûr de
comment il triche au TB pourquoi ne pas
faire
comme en fait je pense que il faudrait
prendre des repentis de la triche comme
conseiller
antitriche mais il a pas de repenti
personne n'avoue quoi oui mais il
faudrait faire un système un peu comme
on fait les ésunis avec le système de tu
balances tout le monde toi tu peux
rejouer on t'envoie même 200000 € enfin
trouver même un m au lieu d'orgiser tour
qui servent à
rien vraiment tu dis ah tiens si si vous
balancez tout le monde eny des preuves
on vous envoie 300000 balles du coup tu
fais tomber tout le monde et les mecs
que tu fais tomber tu les défonces si tu
as pas avoué que tuas fait tomber
personne qu'on fait tomber tu as plus
droit jamais de jouer et en plus après
tu es expert pour aider ouais et puis
les autres fait tu les attaque en
justice tu tu leur défonces leur vie et
celui et celui qui a balancé tout le
monde tu lu files du comme ils ont fait
avec la mafia en fait je pense serait
tellement efficace il un film pas mal je
sais plus le titre bon il y en a plein
mais je ah benah nul la proposé nul
c'est beau bravo Wesley bravo Wesley
Wesley qui va vers la trème Manche déjà
ce ne sera pas une soirée de merde on
est heureux on a au moins une troème
manche alors attends on pour peut-être
en vrai si un Armagedon peut-être là on
serait serait la délectation totale
alors attends attends attends on
va Fabi aan oh il est mieux Fabi allez
va-il gagner à la demande ouais allez
allez c'est tellement une bonne nouvelle
si on a l'armagadon aussi Fab ah bon
nous emballons pas trop vite he Fabi qui
malheureusement a gâché beaucoup de
bonnes positions mais on voit qu'il
s'hydrate bien on voit que les
conditions de jeu sont très difficiles
il fait très chaud 25°gr l'humidité en
dessous de 20 % c'est terrible de jouer
dans ces conditions le PPM monte à fond
on arrive bientôt au 900 attention c'est
que dam G3 c'est le seul coup FAM faut
qu'il il trouve un 3 sur demande oui
demande fa il coulisse allez famille
laiss-toi pas impressionné parce que
Magnus il l'avait peut-être pas vu dam
G3 mais il fait semblant de d'avoir tout
vu et de te on y va on va attaquer ce
roi par on lui fait une sorte de mat de
l'esquel damage 3 tour à 3 tour G3 et
tout le monde oui damage 3 jouer allez
la tour à 3 en plus il adore ce genre de
manœuvre Fabi c'est un peu son trait de
marque trademark je sais pas comment on
dit trademk ah mais aussi G3 qui gagne
la cale ah tu n'as pas de case tuas pas
de cas il pourrait faire G3 il pourrais
faire G3 il pourrait il pourrait ah
attends prend le qure mais bon dmage 5
ou je ne sais
quoi tour à 3 j'im tour à 3 j'aimeais
moi aussi t'emmerde pas fav mais joue te
mets pas mal au temps ah ne nous refais
pas le mais là c'est bien si si si cette
fois il réfléchit pour mettre le le
dernier punch c'est bon
oui donc le film j'avais en tête avec le
conseiller c'est un film avec denzal
Washington
euh là il est très énervé après non euh
ouais ben là c'est le Parin un peu de la
mafia mais il passe sous les radars
pendant hyper longtemps euh avec ouais
c'est bien Fabi
allez on ni que le premier à balancer
serait gagnant bah oui mais c'est comme
la mafia en fait le premier qui balance
il est OK puis toutous les autres se
font défoncer ouais mais juste faut
qu'il balance du monde enfin faut qu'il
donne des tests faut que ce soit
concluant enfin c'est pas genre tu viens
tu balances et on t'envoie du fric enfin
peut-être non non ouis faut les Russel
crro aussi je crois qu'il jouent dans le
film auquel je pense mais ça c'est le ce
système qui marche très très bien le
système qu'on fait les Américains moi
qui regarder plein de documentaires sur
la mafia c'est hyper efficace c'est
d'ailleurs S pour ça c'est American
Gangster le titre du film que après
quand quand il pensait que qu'il y
aurait un un problème il
butait pour ça qu'ils sont entre butés
entre eux ou ouais pour que personne a
balancé rien du tout
h
et tour à 3 iler tour G3 mais je crois
que c'est plus une histoire vraie je
sais pas ou non mais ça ce serait bien
pour lutter en fait faudit trouver un
messen mais après ils ont un petit gang
où ils sont tous au courant les uns et
les autres ils donnent leurs astuces ou
bah déjà tu tu en chopes quelques-uns
puis après tu reproduis quoi si tu es
capable même si tu as triché si tu es
capable d'en lancer quatre ou C on te
c'est déjà bien is te tire d'affaire et
on va un peu te purifier tout
[Musique]
çaou
T3 qui va
arriver G3 pour
l'ARM on
respire pas bien plus déjà W
gagé moi croyais pas tropanchement
pensais qu'il allit suriser tout ça une
journée et surtout les premiers matchs
c'est
trèsant
il a pas jusqu F3 là il faut pas
défendre
Magnus cavali
H6 mais F3 ça l' fort F3
jouer faireour F3 puis on prend enfin tu
su qu ououi B tu suis beaucoup avec non
mais c'est gagnant ça va là il est bien
en avance à la pondule Fabi on est c'est
quand même normal aussi d'être inquiier
vu l'enjeu oui là c'est quand même une
place en final
champion che tour qui qui est au bout de
de tout ça hein donc là il faut gagner
cette partie il faut gagner la prochaine
là il est en double demande d'ailleurs à
Fabi pour rester enve seulement c'est il
est complètement en survie quoi ouais il
s fait tout sur deande après il est très
très bien quoi et s'il survit il faud
encore battre Magnus dans un match en
deux parties et peut-être en trois avec
un autre Armagedon mais peut-être
aurait-il pris l'avantage psychologique
à ce moment ou je crois qu'il suis trop
pour faire ses parties en fait c'est ça
qui m'inquiète allez damage
5 mais moi j'ai ça aussi mais je deme
pourquoi ça marche pas bon pourquoi ça
marcherait pas enfin si trouver
surdemande il me saoule à se mettre mal
au temps h non mais illéchit à fond là
est le for 37 al oui très bonne question
le tochous que c'est pas du tout le même
format c'est que2 parties
malheureusement c'est un peu le format
de ce qu'on voit les premiers jours euh
dans le tournoi c'est très éch plus 3è
set est très éco plus on aurait pu
espérer un 3è set à rallonge en si
parties si parties peut-être
c'est ouis qu'ils ont pas pu se
départager dans les dans les deux matchs
de qure parties tu dis match un peu plus
long
peut-être aura directement beaucoup de
pression est-ce que l'enjeu ne va pas
tuer le je
ou on se remet à rêver
ou on rêve
beaucoup mais pour moi rien que si déjà
il arrive même s' perd il aurait quand
même rempli son rôle ouis
permis
de
[Musique]
plus c'est quoi en
fait ou
direct ça va bien mais fa tu te mets pas
trop mal aut
temp il
se pourquoi il fait ça maintenant mais
je crois qu'il a peur de
Magnus après dam H6 dame F1 fou F4 Tor
G2 qui G4 dame prend C4 sal gueule quce
c'est que c'est t mais il a eu quoi côté
noir ah il s'est barré avec le roi et
tourc mais il sur PR3
ouf dam G2
cache-toiam G2 c'est juste fini t Rach
c'est tu es bien tu défends tout là tu
tu es bien tu fais ton fr quiprès ah
pourquoi tu G4 oui mais je met toi en G2
oui tu cocon tu é es parfait quoi on
n'est pas à l'abri d'une dame noire qui
arrive en H2 qui nous ferait très mal la
prend C4 ouais et ro G2 qui est H3 vas-y
despr 6 peut-être aussi un coup ouais
despr c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal c'est quand même pas mal
on risque de gagner le fou G5 par échec
ah il
gagne bravo
l'armagedonon bon bien sûr avant il y
aura les
enchères on va se délecter de T aussi
tableau et tout géal ouais d'ailleurs
vous pouvez aller switcher un peu sur le
site euh enfin le site chaîne voilà pour
voir un peu cette passe d'armes avec les
enchères et on se retrouve bon je sais
pas peut-être d'ici une dizaine de
minutes à tout de suite ça viz-vous que
vous pouvez pimenter vos parties en
ligne et vous analyser avec des emojis
il vous suffit de cliquer sur l'icône
emoji puis de sélectionner votre emoji
et de cliquer avec le bouton gauche de
la souris sur les chiquers vous pouvez
choisir parmi une multitude de notations
de coup d'animations d'moti et même vos
personnalités préférées du monde des
échecs les émoticones et les emmojis
disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coup et les animation spéciale reste sur
les chiquier jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit
effacée pour se faire il suffit de
cliquer avec le bouton gauche de la
souris sur l'emoji ou de cliquer sur le
bouton tout effacé
essayez-les tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est reparti mesdames et messieurs
c'est reparti c'est Magnus qui a les
blanc contrairement à hier où Fabi avait
les pièces blanches et j'ai l'impression
que son enchère était plus petite Magnus
qui a décidé peut-être de d'avoir est
blanc moi je live officiel en fait et
j'ai pas j'ai pas eu le temps de les
voir en fait les enchères en tout cas
Magnus donc cassé 15 minutes et Fabi 950
qui est peut-être tu par avec 10 qui
joue une une vente ouverte de l'espagnol
alors donc nous on est pour Fabiano he
si je comprends bien pour avoir une
troisème manche bien sû une trè manche
évidemment même famille qu' en peut plus
d'armagadon ben nous au contraire
Ahou on faut qu'on change les noms de
côté
euh ah c'est commandme toute la beauté
de de ce
format dans tout tellement de parties
cou
près bon c'est la théorie hein pour le
moment il d des fois avec fou C5 et
prise F2 des trucs ouais alors là il a
joué avec fou 7 plutôt bon alors dans
cette structure qu'est-ce qu'il y a il y
a la case D4 pour les blancs euh une
petite pression mais c'estès toujours
très solide pour les Noirs c'est une
ouverture pas mal que que kchne jouait
il y a bien
longtemps et souvent les Noirs une idée
ça peut être de jouer F6 pour enlever ce
P5 qui prend de l'espace et euh bah don
un peu des casses pour les pièces
euh fou
C2 il vient il vient attaquer un petit
peu ce cavalio 4 se replace sur cette
longue diagonale je me permets de
demander au chat 8 958 pour Fabi 10 pour
Magnus en fait moi j'ai pas j'ai j'ai en
fait j'étais dans la cine en train
d'attendre ça justement de revenir et
j'ai pas eu le temps de le voir du coup
ça a été montré à quel moment sur le
live en anglais comment est-ce que j'ai
pu rater qu'on essaie toujours avec Fab
d'avoir l'information d'être au courant
et là en fait c'est tout d'un coup en
fait tu m'as appelé tu m' dis mais ça
commence la partie alors que ouais bah
après le live en anglais à 1 minute 30
de décalage he sur la réalité mais
j'étais quand même assez
déçu c'est quoi les armagons et les
enchères je découvre les tournois alors
tu tu découvres pas forcément parce que
ça existe plus ou moins que sur ce
tournoi mais l'armagadon en gros les
blancs sont obligés de gagner mais ils
ont plus de
temps voilà mais en cas de nul c'est le
joueur avec les noirs qui qui
remporte la partie et donc le la
deuxième
manche un peu compliqué expliquer sur ce
format
puis en plus surtout que comme c'est
tous les jours et que c'est tous les
matchs c'est vrai désolé mais comme on
l' beaucoup expliqué on suit un petit
peu mais en gros tu doas te dire que
c'est une partie décisive et si Carl
gagne pas avec les Blancs alors Carana
gagnera la deème Manche et il y aura une
troè manche décisive entre les deux mais
que en deux parties de paravoir un
armagon après donc là ce serait
éventuellement éventuellement et puis
bah si carlen gagne bah il aura il aura
sa place pour pour la finale la grande
finale qui commencera dès demain qui
aura lieu sur de jours donc vendredi et
samedi à partir de 18h comme c'est le
cas quotidiennement ouais donc c'est
normal que j'ai raté le l'interview en
fait ils l'ont quand ils l'ont misise en
fait la partie avait déjà commencé à
cause du délai ah d'accord pour ça qu'on
n' pas pu voir Fab désolé pour
ça c'est une immense déception
évidemment pour nous
ouais c'est vra que c'est quand même
partie intégrante de l'intérêt de ses
enchères ouais ce jeu ce mind game comme
disent les Anglais
ouais c'est eux qui se sont fait avoir
en fait puisqu'ils disent ils étaient
déjà installés à table quand ils ont
montré la capsule
ah qui était
préenregistré en fait je pense qu'il
enregistre tu la diffuse juste untit peu
après ouais là ils ont énormément de
moyens pour ce tournoi c'est génial et
on voit que ça fait vraiment la
différence
hein
Magnus qui vient échanger les dames qui
part pour une finale bon je serai Fabi
je serai pas contre échanger après bien
sûr les blancs aont le coup à4 pour un
petit peu dame rentrer peut-être avec la
tour mais ça m'a l'air suffisamment
robuste côté noir pour ne pas
avoir vraiment moins bien
quoi et on espère nul victoire de
fabiidodor pour se délecter d'un
d'encore un set d'échc comme ça ils
auront joué entre eux ils ont déjà 10
parties on pourrait avoir 13 parties
consécutives entre les deux
hommes mais là malheureusement les
blancs sont
mieux prendre de la ah j'allais dire il
prendre de la tour il a F béc et tour
prend C6 pr qui prend tour D1 roi
F1 ça risque de pas être assez AE aïe AE
AE Aï attention attention attention ah
il peut-être qui B4 on prend 7 qui
D5 mais et tour a 7 fout B4 fou D2 ou
tour4 ou tour 4
ouais je crois qu'on se délecte pas du
tout terrible parti de
merde euh ouais Fabi qui su un peu là
B47 qui est D5 tu as pas tour à 7 a fou
C5 donc tu as que tour
B7 je peut-être pousser ce D4 un peu
trop tôt trop vite je s ouvert tout d'un
coup et ça ouvert la colonne C que ça
faiblesse le pion C7 arrièé et on voit
qu'il se met à réfléchir maintenant
peut-être que de loin il a cru qu'il
avait fou B4 sans trop regarder plus
loin et s dit ah B en fait
non dur à dire mais imprécision du
joueur américain k B4 en tout cas
essayer tour fr C 7 est-ce qu'il va
rebondir en D3 ou en D5 en tout cas sur
D3 aussi D3 t prend7 de toute
façon ça serait plutôt du cavalier D5
alors
ou tour F8 tant pis on défense au fou on
se place au centre et on laisse le
cavalier choisir sa case plus
tard il défend il défend il défend son
fou C éit l'option choisie par Fabiano
carwana qui accuse en retard de 5
minutes mais ça va il encore le
temps position difficile mais
tenable gagner le 3è sera ce soir ambo
ne quitte pas et puis de toute façon il
y aura aussi leè 7 entre West lo et
abdov donc on va se quoi qu'il en soit
ouais ouais se délecter
encore pour le moment c'est la journée
parfaite jusqu'à maintenant on espère
que ça continue ça coche toutes les
cases on est là mon avis à minima je
sais pas combien a de PA ouis 11h c'est
sûr mais 11h3 c'est
sûr j'imagine pas quand même commencer
avant
22h et je sais pas combien aura de pause
effectivement fa quand même que les
joueur puisse se rafraîchir se reposer
là tuas encore au moins un quart d'heure
de partie à moins qu'il y a une gaffe à
un moment où un autre mais oui oui oui
normalement on a un bon qu d' de parti
pause donc au moins d'un quart d'heure
faut quand même une bonne petite pause
que les Jeurs quand même soi frais et
nous propose leurs meilleurs échecs
quand même on parle d'une place en
finale bah pour moi il y a eu C parties
si si Fabiano admettons que Fabiano se
qualifie pour le pour le 3è 7 enfin
reste en vie pour le 3e set ils viennent
de jouer C parties consécutives tu dois
donner au moins une demi-heure de pause
ton mais ça pourquoi pas plus mais tu
t'attendais à combien non mais une
demiheure je suis d'accord mais en fait
pere on pourra donner je sais pas en
fait dur à dire mais
il qui 5 il faut un peu de temps quand
même pour pour se remettre de toutes ses
émotions en plus F6 il joue sur le
clouage c'est pas mal il attaque ce
cavalier mais ça perd il
peé ouais mais ça fait depuis le début
qu' m zé moins qu'il sa mais TR le coup
tu
vois ah je suis
dégoûté il est d raté F7 Fab je sais pas
ouais il su il a raté
ouais alors que moi
j'avais mais j'avais vraiment sans ordi
en plus je suis
dégoûté
mais ça dégoûte quand j'ai le coup quoi
oui D3 j'aimais bien après F6 j'y ai cru
parce que bah pourquoi pas mais c'est
qu'on laisse ce pion passer 1 peut-être
qui pourrait avancer et qui qui qui
avance le se non c'est dommage j'uréette
trè manche mon Fabi qui a quand même
manqué beaucoup de
réalisme allez 6 jouer alors attends
l'ordi ah mais en fait sur une autre
partie l'ORD non non mais là c'est il
est de nouveau là-dessus
tu propos F H4
ou mais cavalier D3 c'est quoi le
problème
cavalier d petre qui D6 il prend un
prend8 ro F8
qui pr
G7
F6 ou pas un coup très inspiré de la
part de Fab mais oui
qui de pauseon d'ailleurs je dire parce
que on répète les conditions de je sont
difficiles pu ça sa d'avoir unadon
fabit fallait s'imposer
avant c'est la
règle c'est que les de jou sur sous la
force je le
comprends ah comme le PSG
hier on a l'impression que ça va aller
puis finalement c'est la
cata cétait pas loin cétait pas loin
cétait pas loin en plus plusig qui
pourquoi tu marques en
fait mais du coup on attendra quand même
un tirage desb 8e de finale qui peut
être savoureux Mo je t'annonce que c'est
Real Sociedad
ouais c'est pas le mie je crois que le
meilleur tirage serait Barcelone ils
sont vraiment naz
quoi
socieddade bon Paris sera plus fort mais
bon ça peut perdre atltico Madrid un peu
même combat après tu as quand même des
grosses et belles équipes tu as du Real
tu as du Bayern tu as du City pas facile
contre cl
déjà il dégoûte Fabiano
bah ben c'est
laissit passer sa chance
peut-être F le se envie de vomir quand
je vois la
caméra on était tellement proche Fab
perfect mais bon c'est pas on quand même
l'autre
match c'est qu'on vivait une journée de
rêve jusqu'à maintenant tous les
résultats étaient positifs pour nous ça
reste une journée plus plutôt pas mal
quand même et Magnus Carlsen en tout cas
quandme un très
beau qualifié pour pour la finale on va
pas le poisser avant avant que de vendre
la peau de l'ours
quoi est-ce queil y aura quand même une
vraie belle pause entre les
ouais mais peut-être un peu moins parce
que là les joueurs ont déjà commencé à
reposé ouais mais est-ce qu'ils ont peu
vraiment peuvent se se reposer pendant
star Magon et je sais pas je sais pas
comment sont les couill c'est peut-être
ser qu'ils ont l'œil àtirrer pour
regarder qu'est-ce qui se passe vu que
le spectacle mérite le coup d'œil
et que c'est vrai il fera peut-être
mieux de faire une petite sieste quand
même pour être pour être bien affuté ils
sont quand même des des grands
professionnels donc je ne sais pas
comment il gère tout
ça
je suis
inquiet Magnus qui réfléchit une belle
position qui a son pion de plus passer
en
E6 il va falloir trouver quand même
comment comment
[Musique]
conclure il a raison de prendre son
temps une belle avance à la pendule
malheureusement y arrivé s sans trop de
de soucis Fabien
Magnus qui nous habitue pas à CH en
général qui tremble pas dans les moments
forts mais peut-être ce so
pour nous offrir un 3è set Fabien dont
tout le monde toute la planète et chiken
rêveo qui a bien remarqué que oui chez
le coiffeur effectivement
pour rafraîchir tout ça tour 4 jouer
plutôt un bon coup je pense attaque le
cavalier peut peut-être se diriger vers
[Musique]
H4 un coup malin joué par le J norvégien
ouis céit le coup principal non c'est
prend à de mais ça va pas aller bien
loin Fabien la tour pe AR peut-être pas
trop vite d'ailleurs mais comment on
conclut tout ça côté Magnus cavalier est
au
bois est facile fait F4 F5 il est bien
raison l'ordi il va droit au but à
l'essentiel sans
fioriture renforce ce pion
passé
ah c'est
dommage c'est dommage
Fabien je partage cette déception
je sais
Fabien es le premier à être déçu voir
même plus que moi
parfois résultat qui met le
se on espère un
miracle mais bon ça serait vraiment un
miracle un peu bizarre avec des k B4
tour t prends tu prends6 que la tour
soit décalé tour C5 et
B4
et en ferm ce cavalier F7 ce diable de
cavalier F7 r C7 tche il bougeend en
f2ac à fond même ça ça l'air dur une T
qui sur la colonne g du cavalier H6
peut-être une petite incertitude un
moment T C6 joué il va attaquer le pion
A6 et surprotéger le pion 6 au passage
peut-être pour que c tour 4 puisse aller
voir ailleurs il don aussi l'acè D6 pour
le cavalier ce coup de tour C6 c'est
quand même beaucoup de
choses lâche ça Fabiano D5 jouet je
crois qu' a D6 D6 probablement très
bien en fait il voulait pas qu'il a D6
qui a F5 mais
bon ve qu' a des 6 tour 7 ouais il a
peut-être un coup comme G4 à ce
moment-là qui donnera la case F5 au
cavalier ilre encore G6 mais bon on sent
que on est au bord du précipice ça de
doit de vraiment craquer s'effondrer
cette position peut sauver la position
sur
demande en tout cas si lui ne la sauve
pas Magnus aurait gagné sur demande
puisquil avait les blanc il était obligé
de gagner
donc très fort dans ce moment là
[Musique]
magnusè il
hésite tente de
fuir alors
peut-être
ouais petite fourchette qui pour se
dessiner fait tour d si changer la
tour C diabless de
tour il veut 7 ah non 7 il
pas tour D7 puis D6 puis 7
puis8 c'est difficile à suivre Fabien la
déception est grande de notre
côté non vraiment magicien des finales
mon toute sa technique dans
celle-là certains joueurs aur laisser
échapper la victoire mais Fabiano qui
pourra nen voouloir qu'à lui-même qui
décide à priori maintenant devrait
vraiment faire le
taf il
jouer attaque la tour jou dame
F1 il ve cavalier F1 cavalier G3 faut
faire nul il tente un dernier truc
hein Fabiano c'est pas mal tenté de sa
part quand
même si naïvement un joueur fait fait
fait tour de il s'en
sort qu' prend 8 en
fait h sur prend 8 la même il doit
sûrement se faire une caisse de fit pour
le roi donner au 4 pour prendre 8 après
être de
de encore du K G5 tour1 après alors
peut-être jolie tentative en tout cas de
Fabiano G4 jouerose dam H6 ici prend la
tour les blancs vont prendre la tour
aussi comment faire maintenant
l'avancer de ce pion le problème
principal des Nord
depuis long
moment5 ramener tout le monde si
possible le RO F7 une fois avancé le
freiner le freiner le freer tant que
possible tu l'arrêtes pas
mais
Fabiano 27 coups encore à jouer pas
facile sera pas les coup les plus
simples de sa vie à
jouer la difficulté de la position dans
laqu il
est une ce de dame
attention bien
peur
fait F5 il ve ramener le C en
F6 ce qui est moche c'est tu fait genre
G5 C F7 k C7 tu peux pas pêcher 8
quoi doubleche double échec
ou
peut-être une idée ah ça marche pas unme
pour pr en fait je pense à un truc de de
fou ouis pour aller faire des échecs ça
et là tu as tu as le perpè h mais
malheureusement il il fait pas t
ou et ton drit éit en H7 ouais ça marcha
aussi ouis
bien joué
Magnus ah tu peux
faire dommage
ouais on a pas grandchose à opposer côté
Noord surtout on a plus de temps là
combien même on
trouverait C7 à
priori 18 secondes pour 25 ou pas assz
prend G7 même sur pr il aura
8 échec et abandon de Fabiano qui
s'incline pour la seconde fois en de
jours consécutivement à l'armé Guedon et
donc Magnus Carlsen est le premier
finaliste pour cette grande finale du
champion de chez tour on se déroulera
demain mais l'action n'est pas terminée
pour aujourd'hui on va voir le 3isè
match bien entendu entre ABF et West
leso on se retrouve bientôt on sait pas
exactement quand donc sur la chaîne
officielle nous on gettete et on quand
ça démarre après la pause
[Musique]
bientôt vous voulez streamer des échecs
comme vos créateurs préférés tels que
bstream Naka ou les surs bis let's go
on le programme de Community streamer de
tess.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience en connectant
votre compte à Chess.com et profiteer de
la visibilité offerte par d'utre
plateformes de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
chess.com/settings/connecting-econs
mettre échec comme catégorie sur twitch
et commencer à streamer bénéficierz
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
Chess.com et apparaîtrez dans notre
liste de streamers en direct votre
profil Chess.com affichera votre stream
twitch qui sera aussi mis en avant
durant vos parties enfin utilisez la
commande community streamer dans le chat
et faites grossir votre audience sans
plus
[Musique]
attendre
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça repart ça repart on suivait sur le
stream anglais toute
l'animation donc pour ce nouveau mini
match en deux parties seulement mais
peut-être avec un Armagedon si jamais il
y a un
partout c'est parti westla est blanc il
est reparti sur E4 il a pas retenté son
coup b3urait pas pu arver une meilleure
pause une fr ah non mais la pause était
très bien
juste attend je pense on a pensé ça
pourit peut-être pousser jusqu'à
22h30 ouais ouais B si tant qu'à faire
mais mais malheureusement voilà on
espère on espère quand même les jouurs
sont quand même bien reposés et vont
pouvoir nous proposer leurs meilleurs
échecs donc on a une fright liver
attaque où les blonds gagné un pion les
sont un peu obligés dans cette Italienne
pour repousser l'attaque et il a jouer
fou D3 donc l'idée de fou D3 c'est de
pouvoir accueillir un cavalier en E4 en
général les nord de Sud donc font plutôt
le modeste en modeste pas tant que ça K5
je m'attendais il est venu en G4 vous
pouvez retrouver l'analyse de la partie
he de
firouja contre caroana qui a été bien
évidemment analysé Fab si vous aimez le
feu le par soin ouais par mes
soins G4 donc oui le coup que la
différence avec le cavalier en D5 G4
c'est qu' peut rebondir vers F4 pour
attaquer le fou D3 et le pion G2 mais il
part sur autre chose qui G4 un coup un
peu plus agressif euh en tout cas W kig5
qui éta attaqué il s'est resitué central
en E4 sur quoi je pense que peuv jouer
F5 probablement je te sens tellement en
joie de
C tu as regardé le live en américain C
don
sourire je te sens heureux Fab ah mais
j'ai découvert un peu un nouveau sport
de ah oui le golf le disque golf là
disque golf je sais plus comment il
l'appelle désoléc un frisbe ouais faut
marquer des paniers de basket mais c'est
un peu du golf parce qu'me de la
précision
euh tuas un disque rouge tuas un disque
noir tu tu tu ça l'air extraordinaire et
Danny dan va l' très fort à ce jeu
déguisé en en pion
ver donc voilà j'ai pu découvir tout ça
pendant la pause
intéressant un beau sport peut-être on
pourrait s'y mettre je su senti très
heureux de ce sport prochains vent on la
porte
sil y en a un prochain mais peut-être
qu'on sera trop en avance sur seront-ils
prêt à ce jeu je crois tu peux mettre
très loin ça pourra volouler dans toute
la salle des disques de partout là qui
disques de
P ah
c'est ça n rend tellement heureux en
fait c'est fantastique je enlever les
échecs du tournoi des
disqu que les pub quoi mais d nous même
notre pub elle a étéit bien pub meup
c'est un grand plaisirasque dommage ce
soit pas quotidien d'ailleurs et donc
figure-toi que j'ai remarqué j'avais
déjà un profil Meetup je connaissais
finalement le site mais je m'en
souvenais pas je l'avis pas assez
utilisé enfin c'est vrai qu'en France on
on utilise pas beaucoup encore cet appli
mais c'est quand j'étais en Espagne que
que je l'avais ouais
euh bref bon mais westle pas facile pour
lui partie he qui se fait un petit peu
prendre à la gorge par Abdou avec cette
variante agressive ce
kg4 position fauolle he un pion de plus
pour les blancs mais il y en a de
partout
ça on écrit un
camouox je sais pas si tu as vu il y a
un nouveau gars qui fait des des des des
shorts sur Youtube du camouox non il cré
lui-même le c'est magnifique quoi il
s'est fait des As avec une voix de de
Macron une voix de Mélanchon une voix de
Zémour ils sont des camoul ils sont des
camoult pour dév
que je vois ça jeis t'envoyer C ouais
c'était très bien cam B belle émission
ah ben c'est fantastique ouais Dame des
4 attention menace mat petit
rock petit qui évite le mat qui met le
roit à l'abri alors jusqu'à quand parce
que la colonnage peut s'ouvrir al qui
est favori d'après toi de ce match
peut-être un petit peu Westley
mais
mais en tout CASD l'air de bien
connaître ce qu'il fait mais
aussi
queas pas trop le
choixfendreant tu dois tout
connaître r
làdedans on verra la fin qui est mieux
mais c'est fou a remis à la mode cette
vente ou fait jouer ça quand tu as tes
propres yeux humains avec les
Blancs bon ça donne pas envie quoi tuas
rien de développer toujours sur une
rangée de après si tu sais tu sais oui
alors de faire donc tuas prends par cœur
tu fais ce qu'il te dit et ça va
mais mais tu aurais pas pu faire tout
seul
quoi non quand tu analyses tout seul tu
es pas du tout sûr de pas de pas louper
une attaque un truc tu suis à analyser
là si tu sais tu sais puis là il sa
ouis bah il fait des TR ça per fousen
enfin de participer au jeu peut-être
devenenir en
E3 et de repousser cette dame alors
qu'il a une erreur c'est le premier à un
point et demi Fab ah oui oui oui c'est
plus qu'un match en deux parties là
attention je corrige ça de ce pas
Fabien et voilà ça on comprend tout de
suite beaucoup mieux le
format
que Wes fait un cours sur ch sable sur
cette
variantei il fait une pierre de
coupoi cour il prend la caass et il
apprend ce qu'il dit il a bien raison
bien raison et j'en ferai de même à sa
place d'ailleurs si un jour on venait à
faire un cours chez sable je je pense
que je l'ajouterai mon
répertoire et tu prendrais la caillass
j'espère C avant
tout il hésite
là je question par j'aurais fait aussi
ça me donnait pas du tout envie
il f prend assez logique je pensere G3
qui peut arriver mais faut 3 pour
couvrir puis on prend
F2 F prend on repousse un peu et au bout
du bout du
bout ça simplifie on aura pas de pion de
plus mais une structure quand même assez
pourri avec qure P isolés peut-on faire
plus
je céit juste pas enfin je vois a T pr
F2 l'ordi mais bon
sinon si t'as
pas il te reprend et ouais je comprends
en fait G3 et il
là tu dois faire dame point F2 prise F2
prise F2 et j'ai j'ai TR quand même et
Caval 4 j'imagine
les dam pr de possible parce qu'on
pourrait craindre un coup comme dame D6
faisant une enfilade mais on peut parer
tout ça avec le fou qui viendra en E3
s'interposer ça bien déchirer tous les
deux déchirer de quoi je sais pas tu
complètement
déchiré non je suis très enthousiaste
parce que je vois enfin je comprend pas
on le serait à moins quoi enfin c'est et
ça quand tu es pas content enfin ouis
gris tu heureux tu es
déchiré récite la gueule
quoi content souffler quoi j'ai réussi à
bien réciter ça je peux bien
m'étirer il a le SAM il se faititer il a
le se
ouais PR2 t PR2 G3 qui Valie au 4 à
venir
on pourrait prendre roi F1 peut-être
pourquoi pas j' fa ro
F1 fin pour toucher le fou C5 peut-être
reprendre F2 par la suite quand on le
voudra on évite de se mettre tout seul
dans un
clouage c'est F1 le coup ouais c'est F1
c'est visuellement je pr f bah c'est sûr
parce qu'en fait tu fais de quand tu
veux et je serai pas cloué je te fais
perdre un temps sur ton fou al est-ce
que je peux même pas te faire C3 puis
roy2 fou
E3 prendre vraiment à la
fin c'est vrai que je ferais bien un
petit C3 personnellement euh
ou alors fou D2 pour d'abord dégager SK
2 à5envoy en
B7 c'est bien ah ok j'aurais fait F2 et
C3 perso j'aurais pas été aussi subtile
que l'ordi mais
c'est subtile F 2 F C3 c'est bien
joué
plus déchiré des deux c'est Kevin quoi
c'est magnifique en
fait plus déchiré que
toi tien ça pensa qu'on est pas du tout
allé manger le mafé au marché de Noël
non mais on a été déçu il y a 2 ans oui
mais bon peut-être c'est à nouveau
peut-êtreon va faire je pense qu'on va
faire le mafé quand même
faut quand même qu'on aille chez Madame
le manger la fondu oui mais on a
peut-être encore du ma ou alors on peut
faire du madame le demain peutêtre on
peut aller chercher du mafé emporté et
demain soir pour la première mange de la
finale on se délecte d'un mafé pendant
la
pause à voir les pauses quand elles sont
elles sont pas très longues pour bien
manger le
mafé aprè onuter le restaurant mafé le
ouais fantastique
par que là pour le moment on a pas eu le
comme tu pars dimanche et pas lundi on a
puir le dimanche soir sinon encore pour
se
baffer tu vasir déplacer ton
train se délecter du mafé mais c'est
vrai qu'on a complètement oublié on l'
sorti de l'équation
mais c'est mainant il est un peu dépassé
par mais surtout qu'en janvier tu ne
seras pas là pour commenter la la
première étape de
Ch tour 2024 ou ouais dommage
je j'ai naivement prévu des vacances et
euh c'est vrai que je me serais enquéri
plutôt de du calendrier j'aurais
probablement sauvé les dates mais écoute
j'espère
que non j'ai un stage après avec Seb à
Paris Paris en plus ouais et non tu
tombe vraiment pas pendant oh là là là
là peut-être je pouris faire un jour ou
deux au milieu à distance mais ouais
c'est c'est compliqué mais tu vas quand
en Guadeloupe
euh
le 11 janvier mais tu seras pas rentré
le 31 bah si mais je serai rentré le 26
après j'ai le stage avec Mazo et cetera
et bon c'est pour ça que aïe aïe aïe AE
c'est ce stage en fait qui tombe mal oui
mais est-ce que tu vas avoir des gens
qui vont venir à ton stage et qui
rateront alors al est-ce que tu nas pas
peur de de finalement d'être vide pour
ce stage ben écoute le tirer mort B il
le stage est plein hein normalement mais
c'est vrai que bon faut peut-être pas
trop dévoer le calendrier il pourrait se
désinscrire ah finalement euh ça serait
bien que ce soit à 18h comme ça on
pourrait faire les deux une journée
parfaite sera
18hou bon bon saué mais c'est pour ça
que les gens sont inscrits en fait on
aura on aura un petit restaurant Le
samedi soir en plus on pourra suivre
peut-être sur l'écran en même temps
entre deux bouché
les stages à Paris qui marche vraiment
bien ouais toujours beaucoup de monde
dans les autres villes parfois moins
enfin ça va mais mais Paris en tout cas
il y a rien à dire ça marche très très
bien on va tenter de s'exporter proche
de la Suisse la prochaine fois en mars
on verrail une soirée mafé si on trou un
stau ma fait pourquoi pas mais et puis
j'espère que non pourra faire notre
notre soirée ici pendant les candidats
si deux soirées d'ailleurs finalement
une soirée barabu puis une soirée mafée
comp un peu nos expériences mais tout à
fait c'est quelle fréquence il sera de
stream de toi comme ça malheureusement
trop rarement la machine l'année
prochaine il y en aura que c dest non il
en un non c il y en avait 7
même deux
je ouais ah si t mis un coup là coup
moral ouais non parce que bon en fait
plus il y a de tournois plus on est bien
sûr de qui se qualifie voà il y en aura
que quatre quatre pauvres
tournois on pourrait avoir des surprises
alors peut-être
mais j'espère qu'il vont quand même bien
division 1 division 2 tout ça c'est mais
c'est pas encore annoncé mais oui je
pense que c'est quand même un point
positif ces
division stage pour quel niveau tout
niveau en
fait on fait plusieurs groupes comme je
en fait c'est dur de faire des stages
tout niveau s'il y a un seul enseignant
parce que bon bah là si c'est trop
disparate certains vont s'ennuyer pour
d'autres sera trop dur en étant
plusieurs tu réartis et
voilà donc voilà ça c'est des stages sur
le weekend il peut y en avoir plus long
comme celui qu'on avait fait avec Kev
enfin ceux qu'on avait fait avec Kev ça
soit Lisbon peut-être en préparation
d'illeurs pour l'été prochain il y en a
peut-être un pour l'été prochain on ne
sait pas encore mais on vous dira le
plus vite possible en tout cas soyez à
l'affu si jamais ça venait avoir lieu se
déplacé dans les pays
baltes on serait très bien hein
avec des nuit blanche bah c'est beau
ais je crois que le soleil se lève à 3h
du matin se couche à minuit et se lève à
3h ah les nuit son courtes mais j'ai vu
des photos de 3h du mat
ouis c'est l'équivalent d'ici en ce
moment à 7h30 quoi hjà une un peu de lum
lum ouais c'est pas un peu ouais non
c'est il fait jour
ouis en tout cas Wes qui fait fou des
deux et c'est TR un peu le truc que
j'aurais peut-être fait moi mais n pas
bah oui mais bon le C c'est roi H8 alors
c'est bien comme ça sur ro 2 tuasses
bien tout rche un mat pourquoi pas ro H7
il a peur des k G5 écha peut-être moi je
fais ro sans
réfléchir et ro sur ro 2 il veut quoi4
G4 ouais c'est ça et tu as pas de
tu te fais enchaîner la tronche en fait
oui bon une fois que tu as vu mais
j'aurais jamais même songé quoi j'aurais
pas fait en fait non c'est
ouais bah rochè peut oui ça je veux bien
mais chite c'était impossible ais coup
chite ça paraît vraiment
débile tu le stage à Paris les gens
non mais il est vraiment complet he pour
le coup c'était le dernier weekend de
janvier en fait si vous voulez vous
renseigner
bah bah je les annonce sur Twitter en
général ou un peu sur les réseaux
sociaux que j'ai Instagram machin euh
euh il y a les miens et il y a ceux de
Seb vasy
euh et sinon bah faut suivre aussi sui
de Kev parce que si on en fait un CT
avec Kev bah c'est bon keV en parlera
sûrement aussi mais mais bien de suivre
un peu ouais sur les réseaux mais je sûr
que si on en fait de un tous les deux à
Paris on peut faire 100 personnes mais
faud qu'on trouve la salle c'est dur
déjà une salle de vin pass enfin mais
ouais si on trouve une salle on peut
vraiment faire hein sans personnees je
suis sûr qu'on fait on fait tu as vu la
BUP Sya ou avant tout il y avait 160
personnes c'est c'est 35 minutes quoi
c'est différent mais genre c'est non non
on pourrait vraiment faire un un petit
stage ou un gros ENF un stage quoi sur
le
weekend ça serait beau ça serait
vraiment un beau un beau défi un beau
challenge
non ça devrais faire nul cette part non
mais si on trouve C sort de salle à
Paris on pourrait faire un grand stage
euh avec euh avec ouais enfin je sais
pas on y réfléchira mais oui ça peut
être
cool différence re roi chut et roich
j'imagine qu'à un moment donné il y a un
fou D3 qui doit changer quelque chose
alors que quand le roi était en H8 bah
comme il avait pas de math il était plus
à l'abri mais bon c'est bah c'est c'est
un truc d'ordi hein un truc d'ordi en
vrai c'est r tous les jours mais c'est
tellement pas intuitif r enfin ça sera
mauvais tellement souvent que même là tu
as pas envie de d'investiguer l'idée
quoi
mais
compliqué ton cerveau il refuse rite en
fait juste ouais je veux pas voir
ça pas pris en B2 le C 5 attaquer si tu
te souviens bon pourir TR en arrière
pour montrer faire de flèches et
et et revenir vite au direct euh en fait
le K 5 est attaqué donc quand on esquiv
avec la tour on a une double attaque et
tu pourras pas sauver les deux donc tu
vas perdre soit ton fou ton cavalier
donc ça vaut pas le coup pour un pion et
et
voilà 6 s personnes à de c'est pas très
encadrant ah mais l'objectif c'est pas
que ce so encadrant c'est que ça
rapporte de la caillass non mais c'est B
personne non mais d'habitude enfin dans
les stages habituels oui c'est c'est
limité en fait en N de places là 100 ça
serait une autre démarche je sais pas si
on appellerait ça stage ou Masterc
plutôt d'ailleurs mais oui un stage
d'habitude tu tuas peut-être allez une
personne pour 10 étudiants vraiment 15
max
euh là oui ça serait peut-être pas stage
le terme mais ça serait sympa on
pourrait choisir des thèmes faire des
trucs cool enfin ouais on pourrait faire
quelque chose de
sympa serait pas le même
prix tu 100 personnes tu peut-être faire
250 € les les de jours je puis à Paris
sur 2 jours vous faites combien 450 4
ou c'est quand même une grosse
différence oui ça serait moins
cher c'est pas le
même pas le même esprit enfin ser deux
choses différentes quoi peut-être
complémentaire c'est pas
pareil mais bon on a quand même ta
présence
qui lumineuse
oui
mais c'est sû que c'est pas la même
chose pas très encadrant non c'est moins
encadrant mais c'est lumineux mais tu
rencontres plus de gens aussi je pas
c'est
différent une expérience avec enfin bon
on l'a pas encore fait on sait pas mais
on peut imaginer ce qu'on pourrait faire
moi j'aime bien les trucs avec beaucoup
de monde je trouve c'est intéressant
quand tu peux le faire je veux dire
parce que tu rencontres vraiment
beaucoup de person
as plus de chance sur 100 personnes de
trouveres
crochure personne que AC 20 oui comment
tes chances s personne tu as vraiment un
brassage qui devent vraiment
intéressant c'est de choses différentes
mais le Stade de France des échecs en
quelque sorte exactement
qu class comme
marrake éta là Veran par je conis pas
le par 25000 € 25000 € 20% plus 20000
location d'une salle comme ça sur de
jours plus que 12000
déjà plus que 6000 et MO encore les 60%
d'impôt qui
viule 2400 € rap mais je pense c'est
sans compter les faux frais
estce rentable en fait au final
peut-être 2000 € le weekend ou 1500000 €
c'est bien enfin c'est très beau hein
mais oui c'est pas
25000 souent souvent il y a cette faute
de faitte ouais
c'est de 25000 à 100 quo instantanément
quoi non mais c'est vrai que le net brut
pas évident quand quand tu as pas
l'habitude quoi
ou puis les dépenses les machins mais
oui faut louer les salles hein ça c'est
c'est pas cadeau quoi il y a le voyage
le machin c'est pour ça que j'écouté
l'hôtel peut-être et
ouais bref onant à nos
moutons nos moutons qui joue donc quatre
P désolé pour les Noirs mais des pièces
relativement
actives il jou fou B3 F
attaquer t défend son pion peuttre un
petit roi E2 pour activer ce roi ça pe
être simple d'attaquer toutes ces
faiblesses parce que les pièces noires
sont bien actives bien centrales cont
contrôle beaucoup de cases
ok fait fou il
estchange
ah bon c'est ça fait nul malheureusement
je pense queesle va essayer mais oui il
devrait pas gagner euh en tout cas match
serréin comment Com Com on
l'attendait il on serait plus qu'à une
partie de l'armagedon peut-être quoi
qu'il en soit on a une partie de
l'armagedon
mais dire que nul quand même ça donne
plus
d'Armon et malheureusement non la finale
sera mais ce sera demain et après-demain
sur de jours donc c'est pour de bonnes
raisons que ça n'enchaîne
pasent très heureux he de vous présenter
la finale demain et
après-demain peut-être un peu court sur
de jours
d'ailleurs finir dimanche sur 3
jours après c'est déjà quand même bien
de l'avoir sur 2
jours quand même bien se
délecter
en tout cas je sens très heureux là
parce qu'on remp nos objectifs plusun
ouais on aura eu notre journée
parfaite les deux armesadon les machins
on n'est pas loin
là trè manche qu'on espérait vraiment
y a-t-il avantage bah symboliquement
pour les blancs même légèrement j'ai
envie de dire parce que regarde tous ces
pions noirs un peu partout en G7 en E5
en C6 en A7 donc ils sont tous isolés
donc il peuvent pas créer de chaîne pour
se défendre les uns et les autres du
coup il peuvent potentiellement être
faible contrairement blanc qui ont une
masse de pion là-bas sur les LAM donc
voilà ça serait ça l'avantage des blancs
après bon tu vois il reste plus 50
pièces les pièces noires sont actives
elles te prennent des cases elles sont
quand même pas mal coordonnées donc
c'est c'est pas facile pour les blancs
mais euh c'est que ce SK G5 finalement
ce soit devenu même quand tu connais
bien avec les noirs et tout ouais c'est
pas si facile d'égaliser ouais c'est
vraiment un truc dangereux peut-être
qu'il faut vraiment faire fer 5 au 3e et
et tu évites
oui alors que avant c'était vraiment un
coup piège uniquement il joue à à piètre
niveau j'ai envie de dire maintenant euh
non maintenant
c'est on va dire que le blason de
laavante a été
redoré et de fort belle
manière qualité de l'air aujourd'hui est
complètement
déplorable c'est vrai que c'est terrible
ça c'est ils sont plus que deux mais bon
ouais mais bon comme ça
pas IR depuis le début de la semaine je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas c'est vrai
que on a déjà vu ce cas de figure il y a
quelques jours tomber en Lambo quoi
c'est euh et du coup on peut avoir des
surprises par la suite de la partie
parce que peut-être les Jeur seront un
peu moins réactifs un peu moins le
cerveau en ébullition pour trouver les
bons coups sousension avec peu de
temps
tout cas c'est
beau mais ouais n quand même encore êre
vigilant c'est pas encore nul à actter
B3 donc il a sauvé son pion B2 qui est
attaquer attaquer le cavalier et il a le
pion C6 attaquer donc il va se réfugier
en A5 pour le défendre mais peut-être
qu'un moment on pourrait faire B4
attaquer ce cavalier et aller ensuite
prendre prendre C6 pour l'instant il
monte son roi donc c'est plut pas
bête le4 jouet peut-être on va pouvoir
fixer ce pion là sur case
blanche tour 3 retour peut-être pour
faire G4 il peut peut-être la gagner
hein ouais ah ou il est capable
techniquement il joue bien B ils joue
tous bien à ce niveau mais il fait c G4
direct ben pourquoi pas c'est pas plus
mal que ce que je proposer
j'imagine donc les Noirs B sont en échec
donc soit ils Bou le RO so il font fou
Pr G4 j'aime pas trop mais pr G4 tout
reprend et après on serait bien placé
mais peut-être il va faire ça pour faire
G5 et roi F5 et s'activer le mieux
possible chance qu'il va la gagner il
nous éloignerait peut-être
dansagon c'est très dommage mais bon
après vu que c'est quand même notre
joueur notre chouchou un peu de la
compétition on pourrait pas lui en
vouloir on serait quand même contre lui
pour la dernière partie bien évid
obligatoirement heureux pour lui dans
l'arme à gedon on le quittera pendant
quelques quelques
minutes qu c'est tant mieux pour nous si
une victoire ça donne vraiment du du
cœur à Lage sinon on est pour les nuls
oui c'est plus difficile ah c'est vrai
que tu es pour les nul tu es bon
ouais tu veux tous échang tu veux pas de
spectacle alors que là bon il faudra
gagner sur
demande pour rester en vie dans ce
tour
évidemment dommage hein d'ailleurs après
avoir gagné la première manche de fort
belle manière tour G3 bien joué je me
questionnais on pe jouer un B4 avant
mais il y a peut-être du roi F5 des
coups intermédiaires comme ça t G3 il se
replace en tout cas la tour qui peut
être à nouveau mobile à droite à gauche
surt à droite pour les vers H3 et
rentrer dans le camp
adverse que ser pas finalement notre
nouveau joueur
fétiche un beau style
ouais il fait des nul sur
dememande
TR de faire nul ça qui me plaît chez
luient rien à des parties
quo de rien en
fait c'est un côté un peu
marrant estil temps de faire B4 toujours
pas par que B4 on gagn un P mais bon
libère le
Pr il le fait il fait B4 C4 prend C6
donc il a gagné un pion il attaque le
pion
E4 de Hérisson que je montre à
Fabien faire fout des 7 maintenant petit
échec le score n'est pas à jour bah si
il m'a fait peur mais c'est la troème
Manche
[Musique]
hein c'est la trè manche c'est qu'il a
une manche hier remportée par abdorov la
manche qui a commencé à 18h remportée
par West leso et donc on est dans le le
T si tu veux en quelque sorte la trisème
Manche et malheureusement
ultime et malheureusement le exactement
alors on peut espérer quand même qu'il y
a un partout et que ça se finisse à
l'ARM Guedon pour prolonger un petit peu
plus le le plaisir mais
évidemment mais malheureusement je dois
dire que pourra pas aller au-delà de de
trois parties dans cette manche maximum
maximum mais on se retrouvera demain
demain mais à 18h pour la
finale ça sera une fort belle affiche
quoi qu'il en soit soit Wesley so opposé
à Magnus Carlsen soit ça sera son
adversaire le jeunousbeck le talentueux
nodiarbeck abdousatorof qui visera
Fabien à la fin du mois le titre de
champion du monde de Blitz
rap peut-être plus le Blitz histoire
de une ligne à son palmarès bon il
cracherait pas sur un titre en rapide
bien évidemment mais ça fera un nouveau
titre ce qui qui fera s très
plaisir estce que là c'est ce n'est pas
l'armagadon encore l'armadon viendrait
cas d'égalité après deux
partie départager les les deux
hommes qu'est-ce qu'il veux sur roi
G6 t
7 tour 4 ah
oui il veut
ça moins d'une
minute commence à chauffer pour ne dire
bec il fait 3 ah fou B5 il veut roi tour
des deux et euh ouais
après 4
ah pas évident de penser que 4 ça
gagneut compr qu'on peut rien
faire il est fort
won prend juste pous ou qu'est-ce
que je prendra complètement changé
d'avis en fait
il
prend il prend ro
prend prend trme c'est qu'il a ro G6 F6
maintenant il fait sa petite danse et ça
le problème les cou donc fautut-être
partir avec ce fou vers B5 pour bloquer
le cavalier complètement je crois F B5
c'est sûr ouais5 ça bien-êre tour d de
RO prend 3 tour prend G2 mais après on
pourrait faire du Tour à 7 et essayer
d'envoyer ce pion a ce serait beau on
westle qui réfléchit moment important
n pas un peu fatigué des échecs depuis
samedi bah écoute moi ça fait quasiment
4 mois là que je commente nonstop tous
les jours je crois j'ai j'ai dû faire un
weekend sur trois ou quatre et
évidemment je n'en ai pas marre j'espère
qu'il y a toujours plus de parties je
suis très très heureux de de continuer à
avoir des joueurs quand même t off so
Carlsen caroana chaque semaine qui
reviennent jouer dans des tournois qui
sont toujours plus intéressants les uns
que les autres surtout que là en plus on
a la chance d'avoir un format très ur
donc c'est c'est fantastique on n pas
l'habitude d'avoir autant de d'armagedon
ah qui va peut-être faire que
nul donc là c'est vraiment
extraordinaire il a juste repris son
temps pour faire ça et pour faire un
petit tour au ah non
t 6 mais C4
D4 il veut tenter il veut tenter c'est
pas t 6 en tout cas il va le jouer c'est
sûr C4 3 4 c'est sûr aussi il peut
peut-être après faire tour à 3 E7
laisser perdre le truc c'est bouffer
G5 il tente il tente tout he westle
c'est pas mal il a beaucoup réfléchi
avant de de choisir cette ligne mais
c'est plutôt pas mal joué de sa part je
dois dire pour l'instant il a conservé
de pion de
plus c'est bien pour nous he parce que 3
secondes de rajou par par coup donc plus
il y a de coup jouer dans la partie
Fabien plus ça
dure il y a trois jouet donc attention
le fout7 maintenant et en prise il
faudra sûrement le défendre tour à 7 on
peut le perdre mais après le cavalier un
peu loin pas facile deiser une telle
pièce pour stopper après les pions le
roi blanc qui peut aller vers E5 et
chercher
[Musique]
g545
aussi de toute façon déjà liquidion G5
qui peut nous mettre en danger de perdre
c'est pas mal attention il faut jouer W
faut pas
tomber il joue sur demande
Fabien
c'est bien joué va forcer il va forcer
les avancer il va gagner temps pour
ramener le cavalier et affaiblir ramener
vers son roi pour les prendreê le
laisser là d'ailleurs
maintenant c'est ce qu'il fait mais il
essaie ah non ça fait nul nimporte
où8 Bou ah serait bien qu'il joue encore
quelques coups de ah malheureusement non
aur pu aller chercher encore les 42
secondes côté nvec bon du coup du coup
partie nulle donc dans cette première
partie qui était vraiment halente et euh
ben écoute la prochaine le vainqueur
serait qualifié on espère quand même la
nul vous l'avez bien compris pour avoir
droit un ultime Armagedon dans ces
demi-final qu'on espère donc vivre avec
vous que un très beau message
qui'empêche c'est vraiment la synthèse
de tout ce qu'on peut faire de pour
compliquer les règles tournois à point
pour se qualifié différence de cadence
fer bracket des armagedons des des
matchs en des trucs en r Robin ouais
mais c'est vrai que c'est beau il a des
se qui ont des points différents enfin
c'est c'est la be énormément de règles
différentes qui fait que on doit
s'adapter chaque jour chaque jour et y a
là il y a plus de loser bracket tout
d'un cou qu' en a tout le temps donc
c'est tu ne sais pas ah mais tu dois
être tu dois V c'est là qu'on VO les
bons élèves ou pas ceux qui ont suivi
parce que pas évident pas évident mais
bon je pense qu'on a plutôt bien compris
ce qu'on ce qu'on voyait là et et voilà
on a une nulle et donc on sera supporter
de la nulle pour la deuxème partie ce
qui sera pas simple pour nous en Espagne
partie très insipide des échanges rien
quoi mais mais qui dure longtemps aussi
mais pas facile avec
son quand Mme le feu
chiqué il faudra que Wester réussisse à
l'éteindre
non on aura préféré un Guiri en face là
guisso ça aura été on a augmenté nos
chances mais et bon retrouve on se
retrouve très vite pour la suite merci
tout à de suite saviez-vous que vous
pouvez pimenter vos parties en ligne et
vous analyser avec des mojis vous il
suffit de cliquer sur l'icône emoji puis
de sélectionner votre emoji et de
cliquer avec le bouton gauche de la
souris sur les chiquers vous pouvez
choisir parmi une multitude de notation
de coup d'animation d'émoticone et même
vos personnalités préférées du monde des
échecs les émoticones et les emmojis
disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coup et les animations spéciales restent
sur les chiquers jusqu'à ce qu'elles soi
effacé pour ce faire il suffit de
cliquer avec le bouton gauche de la
souris sur l'emoji de cliquer sur le
bouton tout effacé
essayz tous et et amusez-vous bien sur
[Musique]
Chess.com
c'est reparti mesdames et messieurs avec
nordirbeck et qui n'a pas répété D4
c'était très mal placé dans la manche
précédente il est beaucoup suer avec les
Slaves de
Westley et donc donc qui joue 4 et
Westley qui joue la solide
berlinoise VI jouer D3 pour pas qu' a de
finale il l'air très
heureux il regard tout
sourire de toute façon il est toujours
tout sourire West donc on espère la nul
hein voilà on vous le dit franchement
hein par qu'on aimerait quand même cet
Armageddon décisif et pouvoir se
délecter encore un petit moment on
pourrait peut-être même finir
vendredi passer minuit ouais
donc cette position d'espagnol et le
coup fou à 4 qui peut surprendre plus
d'un alors que le fou n'était pas
attaqué en B5 mais souvent on sait
qu'après C3 il se redirige vers C2 ou B3
et puis surtout ça évite le coup CAH
des4 des Noirs qui aurait attaqué le fou
B5 alors que là on pourrait juste
prendre le pion de 5 euh et se servir de
ce cadeau faire sur un plateau
plateau d'argent même
ouais peut-être même d'or r tour 8
peut-être qu'il veut d'ailleurs un C
des4 à venir donc C3 pourrait être un
coup ici pour les blancs
voilà est-ce que wesle va jouer avec D6
ou D5 D5 qui doit être possible
traitement plutôt moderne de de la
position a l'activité au détriment
peut-être de la structure de pion voilà
voilà c'est ce qui joue ça donne envie
quand même des5
qui souffle un peu quoi
ce qui aurait sûrement aimé le petit
dame des4 dame 4 quand même bjour la
berlinoise ce n'était pas du
goût
nordbec le gen ousbec
abdf
et oui tu GJ qui c'est vraiment top
toutes ses pauses en tout cas on a bien
le temps de se reposer avant chaque
partie oui et c'est surtout aussi pour
les joueurs comme on nous le disait dans
dans le chat un petit peu plus haut joue
à ce niveau tu serais bien content
d'avoir une pause et c'est exactement ça
les joueurs à ce haut niveau ont
vraiment besoin d'avoir ces posstes qui
sont en réalité indispensables pour
pouvoir déployer leur leur niveau de jeu
et là c'est vraiment le strict minimum
qu'ils
ont
bref petit
H6 petit coup H6 oui bon mais en place
sa sa carapace avec les Noirs veut pas
laisser la C G5 au blanc
ça à peu près égal comme
position oui mais il peut se passer
encore plein de choses c'est pas encore
d' Dr
malheureusement diable de Nord qui va
tout
tenter on l' déjà vu à l' lâche pas
jusqu'auau dernier moment donc Wesley va
devoir être être affuté il a l'air
serein cel dit he à la caméra là il il
plane un peu un aigle il a mis
le peut-être l'éclairage qui le gêne
ouais des fois dans les studios il y a
des il y a des lumières comme ça qui
gîent ouais il construit une sorte de de
de petite casquette
manuelle
ok jouer H6
ouais en tout cas il c'est bien sorti
l'ouverture non ça va ça bien sûr non
mais même pour les l c'est pas si simple
parce que T 1 tu aimes bien le faire
automatiquement mais il y a peut-être le
cavalier qui va arriver en G4
tuas faire tour de bon je sais
pas
mais c'est le coup que tu envie de faire
en fait de base le T pour renforcer4 et
te faire le petit trajet avec le et
C ah oui on ira vers l'ARM
ser ser
soulagé mais c'est tellement
pas
mon style
de
nordirbec je sens faire un tour au de
quoi alors qu'on nous souffle dans Leide
que la qualité de l'air s'améliore
enfin
il pr
[Musique]
PR4 ça
reprend les deux sont sûrement possibles
pour les
blancs bien reprendre du cavalier mais
non pas du tout me fais
mentir et reprendre du
pion a 5 jouer vouit pas du coup B4 et
ça
s'entendent c'est égal
hein al peut-être dame C2 avec les
Blancs histoire de se mettre en place
pour jouer après cavalier F sortir fou
C1 mais euh ouais mais il peut se passer
des choses
hein et tu on dit que l'humidité est
très faible mais hier on est on a on a
eu été à 17,9 %
hein c'est quoi le tau norm par Akan on
est à peu près hein pas te disent que V
c'est un Amam ou un ou un
désert la mê c'est c'est très humide
non je voulais dire un Sona peut-être
ouais
un Sona
oui que je Sona tuas pas son qu'il est
trop d'eau
quoi mais je sais pas je suis pas du
tout au courant des taux d'humidité dans
l' non je sais pas non plus tiens je
regardis un petit peu
le mot culture culture humidité
quoi 70 % d'humidité la CAN quand
même al c'est peut-être la nuit et tout
ça
mais 70 % mais c'est pas énorme paraî
bizarre 70 % c'est beaucoup pas beaucoup
100 % c'est c'est c'est de l'eau non
ouais bon on n pas dans l'eau non plus
là la qualité de l'air est
bonne
CAN
nonité
valide et met t d'humidité
appartement
% il te
disent l' doit pas être trop sec pour ça
qu'il est recommandé de maintenir au
taux d'IT com 40 et 60 % donc c'est vrai
que 20 % c'est
vraiment c'est
es sont bien en de ça de ce qui pourrait
faire et c'est vrai que c'est dommage de
mal utiliser ce boîtier
hing fort fort utile d' toutes les
indications de ce qu'il faudrait pour
pourre les conditions optimales et pas
arriver à humidifier cette
a ils sont pas en distess
respiratoire écoute ils ont pas l'air
trop mal à la caméra mais oui forcément
forcément ça doit jouer à un moment he
dans la prise de
décision il sont il sont ils sont soumis
quand même un
stress un effort intense et
[Musique]
donc pas évident il a jouer tour B8 un
coup un petit peu mystérieux quand même
il doit vouloir du B5 à un moment ou un
autre prend B54 ouais mais bon pour
l'instant j'ai qu' y a y prend donc
euh on n'y est pas encore mais
euh à venir
peut-être j'ai TR
jouet
là ça joue en fond de cours
ouais très fond de cours mais ouais est
là qui bon bon ça va
maisille nous chercher la petite nulle
quand même
he je sais pas exactement com va
s'agoncer là
euh mais j'ai ouais comme je dis j'ai
pas tout à fait tout compris au coup
tour
B8 vu que c'est très métrique c'est pas
très grave
j'imagine mais 100 % humidité en fait ça
va être le taux maximum que qu' peut y
avoir d'humidité dans l'air j'imagine
qu'en fait il y a un taux d'humidité
maximum ça je sais je l'ai appris dans
cours de je sais plus
quoi bah du coup après ça changera
l'état peut-être de non un moment donné
ou l'air ne pe plus dans l'air plus de
l'air quoi mais en
fait c'est mathématiquement ça peut pas
dépasser en
fait c'est pas mathématique c'est
physiquement ça peut pas
dépasser les REP sont F en
D6 quelques cou énigmatique se succède
chez westleyutre qu'il a envie de mettre
le cavali E7 proposer l'échange des f
cas blanche aller vers G6 par la suite
une cas6 sera quand même
mieux un peu les ailes coupé à cause de
spion C3
si encore nul aujourd'hui pour la petite
anecdote il y aura toujours eu des
armagueddons au moins un Armageddon dans
tout le tournoi à chaque ronde à chaque
ronde ou match ah oui oui enfin il y a
au moins eu toujours un armagadon
ouais ce qui est intéressant stat
intéressante c'est que les joueurs
vraiment très proche et C slot on aurait
pu avancer sans arme à Gon il y a
toujours eu un arme à
gison non on a des matchs très serrés à
chaque
fois
ça 100% après ça condense l'air puisque
l'air sature en eau c'est ça l'air
sature en E en fait
donc condensation l'ç en fait
ok d'ailleurs en fait ce que je crois
comprendre ce qu'on c'est que selon la
température la même quantité d'eau va
pas être compter pareil oui mais bon
j'is quand même à chaque fois un taux de
100 % un tau auquel tu es tias pas 102
200 % d'
d'eau et ben non alors cavalier E7 jouer
propose l'échange des fous ça on a bien
compris l'histoire de ce fou des6 et
cavalier H4
jouer qui veut peut-être se rediriger
vers cette case
F5 chauffer en appartement à son taux
chuté c'est sûrement les chauffages he
qui font
chuter et qui don met dans ses
conditionition
de de sécheresse
extrême et a 0 % tu meurs ou
pas est-ce possible sûrement mais je
sais pas genre tu es est ce qu'on a ces
conditions de 0 % autre que
théoriquement
parlant
intéressant en tout cas grâce àing on
apprend des
choses qu'on se questionne sur des
sujets bon on n'y connaît rien on n a
pas forcément pensé de base donc ils
disent oui mais ils disent oui tu meurs
c'est que là fait ils sont proches de
crever quoi à 20 % près quoi mais
pourquoi si à 0 % on
crève que c'est peut-être une info de
chat j'aimerais j' savoir plus à ce
sujet quoi sinon
bonçon que chaque fois j'ai mené une
enquête avant d'aller dans un lieu pour
pour être à peu près sûr du taux
d'humidité et pas être trop mal
quoi
en West qui nous fait le taf pour
l'instant il fait un petit dame D7 à
tour je crois je crois qu'il tend un
piège diabolique à son adversaire
dame
est-ce que nB va échanger les dames
dirig on peut-être vers une petite
nuulle bon nous c'est tout ce qu'on
souhaite bien évidemment
ou euh vat-il faire marche arrière ou un
coup comme A4 pour la défendre ça bon
c'est de son ressort un coup comme dame
2 semblerait peut-être aussi
envisageable prend prend C F5 je pense
qu'il va échanger remettre le fond F8
magnifique fou F8 qui va tout
couvrir on pourrait avoir un ensuite
pere un CAV qui vient vers C5 ou ro H7
et G6 pour chasser ce cavalier F5 actif
et peut-être des échanges massifs deis
pièce lourde qui reste les tours le long
de la colonne
D seule colonne ouverte de l'
chiquier
une bonne chance de voir une nul mais
c'est pas encore fini qui s'accroche
malheureusement pourrait juste tendre la
main on serait on serait
rassuré il all en
C5 un choix tout à fait raisonnable
aussi avec H5 G6
son un petit peu pourquoi pas al
peut-être ton coup H5 ou A4 pour prendre
encore un peu plus
d'espace
pour G6
solide attaque le7 un coup comme tour
bd8 pour le protéger
ou l'autre bien
sûrite possible
aussi
tour3 tour G3 dans le chat j'imagine un
peu avant mais c'était pas dans tous les
cas H5 G6 c'est
solide voà çait juste faire
nul qu'on serait déçu dev voir un autre
résultat si proche du but partie bien
tenue de part et d'autre un bon niveau
de jeu sur ces 20 premiers
coups
on est tout proche nouvel
aragedon de la chance on dépasserait de
nouveau les 6 he de
jeu 6 he de
bonheur comme dirait Vlad dit une phrase
qui beaucoup plu une fois ils ont réussi
à faire jouer les gens rapides plus
longtemps qu'en partie longue
et c'est pas
faux fine
observation c'est la contre la vraie
dimension sportive he du jeu
ouais iment des capacités de la
résistance demandé au
joueurs
exceptionnel plus le CO2 qui est
augmenté ça devient un peu comme des
étapes de montagne là c'est le moment où
les conditions sont
difficiles
prend des v prend B3 il prend des cases
au cavalier B6 il veut faire sûrement
fou B2 et T1 pour liquider le plus
possible ou fou D2 et T et D1 pour
ensuite rebouger ce fou D2 probablement
C1 très bien géré pour l'instant avec
cette partie pas du en
difficulté il fait à
4 redéplo en
C2 se libère la case 3 pour sortir son
fou ou peut-être même aller jusqu'à
G5 je
pens6
il n demande l'âge d'Abd il est encore
tout jeune il do avoir je sais pas 18
ans à peu près
ouais il y a beaucoup de jeunes prodiges
maintenant et lui il a son collègue
sindarof bon il y a tous les Indiens et
le petit ch
voilà il y a une quantité
industrielle jouir qui arrive de plus en
plus fort de plus en plus
jeune sont impressionnant et demain il
faudra se farcir Carlsen h Carlsen qui
sera un petit peu plus frais avec ses
adversaires il a pas eu d'armadon hier
ah si il a eu Armon hier qui était un
peu moins frais aujourd'hui mais bon
comme C contre le même adversaire ça ne
s'est pas ressenti et là Carlsen qui a
pu rentrer tranquillement c'est un bon
repas ou à l'hôtel que sais-je pendant
que voilà Westley et nordbec ususe
encore de
l'influxjà qui seront pas favoris contre
le
Norvégien mais voilà un peu comme rolong
Garos prime à ceux qui gagnent plus en 3
7-0 plutôt que des matchs en 57 qui d et
ça pèse dans les jambes à la fin mais
encore faut-il savoir gagner vite
complètement
Fabien en tout cas quelle belle journée
d'échec encore une fois
extraordinaire
qui monte sans
roi tours assez égal
mais comme vous voyez les deux joueurs
pour
l'instant pas la nulle tout de suite et
ils vont essayer de se poser des
problèmes l'un l'autre essayer de faire
craquer
l'adversaire le CAL qui revient
C4 j'ai pas trop de plan encore hein
pour les blancs pour essayer de craquer
la la noix qui a cette position noir non
mais nadbec il essae vraiment à fond à
chaque fois
il veut vraiment nous enlever le nous
TER le pain de la
bouche on nime pas ça nous on aime bien
s'il y a du
pain il est là quoi
lui t'intercepte quoiis
c'est alors B il sympa quoi il veut
juste échanger ton cavalier il veut plus
rien voir s C chiqu
ouais être n jouer plus de coup pour
vraiment aller le plus loin possible
dans le
tempsz il a clou le cavalier fou ça
défend
attention4 à nouveau en
l'air
parce que vois qu'il reste plus que 2
minutes 40 chacun donc ça veut dire
qu'il y a beaucoup de temps qui a été
dépensé il fallait bien réfléchir quand
même ah peut-être peut-être
peut-être je crois qu'il a envie de
faire C4 C5 et peut-être se faire une
route pour le roi jusqu'à B5 et essayer
d'ataquer ce pion à4 s'est un petit peu
désolidarisé du reste de ces de ces
pions alors il y a eu B5 jouer
euh je m'attendais à C4 plutôt
euh F5 joué par Westley d'accord C4
peut-être B6 hein
ouaisoutenir oui après c'est bien parce
que c'est une partie qui peut faire
beaucoup de coup une nouvelle
fois ah il est parti en la il veut bien
lui laisser faire
C5 bon pourquoi s'en priv en même temps
côté blanc mais c'est vrai qu'il se dit
bah j'enlève mon fou ma tour défend le
pion tout va
bien le rythmeentre les parties turtal
mais ça permet au joueur de récupérer
c'est la condition C on a un gros niveau
de jeu après voilà il y a le choix c'est
vrai
que ça pourrait enchaîner plus mais il
pourrait y avoir peut-être des des
gaffes des choses qu'on a pas l'habitude
de voir ici quoi
ouais là bon on donne vraiment au joueur
toutes les cartes les clés pour nous
offrir du le meilleur des
spectacles
on voit quoive que cette fou cette
énergie que dou satf il tentein il
ramène son roi vers le pion à 4 qu' a
bien identifié comme étant
potentiellement
faible pas mal joué ce coup qui peut lui
bien la casse pour la tour à4 d'ailleurs
une petite pression
latérale ah il veut nous TER le pain de
la bouche ou alors il veut faire une
partie très longue comme je le disais
estce que on peut espérer que
l'armagedon ne débute qu'à minuit
maintenant h oui parce quand même une
pause après cette partie pour bien
laisser les joueurs faire leurs enchères
répondre aux interviews puis peut-être
un peu quand même se reposer dans
l'horloge j'imagine qu'ils ont non je
sais pas où dans le salon peut-être
c'est déshydraté manger un petit peu
éviter la fringale serait dommage si
proche de de la
fin
des pièges ici ou là coup comme tour à 4
qui envie de jouer il y aur peut-être
C6 colonne C pour la tour car sur B6 il
pourra y avoir fou pran et le pion c'est
qui file attention attention et
malheureusement c'était pas comme ça
pour les final finales de la B Cup
malheureusement ça allit un peu trop
vite la B Cup ça enchaîner c'est un des
points faibles du
tournoi on a la salle que un
jour on est obligé d'enchaîner les
matchs ça passe trop vite
c'estra tu as pas tu as pas les mêmes
budgets que que ce tournoi tu peux pas
et oui si on av sur jours projet aussi
ambitieux en terme de de de format et de
et c'est pour ça qu'on est obligé de
faire un peu comme un un peu comme le
fast food enchaîner les parties comme
ça c'est pas par choix
aprèsaînement qui
sec bon c'estme F foot de qualité j'ai
envie de dire mais quand même
ou tu sens un peu sec pas de sauce donc
là qui a mis ses pièces de manière
optimal qui pense pas pouvoir améliorer
quoi que ce soit qui répète qui fait roi
des 7 re qui donande à son adversaire
d'essayer de progresser dans la
position c'est difficile pour les blancs
il fait TBER hein est-ce qu'il veut
partir de l'autre côté je ne sais
où encore une rupture avec un G4 avec
une tour en F1 qui vudrait
rentrer le roi fait bonne garde quand
même il revient en B3 russiss TR B1 et
c'est nul ça répété ah tu vois
finalement il a joué mais pour aller
vraiment au bout du bout donc 23h44 et
oui on pourrait ne pas commencer l'ARM
magadon avant minuit donc on va se
retrouver vraiment pour cette partie
vraiment décisive la dernière de la
journée on aura le deuxè finaliste on
rappelle c'est Carl de l'autre
côté Onra une finale de rêve quel que
soit le vainqueur n sera peut-être un
petit peu pour sa notre chouchou notre
chouchou oua mais mais voilà je vous dis
on se retrouve très prochainement regard
wesle comm il est content
d'être il a atteint son objectif c'est
fantastique et bien à tout de
suite quel est le meilleur moyen de
suivre n'importe quel événement échikien
Surpat du monde au tournois des
candidats en passant par le speechess ou
les title today
chess.com/events couvre tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables base retrouvez
toutes les infos essentielles comme le
programme les horaires des rondes les
prix les résultats les contre rendus
quotidien les bios des joueurs les
règles des partag et plus encore vous
pouvez même participer à la compétition
en pronostiquant les résultats pour
tenter de gagner des abonnements premium
alors rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/events aussi bien sur le site
internet que sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour vivre votre passion comme
nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
[Rires]
et c'est Nord qui va les noir
ouais avec 9 minutes
19 qui en chéri plus bas que Westley qui
avait mis 9 28 il me
semble deux joueurs qui semblaient avoir
envie d'avoir les
noir mais à quel
prix
ben du coup le prix c'est un peu peu
moins de 6 minutes
mais donc qui va avir les blancs alors
qu'est-ce que tu t'attends à quoi comme
premier coup j'ai plus d'idée là plus
d'idée sachant que a quand même peut
tout jouer on sent qu'il va peut-être
plutôt jouer E4 mais euh écoute peut
s'attendre à tout il nous a fait quand
même B3 tout à l'heureou surprenant mais
bon on peut avoir une Anglaise on peut
avoir un petit
D4 pourquoi pas un
riti je cache pas que là je suis un peu
comme les joueurs hein nous on a un tout
petit peu moins de pause puis qu'on doit
vérifier un petit peu tout mais malure
c'est peut-être ça qui fait qu'on peu
fatig Mo sur le qui vive
6h de Live après c'est passionnant donc
forcément on est encore là mais mais
l'énergie se fait
moindre le sommeil commence à être
présent on fera une belle nuit
après avec les yeux pleins d'étoiles
avec toutes les belles parties qu'on a
vu aujourd'hui et surtout l'espoir d'un
beau match demain ah ça c'est garanti
hein demain après-demain on va encore se
régaler
euh avec deux beaux matchs en
perspective peut-être encore des
armesageddon 1 2 peut-être TR à venir
dans la finale
euh
donc bien sûr on va pas bouder notre
plaisir peut-être je vois des ombre se
mouvoir mais est-ce que c'est de
scèneffet de scène les gens ne sont pas
encore là non il faut bien attendre faut
bien qu'il se repose quand
même ilose un petit peu moins que ce qu'
joue pourra réclamer d'avoir le droit au
même temps de pause que la partie
précédente
pour baisser en température cerveau
avoir des pauses quasiment aussi long
que les
parties
non vrai même pour les joueurs ça être
interminable quo
oui des fois tu as envie de ouais tuuras
marre
bon c'est vrai que je je me questionne
de pourquoi les gens ne reviennent pas
surtout que même sur le live en anglais
on a vu les enchères donc je vous dis
hein westleake avait enchéri 928 il me
semble 919 c'est ça
ouais don comme je te disais j'avais une
idée une variante moi de de ces en
chères c'est que tu dois jouer avec le
temps que tu as
mis ça
CP tiit très bas là du coup Westley bah
il jou avec 928 avec l'obligation de
gagner contre
919 du coup tu tu dis combien de temps
genre c'est 5 minutes
l'enchère maximal
tu prend pas de risque tu mets 5 puis
bon B l' tu met 4 459 bravo mais tu veux
quand même les noirs et qui va à 4 enfin
on sait
pas r C'est tricky mais tu vois c'est
c'est un nouveau jeu encore plus
de et je pense pour vraiment bon le CL
du spectacle dev chérir devant la caméra
pour dire ce qu'il pensent que l'ARE va
dire leur stratégie d'enchè pourquoi
pourquoi ne pas carrément enlever la
partie desche
après pron si le but c'est juste le plus
bas possible tu mets zé ah d'accord
c'est pour ouis quand même il se passe
un truc mais je pense que quand même tu
devrais peut-être avoir
un un quart de points peut-être pour
avir gagner l'enchère déjà dans ton
classement déjà quoi tu tu tu marques un
peu des points parce que tu as
ou alors peut-être allez on va
complexifier un peu les règles qui m'ont
l'air bien simples euh tu dois dire
quelle couleur tu veux avec ton enchère
et si ça tombe juste tu marques si
l'autre voulait aussi c'est équilibre
chacun a quand même remporté fait
réalisé son
objectif par contre si tu te fais avoir
là ça te coûte ça te coûte pour te
mettre du
malus belle idée
Fabien se soumettre peut-être à Dani
quoi un moyen peut-être qui nous
permettra de meubler donc c'est posé
chquen mais par cet autre jeu tout aussi
intéressant à mon
avis on calulé ça finira à minuit au
plus tard mais en fait on avait été
négatif
hein non non ben oui c'était bien
mal bien mal je sais pas mais mais bien
mal
quoi
propose encore autre chose faut êre le
plus bas possible mais si tu as à moins
de 90 % de l'autre tu
perds ouais c'est beau c'est beau c'est
beau voilà il faut fa raffiner ces idées
là
et vraiment je pense une
compétion
exquise alors je vois le caméraman
preneur de son je sais pas trop qui qui
est là non ou voyez qui vérifie que la
pendule est bien branchée bien accroché
bien solide sur ses appuis parce que ça
peut cogner fort sur sur les boutons
faudrait pas que la pendule tombe par
terre non plus à un moment si important
on parle quand même d'une qualification
pour la finale du champion che tour
2023 ce n'est pas rien on rappelle hein
il y a quand même 50000 € minimum à la
clé sur cette partie et oui 50 K c'est
que le perdant je crois la coquette
somme de 50000 € dollars pardon ce qui
est déjà bon
sympathique mais le finaliste va déjà
empocher 100000 et le vainqueur
200000 donc voilà les joueurs qui ne
doivent pas trembler avec de tels enjeux
sur une seule partie je veux dire
n'est-ce pas un peu court peut-être pour
une telle somme peut-être onit trouver
un autre moyen de départager les
joueursêre des multiplesarmagon qu
armagadon enfin oui déjà 4 ouais après
en cas
[Rires]
d'éalité
al
VO Wesley aussi qui a pris s petites
bouteill parce comm on l'a déjà vu peu
d'humidité dans la pièce donc il ne fait
pas l'erreur d'oublier sa bouteille il
est pr à sidrater alors que N n'a pas de
bouteille peut-être une erreur un peu de
de
jeunesse on saura plus dans une
vingtaine trentaine de minutes maximum
maintenant les joueurs qui à dou qui
replacent leurs pièces noublie pas de se
désaltérer voilà avant même le premier
coup il en boit pas trop il garde quand
même une quantité raisonnable d'eau pour
pour bien la répartir tout au long de
l'effort et de la
partie et les gens se salut et c'est
parti et c'est une
Anglaise extraordinaire Fabien ce début
de partie et ça pourrait tomber dans une
catalane éventuellement
c'est 5 qui empêche un peu on s'attend
un petit rock quand même il prend puis
on prend petit rock et si on joue avec
des4 é Clement ça transforme dans une
Tarche
pourrait ressembler à une attaque pasof
à couleur inversée AV avec G6 alors
là une position intéressante pour les
blanc pour jouer pas complètement il pe
un pion isolé en chez l'adversaire mais
ça joue vite he chez N connait bien ce
qu'il fait wesle qui prend C5 le fou qui
reprend se déplace pour la seconde fois
A3 il en de faire B4 et fou B2
j'imagine j'aime beaucoup la position
qu'il a obtenue avec les Blancs
westleyy tranquille notre chouchou he je
le rappelle on espère allez réfléchis
bien des becc mettoi mal au temp il y a
pas de plus 3 secondes hein jusqu'au 60e
au 60e il y en aura qu'une de secondes
donc là les le temps perdu se paye
cash après j'ai peur parce qu'il a remis
il a de nouveau sa veste Puma
i qu'il est efficace avec cette veste
mais bon W là aussi il a son
blazer chemise bleue dessous aujourd'hui
H6 un coup un peu mou un peu mou qui tra
du Fou G5 mais le fou ne devenait pas
vers G5 de toute façon voilà ça y est
qui le
pose et puis on peut bien penser après
un plan avec D2 k B3 qui rebondit qui aa
des cases à 5 C5 D4 il va être bien ou
et ça fait déjà une minute de dépenser
pour
nierbeck on voit qui est beaucoup moins
gêné par l'éclairage qui met pas sa main
ouais pour se cacher sur une lampe c'est
pour ça qu'il voulait les blancs en fait
pour du bon côté du bon côté de la de la
lampe 5 jouet donc il une pression sur
B4 B5 défendre le
pionfendre trouver comment mérit de voir
Wesley son les de
domin cette phase barrage de seconde de
3è je pense que sur l'ensemble du tourno
c'est Wesley Magnus qui mérite de se
retrouver face à face Fabien en finale
pour
s'expliquer est-ce que Puma peut faire
peur au chat de saut ça peut ouais mais
aussi il peut il peut penser que c'est
un c'est un ami autre chat
ouaisou une très belle vidéo d'un Charat
rou qui était comme ça avec deux
tigres euh qui était très heureux de
voir le le petit charatou quoi tu aura
été heureux de voir les tigres aussi é
non ça va en fait chat
deis beaucoup ce design et
logo
sponsorvénement doiton le le
rappeler de très belles
marquesate
encore évidemment
pas mal joué ce qu'il fait en tout
cas le
C4 la contrepartie un peu cette poussée
du pion B qui a faibli les
cases colon adjacent cette case C4 qui
va s'allumer pour le
cavalier qu' si c'est demain la finale
on le répète la finale la grande finale
tant attendue sera déjà ce soir pour
nous Français et oui oui puison a passé
minuit à peine
17h50es notez bien
l'horaire dans votre calendrier mettez
vos réveils pour ne surtout pas rater un
seul gram de cette finale avec Magnus
Carl qui sera là face à
qui on le SAA dans moins d'une vingtaine
de minutes
maintenant qui joue changer ce cavalier
en4 j'imagine qu'il veut garder le fou
sur la diagonale
ça peut-être en D4 ça pourrait coûter le
pion
à3
parti début de partie difficile pour
Wesley
poussif bien ce qu'il fait au
début maîtrise bien cette position bien
connaître les plans les tenant les
aboutissant mais bon jeand Mme bien
jouer F4 tant
pis que pour pour à
je pense qu'il est un peu obligé don la
paire de fou ser quand même on fera
grismine le caver advers pr viendra en
E4 le 4 FO 3 en plus on pe peut-être
faire cavalier E5 oui prend à voilà et
puis du dame B3 qui peut arriver de la
tour en d1re de la case B6 qui qui sera
là non on y croit toujours on y croit
toujours Puma devait
s'imposer ce serait la
vie donc au joueur Beek réfléchir
maintenant de voir sil prend pion à3 a
si si peut-être il se développe avec un
coup comme fou F5 peut-être que
sais-je7 dame B3 B3 sûrement
oui
jou assez vite par
Westley une belle avance à la pendule
pourra l'utiliser à bon pour
réfléchir qu sentira le moment clé
arrivriver je pense qu' par FD peutre un
coup comme cavalier E5 ouais je pense
jeance 7 minutes pour ça passe vite ça
vite on a jou que 16
coup il a encore encore 44 coups
ça y est il s'est mis à accélérer
Wesley son setup placement de pièce
6-être pas très inspiré de passer par
par la caisse
D7 il a donné ce dame B3
finalement on prend j'ai envie de dire
c'est pas une mauvaise
case libér la case D1 pour la tour
donc pourquoi pas et donc 5 je trouve ça
intéressant qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
faire
d'autre que nous propose l'ordi il nous
propose cavalier e 5
hein il hésite westy pour le moment il
fait B2 coup intéressant qui veut aussi
échanger ce cavalier C4 et je pense
serait content de mettre la dame en B2
pour faire une
batterie direction du roi adverse et de
ce pion
G7 c'est bien
joué intéressant de sa
part
bien qui kick bien pour le moment en
rythme non mais il assz à l'aise dans
cette position ça va il joue pas à côté
il il connaî les plans mais West c'est
intéressant ce qu'il fait aussi parti
voilà partie équilibré comme bah comme
tout ce match au
final qui qui du coup se décide ce
nouvelle arm
gedon AA pas vraiment pu en être
autrement j'ai l'impression sont quand
même tellement les deux joueurs sont
proches
similaire mais qui reparti avec son cant
D6 peut qu' V aller vers F5 chasser fou
D4 quand même rayonnant au milieu de les
chiqu D3
alors qu'en B2 il fait grism en B3 il
revient vers le centre sur F5 tu te
relibérer la
B2 qui je chic Chac aprs à voir sior
aurait un coup comme D4 ouvrant le fou
E6 don la C C3 pe-être pour l'utre
cavalier donc je de calculer tout
çaon pe avoir des vis-àis un peu de part
et d'autrre C tour en D1 face à la dame
D8 le F 6 face à la dame
B3 on
pourrait ça réfléchit ça
calcule il a joué à 4 il a joué à 4 qui
F5 comme attendu peut-être qu' ve pas
bouger le cavalier alors
il va rien bouger du tout peut-être
tourac1 un coup comme
ça qui D3 aussi hein pourquoi pas voilà
c'est joué
d'ailleurs nous aussi on peut aller vers
F4
ouais que se passe-il sur nul serait les
noirs qui
gagnerurai donc il reste 40 coups à
jouer hein pour nandierbeck avant
d'arriver à se rajoute de plus une
seconde et encore 5 minutes 13
une petite avance à la pendule quand
même qui font un petit peu mais ça va
pas complètement il a une position qui
joue donc je pense que et l'un et
l'autre PEV être satisfait de de ce qui
se passe pour
l'instantass
chouchou qui met la pression ah j'espère
qu'il va tenter le tout pour le tout
jusqu'au bout
hein 440 hein ça commence quand même
souvent hein c'est
graine tu as le temps tu as le temps
puis un moment ouais c'est tu prends 30
secondes par cou ça va hyper vite en
fait dame D6 jouer donc il lit ses tours
c'est très bien peut-être dame à 3
h il tu juste fou B2 il veut pas il veut
pas Laer D4 c'est ça
j'imagine des4 sera un petit peu
pénible 5 pas dama à
3 B6 bien attaquer le pion f2u par le3
mais une pression par là-bas fa dame B2
oui pourquoi
pas para logique comme coup B2 a
toujours ce fameux coup E4 qui est r
dans la position en plus de C3 par la
suite donc d B2 on se de tout ça une
pression sur la grande diagonale j'aime
bien et puis peut-être 3 et
D4
j un tout petit peu
accélérer pression la pendule en plus
il a réussi à garder beaucoup de pièces
quand même he qui se réajust sur sa
chaise de boire une petite goutte
peut-être aussi là pour êre à l'affu
pour ces dernières minutes qu'on voit
que l'humidité s'est pas tellement
amélioré hein
donc direb qui va devoir jouer là c'est
sous les 4
minutes mais c'est pas facile parce que
wesle maintient la une position qui joue
sans faire de grandes menaces ou quoi
mais G4 là oui peut-être c'est une
position voilà tu as pas d'égalité
facile il retend qu' une minute là il t
entre 30 secondes et une minutes sur
chaque série de deux trois coups à
chaque
décision mais je peux l'entendre c'est
vraiment des décisions qui qui valent
cher au sens
propre pas que comme l'expression le dit
c'est on rappelle 50000 la différence
entre entre nul une défaite pour luiette
partie donc il jouer F F6 pour
neutraliser cette grande diagonale et
Wesley qui boit voilà bravo Wesley qui
sait que c'est le moment de bien se
réhydrater laisser le cerveau à l'affu
pour trouver les B là il y a un problème
sur fou prend cavalier prend il y a
cavalier F4
peut-être coup naturel tout ça on
commence à taper fort probablement c'est
ce qui va enchaîner de toute
façon al dit que j'aurais même GF mais
ce sera pas jouer ah ça pourrait mais je
pense pas mais ça pourrait parce que
c'est relativement thématique dans C
dans cette arrache ENF ici ou là quoi
tu vas faire E3 cavalier
F4 pris du
cavalier donc F4 j'imagine quand même
fort naturel comme coup et ben il en
fait un autre il fait D2 pourquoi pas il
veut pasevoir l'autre cavalier en E4
revenir il va aller vers B3 c'est pas le
choix numéro 1 de l'ordi mais c'est pas
non plus une faute c'est un coup qui
fait vraiment
réfléchir maintenant cavalier
F4 regarder ce qu'il a sur G5 G5 le C de
sûrement ouais puis y a le cavalier F6
qui reste en prise derrière
aussi
si si cavalier F4 marche et c'est
jouer c'est joué il a toujours son
avance à la pendule qui maintenant
commence à être importante en fait bien
sûr elle est beaucoup plus courte que ce
qu'elle était au début de la partie
maistionnellement
voilà si peu de temps en face mais bon
alors qui clique vite dans ces moment là
est-ce qu'on pourra rebouger le C ver B3
F3 quelque part B3 al dit aime bien mais
parce que tu échang tout en fait tu vas
juste gagner D5 en force hein parce qu'
serait déjà sil avance en fait la
question c'est qu'il a B3 qui prend tour
pr T prendc1 et
D4 partie vers F1 c'est pas mal aussi je
pense il veut aller vers vers E3 et on
attaque donc ce qui a
D4 et là ça va être dur pour pour
noirbeck il va sûement il changer les
tours déjà enlever cette tour d' qui
attaque ce k
D4 c'est qui sidrate au meilleur des
moments il prend d'ailleurs souffler un
petit peu je penseil va prendre vite
westle la tour
ok c'est fait pass sous les de 30
nierbeckfin qui va bondir le3 au
prochain coup probablement mettre une
nouvelle pression sur ce des tourd1
aussi he qui peut revenir
et plus que de 18 pour
nierbeck et on VO regarde le siège
nordierbec qui bougele est tranquillou
ouais ça veut dire qu'il doit bouger les
pieds
en
rythme regardé sa
pendule que c'est important aler
NF a pas de
temps
minutes pas de
tempun
temp que là il commence à rentrer peu
comme Fabiano tout à l'heure dans le
moment où tu as vraiment peu de temps
stressant c'est comme
ça il va rentrer le truc il doit jouer
un coup toutes les 3 secondes
c'est pas beaucoup en
faitp c'est encore plus dur qu'as pas de
PR pas et puis même c'est plus long de
bouger les pièces que de
CC là il rentre vraiment dans le
[Musique]
moment 3 sour des des de les de sont B
d'ailleurs qui boit au meilleur des
moment il s'hydrate le chat C 3 tempo
évidemment ou ousbec les uzbc ça clique
hein 31 j'imagine att cavier D5 ça
s'appelle un punto ça va attaquer quand
même quatre fois le pon des5 hein deux
cavaliers en fout une
tour et puis du coup comme il est mal
c'est plus dur de clic
encore il pe chercher ce pion s'il veut
ouais de deux manières différentes mais
il va directement comme ça c'est très
bien attaque la dame sur la route fou
prend cavalier prend on imagine ouais
cavalier reprend fou prend
ou tour je ne sais
pas tu gagnes un peu le BF de menacer F
pr F7 au
passage ah non tu
pasg pour l'instant peut-être t reprend
mais fait F prend j'aurais fait F prend
aussi su par dame B3 de toute façon fou
B3 quoi qu'il en soit on c pas un
clouage par ici on peut faire fou
B3
Dam
d B3 d 5 aussi c'est des coups B3
peut-être F
B3 qui joue très très vite maintenant il
a plus trop le temps de
traîner bug C5 cou comme ça je sais pas
trop on a ce problème GT
qui qui arrive au meilleur des moments
a buggé sûr qu'il l'a pas joué là pour
pas voir la fin de la partie mesdames et
messieurs on suis un peu à la cams comme
on peut alors ils essayent de réparer je
vais voir si ça ça
marche mais ça y est on a récupéré le
DGT les chi la position est normale 4
minutes pour wesle alors il a pas besoin
de jouer trop tempo il a une position
qui peut travailler au aux échecs nor m
j'ai envie de dire sans jouer pour faire
tomber al faut pas s'endormir dans ces
cas-là mais voilàut pas s'emballer à
juste vouloir faire tomber
l'adversaire 23 CJ en 47 secondes il va
y arriver à priori mais en faant
peut-être des erreurs ici ou là donc
faut pas faut pas gâcher
quoi d D4 dame prend je pense que la
finale est pas terrible
non je suis pas sûr qu'il a gagne en
fait s avait pas temps il va faire dame
à 8 pere ramener le fou sur la grande
diagonale puis aller en C6 avec le fou
avec une d en
B7
B73 C6 peut-être un plan comme ça
répète sur dame prend B6 ça juste été
raté non priori dame 4 F3 juste puis
dame
D4
ouais c'est choses faites et là
maintenant dame D4 le pion passé ça
change tout absolument réussi à jouer il
avait créé l'expoir de jouer si
vite il a encore une microscopique
chance j'ai l'impression que dame C4 va
faire mal parce que dame B2 dame C2 qui
couvre tout allez reste 13 coup 22
secondes et dame B2 ro H3 encore pire
peut-être que tu as pas d'échec ça
menace dame F7 hm
hm badbe qui a encore une douzaine de
coup à jouer m G6 bon ben c'est
peut-être le mond d' en le
passé P qui va aller jusqu'en B7 et il
va être soutenu par la dame PR6
peut-être même ouais et B8 pour une
autre
dame qui a remis ses lunettes pour faire
dam press 6 il a mis ses lunettes il les
enlevé il fait dam proc 6 et il a
gagné finale de
rêve AC ces deux journées là nous ont
finalement donné les résultats attendus
entre le le VUR voilà mais vraiment
match en plus les 3è et les 4e en fait
il y a
eu aucune surprise mais on s'est bien
délecté toute cette journée j'espère
vous aussi
euh donc on se retrouve demain 18h avec
la finale de rêve entre vraiment les
deux joueurs les plus en forme de de
cette compétition qui ont qui ont dominé
qui ont dominé outrageusement qui on
montré une grand un grand niveau de jeu
on en VO un Raed vers la chaîne
officielle vite vite vite sans perdre de
temps
pour interview et on se retrouve demain
ciao ciao